Vielen Dank. Das war's. Die Freak Show. Deutschland hat auch gewonnen, hab ich gerade gesehen. Insofern alles super. Das war uns ein Fest. Genau. Viel Spaß auf eurem Tinder Date.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zur Pressekonferenz nach der Freak Show 195. Mit mir aus unerfüllten Gründen der Cheftrainer des 1. FC Union Berlin, Jens Keller. Jens, deine Einschätzung zur Sendung.
Ich glaube, kann sich jeder vorstellen, dass wir sehr enttäuscht sind.
Enttäuscht?
Wir sind natürlich enttäuscht. Wir haben uns was ganz anderes vorgenommen. Aber jetzt zählt es, die Mannschaft mit der, das zu analysieren, drüber zu sprechen, an was liegt. Die Leichtigkeit fehlt uns ein bisschen. Die müssen wir schnellstens wieder rein bekommen.
Das klingt ja nach einem richtigen Dämpfer.
Ja, klar ist das ein Dämpfer. Aber so wie wir heute aufgetreten sind, ist es einfach nicht die Mannschaft, die wir kennen. Wir haben heute nicht annähernd die Leistung gebracht, die die Mannschaft in der Lage ist. Wir haben Fehler gemacht, die ich so noch nicht kannte.
Wie empfandest du Tim am heutigen Tag?
Sehr unaufmerksam und das ist natürlich unheimlich ärgerlich.
Okay, was ist mit Roddy?
Auch mit dem müssen wir leben und werden weiter dran arbeiten.
Dennis war gar nicht da, war ja vielleicht angeschlagen.
Nein, er war nicht angeschlagen, aber er war lange verletzt. Man hat gesehen, ihm fehlt auch die Frische. Und deshalb haben wir ihn runtergenommen.
Und wie war ich so als Pressesprecher?
Sie haben enorme Qualität.
Neue Mannschaftsaufstellung. Das ist ja wieder ein dickes Thema heute und da müssen wir auch gleich mal nachlegen. Aufstellung auf der Nummer eins, zu Thim. Ja, der Idiot nennt sich immer selbst zuerst. Nummer zwei, unser Libero, Roddy.
Ja, damit müsst ihr leben.
Damit müssen wir leben.
Im Mittelfeld Huckel.
Die Blutgrätsche.
Flankengott.
Blutgrätschen, Huckel. Und im Sturm, die Letty.
Wenigstens nicht im fucking Tor, da musste ich immer als Kind stehen.
Ich war ja Torwart, und ich bin es immer noch in gewisser Hinsicht. Tatsächlich passt das auch ganz gut zu meiner Rolle hier.
Du hältst den Kasten sauber.
Und wenn es halt vorne nicht so läuft, dann muss man halt auch mal eingreifen.
Muss man den Kahn machen. Oder wie war diese Ansage von Kahn mit den Eiern, wir brauchen Eier oder so?
Ossereier. Ossereier, wir brauchen Ossereier. Ja, haben wir auch bekommen, nicht unbedingt jetzt in der typischen Darreichungsform, aber wir sind absurd mit Süßigkeiten überhäuft worden. Unter anderem von Georg aus Zürich und Benedikt, ich glaube aus Österreich, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe. Ach nee, das ist nur eine Postkarte hier. Das weiß ich gar nicht, wer, oh Gott, ich immer wieder mit meiner Vorbereitung. Tut mir leid, auf jeden Fall gab es noch ein schönes Schokopaket, auch aus Österreich. Und das führt hier schon zu einer extremen Überdosierung. Aber du hast jetzt gefunden, was du gesucht hattest.
Ich mag ja sehr dunkle Schokoladendinge und ich habe hier gerade zu meiner Freude gefunden, feinste dunkle Schokolade. Mit Haseln nur 50. Das ist ein bisschen mau. Aber mit Haseln noch so eine Mandelcreme-Füllung. Also wenn diese Zitronencreme von eben schon nicht genug war, dann hole ich mir jetzt auf jeden Fall die Überdosis.
Wir halten die Adrenalinspritzen schon mal bereit. Wie heißt dieser Schock, bei dem man das einsetzt? Genau, in dem Fall Zuckerschock. Aber wie heißt das, wenn man das falsche Antibiotikum bekommt und dann kriegt man diesen...
Müssen wir jetzt nicht unbedingt ausprobieren, oder?
Das heißt, das aus Pöpfig?
Nein, das geht dann meistens in den Arm und nicht in den Herz.
Ja, so ähnlich.
Ja, ansonsten hatten wir hier schon einige wegweisende technische Diskussionen im Vorfeld. Da wart ihr jetzt alle noch nicht live zugeschaltet.
Wegweisende Techn... habe ich was verpasst?
Ja, in dieser Zürich-Box war ja nicht nur Schoki, sondern...
Weiße Praline Prügeli.
Ich zitiere das hier mal. Also endlich bringe ich mal ein Päckchen nach Berlin, schreibt ja Georg. Vielen Dank für das zweiwöchentliche Welt-Exklairen dem Schweizer Schoki. Schogi, wie spricht man das richtig aus?
Schogi. Ich mach mich jetzt nicht zum Deppen.
Ja, dann muss ich das dann wieder ausputzen. Findet ihr Rex den einzig wahren Sparschäler? Geo, wir müssen reden. Also, zunächst einmal muss ich zugeben, dass der Rex mir bis dahin so noch nicht bekannt war.
Doch, ich kannte den.
Guck mal, den gibt es sogar von WMF.
Ja, ja, diese Bauscharform ist zumindest sehr alt hergebracht.
Also Sparschäler sind ja schon... Also Sparschäler ist ja irgendwie so ein bisschen ein komisches Wort. Sagen wir mal Gemüseschäler. Weil hier geht es ja wohl primär um Gemüse.
Na, ich glaube, es spart deshalb, weil er so dünne Scheiben abschneidet. Du sparst.
Ja, ja, ist mir schon klar. Aber sagen wir mal, es geht im Wesentlichen eigentlich ums Schälen und nicht so sehr ums Sparen.
Aber wenn ich den Preis auf Amazon sehe, geht es auch ums Sparen. 4,95.
4,95 der Rex.
Also von WMF sogar. Was heißt von WMF sogar? Genau diese Form, aber von WMF.
Ach so, haben sie wohl lizenziert oder was? Also das scheint mir hier so ein bisschen das Original zu sein, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Ist hier auch eine Patentnummer drauf? Ne, was ist das hier?
Model?
Ne, nur eine Modelnummer. Sena Swiss. Naja, auf jeden Fall drängte sich dann natürlich sofort die Frage auf, was ist eigentlich die optimale Form für einen Gemüseschäler? Und der Rex geht ja hier ganz klassisch ran mit der, wie soll man das jetzt sagen, mit der Horizontalvariante. Das heißt, man zieht den Schäler quasi mit der Klinge, also das macht man ja eh, aber man hält ihn, wie soll man das beschreiben?
Der Griff ist rechtwinklig zur Klinge angebracht.
Richtig, sehr schön. Roddy, ich seh schon, das Extra-Training hat sich gelohnt.
Das Training-Sager.
Schick dich dann auch noch mal auf ne Runde. Dann ist an der Seite noch so ein kleiner Schnupsi dran, der ja zu dem Aushöhlen von dunklen Stellen und all solchen Sachen bei der Kartoffel etc.
Geht auch beim Apfel?
Gedacht ist, geht auch beim Apfel.
Beim Apfel wird's schwierig.
Du hast dann schon gleich den richtigen Hinweis, dass das ja nicht linkshänderkonform ist, weil hält man ihn in der linken Hand, wie das ja bei Linkshändern verbreitet ist, dann ist quasi die Klinge, also entweder ist die Klinge falsch rum.
Naja, so würde man ihn natürlich nicht halten.
Ja, also wenn sie richtig rum ist, dann ist auf jeden Fall dieser Schnupsi irgendwie innen und das ist irgendwie blöd. Richtig? Genau. Und das bringt uns dann gleich, oder mich zumindest, zur ersten Empfehlung dieser Sendung. Leute, wenn ihr euch schon immer gedacht habt in der Küche, Gemüse schälen, wenn dann richtig.
Rechts unten Gemüse schälen.
Genau, also einfach so maximale Ergonomie. Da ist mir ein Produkt über den Weg gelaufen, was man schwer bekommt in Deutschland, aber man kann das so über französische Kanäle bekommen. Bei Amazon Deutschland habe ich es auch gefunden, aber man kriegt es dann trotzdem aus Frankreich mit extra hohen Lieferkosten, die aber, das sage ich gleich dazu, sich absolut lohnen. Ich rede von nichts weniger als dem Mastrad, Mastrad, sagt man das vielleicht so? Mastrad. Kann man schon am Ende nochmal so andeuten, auch wenn da kein E ist. Elios Gemüseschäler. Den gibt es auch in lustigen Farben und auch in einer Keramikvariante. Und ich verspreche euch, das Gemüseschälen, ihr legt die Kartoffeln einfach nicht mehr aus der Hand. Das ist einfach geil. Und der ist auch komplett linkshänderkompatibel, weil die Klinge doppelt ist und man vorne und zurück und an jeder Hand halten kann.
Und der sieht auch noch fast aus wie ein Sexspielzeug.
Er sagt ja auch fast.
Fast.
Sehr fast, ja.
Mastrad, Elios, Gemüseschäler, das ist euer Einstieg in Technologie des 21. Jahrhunderts, obwohl es das Gerät wahrscheinlich schon seit 30 Jahren gibt. Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Éplucheur Julien.
Aber der Druck, also man merkt ja immer erst, wie sehr man solche Geräte schätzt, wenn man sie verliert oder sie kaputt gehen. In dem Fall handelt es sich um, weiß ich gar nicht, eins von beiden ist passiert, ich glaube, es ist kaputt gegangen aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Und dann musste ich das einfach wieder haben. Also es war einfach nicht erträglich, dieses Produkt nicht im Haus zu haben. Weil alle anderen Shaler, die mir so in die Hand fielen, das haben mich extrem unglücklich gemacht.
Kleiner Hinweis an der Stelle, ich meine, Thim leckt ja gerne an Produkten, das sollte man da wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Naja, also unten ist es schon ganz okay so. Halt oben nicht.
Ich hab ja gerade festgestellt, ich hab gar keinen Sparschäler, sondern einen Pendelschäler. Ist das nicht das Gleiche?
Naja, das Sparschälen sagt ja nur was über das Ergebnis aus und das Pendelschälen sagt was über die Art und Weise des Schälens aus. Und ich würde auch sagen, der Mastrad-Ilios Gemüseschäler ist auch ein Pendelschäler.
Weil ich hab ja vor langer Zeit, als ich mal selber Gemüseschälen sollte und wollte und in meiner, wie sagt man, Einzugs- oder Auszugs, also das, was man so von den Eltern so mitbekommt, wenn man dann das erste Mal...
Die Aussteuer.
Die Aussteuer. Das Gerät, was da enthalten war, hatte mich dann doch eher enttäuscht hinterlassen und dann habe ich mir auch mal einen gekauft und das ist ein Gerät, was ich auch seit zehn Jahren in Betrieb hab und taugt. Allerdings weder wahrscheinlich linkshänder geeignet, noch Sexspielzeug geeignet. Das wäre der WMF-Pendel Schäler 19cm Profi Plus. Falls du den noch mal auf den Schirmen holen möchtest.
Ja, du darfst ihn mal gerne gleich mal in den Chat schmeißen, dann haben wir alle was davon. Denn nur links, die im Chat landen, landen auch in den Tornhauts.
Ich hab meinen Slack noch nicht gebootet, scheiße. Kommt sofort, Metaebene, Freak Show, oh Slack-Duo.
Slackst, ganz schön rum. Ja, ja.
Pause, Wart, Dauer, Wackel. So, hier kommt der Link.
Hast du einen Slack-Lag?
Da hab ich heute auch noch mal eine sehr berechtigte Kritik gelesen zum Thema Slack-Lag. Kriegen wir das später noch unter.
Jetzt kannst du klicken.
Chromargan.
Ah ja.
Teilmantiert.
Der hat erstens auch ein schönes Gewicht, also einen guten Schwerpunkt in der Hand.
Das sind diese WMF-Griffe, die sind schon ganz ordentlich.
Und ist auch zünftig scharf. Also funktioniert auf jeden Fall auch.
Aber die Rauspul-Nase ist auch hier an einer Seite. Das hat den großen Vorteil vom Mastrad-Elias-Elios Gemüseschelan, weil da ist halt der Rausprokler an der Spitze. Und das ist natürlich wirklich... Also pfiffig ist das einfach. Da hat sich jemand wirklich Gedanken gemacht. Wahrscheinlich ist es auch so ein Produkt, wo irgendwie so ein französischer Herr die ganze Erfahrung seines Lebens eingebracht hat in dieses Produkt.
And then you die. Das ist doch wie bei der Ente, wo ja eine Designvorgabe war, ein Sack Kartoffelensäure in den Kofferraum passen. Und das scheint wahrscheinlich so eine urfranzösische Sache, sind halt Kartoffeln und ein ordentlicher Kartoffelschäler gehört da eben auch dazu.
Ja und die Franzosen haben auch das gute Opinel, glaube ich. Womit sich auch Kunstguts schälen lässt. Es ist natürlich ein Messer und jetzt hatten die so fancy Dinge. Es ist halt ein Messer mit Nackte.
Ja, aber mit einem normalen Messer schälen, das muss man schon können. Also ich kann das nicht so gut.
Du hast doch die Apple Watch, die dich dann beschützt, das hatten wir doch gerade.
Ja, das Metallarmband.
Du willst mir sagen, du hast ein Opinel in deiner Küche und damit schälst du deinen Spargel?
Das stimmt so nicht, das Opinel ist immer in der Tasche. Das hab ich eigentlich immer dabei.
Du hast immer ein Klappmesser in der Tasche?
Nee, wer hat sowas in der Tasche? Ja, ich hab das meistens dabei. Zum Stiftespitzen vor allem. Es ist sehr praktisch, immer dabei zu haben. Aber für zu Hause nutze ich dann doch eher...
Konventionelle Waffen.
Wie so ein Zwilling, genau. Ist auch, wenn man es in einer längeren Variante kauft, vielleicht als Sexbrillzeug geeignet, um nochmal den Vergleich von Ockel wieder aufzubringen.
Jetzt wird es auf jeden Fall wild.
Also irgendwie bin ich hier falsch heute.
Die Gelegenheiten zum Themenwechsel drängen sich geradezu auf. Nach all den ganzen Süßspeisen muss ich jetzt auch nochmal sagen, du meintest ja vorhin Ayran. Also als Konterbier zum Süßspeisenexzess.
Ja.
Als Hangoverbekämpfer. Es gibt nichts besseres als Ayran.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das so auf dem...
Ich hatte so lange schon keinen Hangover mehr.
Auf dem Magen dann vertragen würde nach einem Hangover.
Aber, ja.
Aber ich bitte dich, Mango. Ayran, Mango. Nee, das geht einfach mal gar nicht.
Also süß salzig ist so eine Kombination, die kann ich also auch nur schwer ab.
Aber isst ihr nicht manchmal so Schokolade mit Salzzeug?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Nein, so diese Knusperflocken im Ayran.
Ich muss sagen, ich halte dieses Ayran getränkt. Das ist für mich immer eine wahre Freude, dass es das hier so mannigfaltig im Angebot gibt. Weil das ist einfach mal eine der wenigen Produkte, die man so in so Läden, in so Imbissläden bekommt, die noch so eine Ua... Er kullert langsam in Richtung Linie. Es ist einfach so ein grundlegendes Ding. Es ist einfach so ein Joghurtgetränk mit Salz und nicht irgendeine Zuckerscheiße. Fanta, Cola, Spreit... Du kriegst fast nur Dreck, wenn du in so einem Versorgungsort einfach nur mal was Gesundes trinken willst.
Wasser, könnte ich empfehlen.
Ja, Wasser. Aber ich meine Wasser aus Flaschen in Deutschland.
Aber gut, diese Versorgungsorte, wo es dann meistens Döner gibt und gesund, ist jetzt vielleicht auch in einem Satz schwierig.
Bio-Döner, ich wohne ja in Pretzlauberg.
Ja, haben die keine Bio-Nade oder keinen Bio-Zisch im Angebot?
Doch, bestimmt auch, aber ich bin auch nicht so ein Kohlensäure-Freund.
Aber was ist denn jetzt deine Kritik an meinem Mango-Eiran?
Dass ich einfach finde, dass einfach ein Mango-Eiran ist im Vergleich zu einem normalen Eiran, das ist einfach eine...
Frevel?
Gotteslästerung.
Ja, genau.
Okay, da ich Gotteslästerung jetzt nicht so schlimm finde. Ich weiß nicht, jemand schrieb gerade Mangolasi im Chat, das fand ich vorher mal richtig geil, aber es war mir irgendwann zu süß und dieses Mango-Eiran, der so ein bisschen salzig ist und aber trotzdem noch diesen etwas süßeren Mango-Geschmack hat.
Das ist so die türkisch-indische Brücke.
Ja, ich mein, Eiran ist mir auch schon so ein bisschen, gehört so zu Berlin so dazu, wie so ein Döner halt. Hast du denn diesen Mango-Baum vor deinem Studio noch nicht entdeckt? Nee? Ja, aber ich finde das ist schon lecker. Also den mit Kirsch finde ich so okay. Also den finde ich nicht so nett. Aber falls du es nicht weißt, den gibt es auch in Kirsch.
Was? Nein, es gibt Kirsch-Eiran.
Wir gehen mal zum Späti.
Was kommt als nächstes? Mit Fanta-Geschmack?
Nee, mit Schokoladengeschmack. Oh, das wäre schon ein bisschen wieder geil.
Aber was ist denn da noch Iran dran? Also ich meine, der abgepackte Iran ist ja im Prinzip schon so schwierig. Ja, also das ist ja schon ein Iran, aber so ein richtiger Iran, der hat ja noch Gurke drin.
Echt? Ich dachte, Gurke gehört nur so in Cocktails.
Oder auf Augen.
Das ist ja auch so eine Art Cocktail.
Ein Milchsalzkocktail.
Also Gurke und Iran hab ich noch nie zusammen.
Doch, das kann ich mir aber vorstellen.
Also so richtig, ja.
Eher als Mango.
Das macht so richtig frisch. Also wenn der so handgemacht ist, es gibt halt so einige wenige Türken. Da gibt es dann halt, also es sind vor allem die Türken, wo halt auch vor allem viel Türken sind. Und dann so im Sommer, dann hast du halt so richtig so eine Kanne mit Iran, also nicht so das abgepackte aus den kleinen Plastibächern, sondern kriegst du noch so den Iran so eingeschüttet. Das ist einfach der Hammer. Kann ich keine qualifizierte Aussage zutreffen. Aber es mangelt ja auch ein wenig an Türken im Translauer Berg. Daran könnte es liegen.
Wir sollten vielleicht mal so ein kleines Austauschprogramm starten.
Ja, dann muss man dann irgendwie nach Cross Mountain gehen. Dann gibt es das ordentlich.
Oh ja, stimmt, da war ich letztens erst.
Im Wedding gibt es auch einiges, das stimmt.
Diesen kleinen kulturellen Ausflug.
Genau. Na jetzt haben wir... Ich will jetzt nicht so viel drauf eingehen, aber ich fand es ganz unterhaltsam, wie die letzte Sendung doch Wellen geschlagen hat. Also da wurde ja viel drüber diskutiert. Ich nehme an, ihr habt ja alle nicht gehört, aber...
Ich hab die Wellen nicht gehört.
Wann war denn die letzte Sendung? War das die zum Frauentag, wo du gesagt hast, ich wäre nicht da? Wo du so rumgenörgelt hast?
Ja, also wir haben uns ja viel über Virtual Reality und den ganzen Prospekt davon angeschaut. Aber ich fand das irgendwie sehr schön, wie die Wogen dann so hin und her wogten.
Ein Reizthema.
Ja, ich fand die Sendung aber eigentlich ganz gut. Also ich war dann mit der Leistung der Mannschaft eigentlich ganz zu viel.
Was soll man da sagen?
Ja, also am Ende zählen auch nur die Punkte.
Vor dem Spiel ist nach dem Spiel.
Die nehmen wir dann einfach mit irgendwie.
Nach dem Spiel ist vor dem Spiel.
Man muss eh von Sendung zu Sendung denken. Sag doch mal, einer mit Fußball könnte man nicht universell arbeiten.
Gepodcastet wie eine Flasche leer. Um mal den Klassiker zu tippen. Dem ist jetzt nichts mehr hinzuzufügen.
Womit machen wir weiter? Also ich hab sehr viel aufgeschrieben, weil ich dann tatsächlich viel erlebt habe in den letzten drei Wochen. Es war alles sehr umfangreich. Bevor ich euch zuquatsche. Wollt ihr irgendwas anderes vielleicht?
Ja, komm wir machen noch ein paar leichte Themen.
Weil die kleinen Sachen, die fallen ja dann sonst hinten dann immer so ein bisschen runter.
Also ich mach gleich den Anfang direkt. Nämlich hier aus der Kategorie Spiele. Hat auch viel Wellen geschlagen. Also jeder, der das nicht jetzt schon mitbekommen hat, dass es ein neues Point-and-Click-Adventure von Ron Gilbert gibt. Der lebt ja tatsächlich unter einem Stein.
Ich hab's gebacked auf Kickstarter.
Ich auch. Und zwar ist die Rede von Thimbleweed Park. Und es ist insofern interessant, als nicht vor allzu langer Zeit das erste erfolgreiche Kickstarter für ein Spiel war... Wie heißt der andere nochmal? Schäfer, Tim Schäfer und Ron Gilbert zusammen wollten ein Point-and-Click-Adventure machen. Das hat er damals auf Kickstarter. Das war das erste Mal, dass er so Millionenbeträge und für ein Spiel und so, ne? Das Spiel selbst, aber irgendwie war nicht so doll. Ach so, ja, die beiden Herrschaften, die haben so Klassiker wie Monkey Island, Manic Mansion, Day of the Tentacle, ähm, weiß nicht, Indiana Jones waren die da? Nee, da warst du das wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber das sind halt so die, ne? Die Knaller-Point-and-Click-Adventures aus alten Tagen, das haben die gemacht und genau, wie gesagt, dann wollten sie zusammen das erste Mal, das vor ein paar Jahren machen. Ist nicht so ein geiles Spiel raus geworden, ist relativ gefloppt. Ich hab sogar schon den Namen wieder vergessen. Ich hatte es auch gebacked, aber es war eher mau und jetzt hat sich der Ron Gilbert auf eigene Faust noch mal dran gemacht, jetzt so einen Point-and-Click-Adventure zu machen. Und da war ich dann auch aufgrund der vergangenen Erfahrungen erstmal so ein bisschen skeptisch, hab es auch ewig lange nicht angefangen zu spielen, obwohl es schon in meinem Steam-Folder lag. Und jetzt hab ich es doch vor ein paar Tagen angefangen und muss sagen, das ist wirklich sehr, sehr großartig, sehr, sehr nerdy auch. Da gibt es so viele Nerd-Topics drin, ein ganz, ganz großes Kino. Und auch sehr liebevoll gemacht. Und das unterhält mich tatsächlich sehr gut seit Tagen.
Ja, und vor allen Dingen, ich hab natürlich, dachte mir so, oh ja, gleich auf schwierig.
Natürlich.
Und war dann nach einiger Zeit auch direkt erst mal stumpt. Das ist mir dann irgendwie schon lang nicht mehr so richtig passiert bei so Adventures, weil die gerne mal zu leicht sind.
Also ich hatte das auch direkt auf hart gespielt. Also man muss sagen, es gibt den Casual Mode und da schreiben sie auch dazu, glaube ich, wenn du noch nie Point-and-Click-Adventure gespielt hast und dir nicht so der Flow und die Zusammenhänge so schon mal bekannt gemacht wurden, dann spiel vielleicht doch erst mal Casual Mode. Und im Hard Mode ist dann halt wirklich viel mehr Puzzle und auch, ja, etwas tiefer greifen. Und der Clou ist eigentlich an dem Spiel, dass es quasi an verschiedenen Stellen des Spiels bis zu fünf Charaktere gibt, die man steuern kann. Und manche Puzzle musst du halt auch mit den Charakteren zusammenlösen. Die müssen dann an einer Stelle auf der Map sein und dann muss der eine den Knopf drücken und der andere muss, also ich erzähl jetzt sehr abstrakt, damit es nicht gespoilert wird, aber du musst sozusagen dann auch so, ah ja, aber der alleine kriegt das jetzt nicht hin, aber dann kann ich ja noch den und dann... Also du musst auch die ganze Zeit nicht nur für deine Figur denken, wie krieg ich jetzt das Puzzle gelöst, sondern dann auch noch, ah Moment, da sind ja noch vier andere Figuren, vielleicht kann ich die dann so...
Waren die auch fast, dass man irgendwie so den Charakter wechselt, weil jetzt die eine Person von der anderen träumt und so und dann ist man irgendwie im Traum oder so was?
Ja, also wie gesagt, ohne...
Flashbacks und so und so.
Genau, ohne da zu viel erzählen zu wollen. Ja, genau, so ne Sachen gibt es da auch.
Du weißt, dass der Typ in Berlin war?
Ja, ich wollte da auch hin, aber ich glaub, ich war an dem Tag dann krank.
Eine mir bekannte Person war dort und er hat dann Zertifikate ausgestellt oder, warte mal, Zertifikat. Also es gab dann so einen Wisch, den er dann unterschrieben hat, wo es mehr so eine Absolution gibt. Also er hat dann den Leuten, die damals in ihrer Jugend seine Software geraubt kopiert haben, irgendwie Absolutionen erteilt, das was schon irgendwie okay ist und sie können wieder putzen lassen.
So ein Sündenerlass.
Ja, so quasi. Fand ich irgendwie ganz nice.
Kostete der so wie bei der katholischen Kirche?
Ich glaube nicht, aber ich glaube, das war auch nur so ein Treffen für die Leute, die Crowdfunding unterstützt haben. Nee, da konnte jeder kommen. Da konnte jeder kommen.
Aber was halt auch schön ist, das ist halt so ein Pixel-8-Bit-Grafik gehalten, aber jetzt nicht einfach nur so hochskaliert von der Mini-Auflösung, wie das so bei den Klassikern am Anfang war, bevor sie remastered wurden, sondern halt kannst du halt auf beliebig großen Bildschirmen und füllt dann auch gut aus. Schöne Musik haben sie, schöne Dialoge, also auch eingesprochen und ansonsten vom Bedienen her sehr, sehr wie früher.
Sehr spartanisch mit diesen Verben, die man anklickt.
Dieses Monkey Island und so weiter. Ich muss ja zugeben, dass ich diese ganze Nummer nicht mitgemacht habe. Da war ich dann schon weiter. Also das war irgendwie zu dem Zeitpunkt...
Nein, Monkey Island, da kann man nicht weiter sein.
Das ist zeitlos.
Nein, ich sage ja nicht, das ist doof oder so. Ich akzeptiere ja, dass das sozusagen die Gemüter in Wallungen gebracht hat, nur ich war... Ich habe mich halt am Anfang wie alle beim Computer mit Computerspielen beschäftigt, so ein Stück weit, und natürlich das eine oder andere geduttet und toll gefunden und werde ich niemals vergessen und all das. Aber ich fand dann einfach Spielen, das hat mich einfach nicht gereizt und habe das dann halt relativ früh gegen Programmieren eingetauscht. Das fand ich halt irgendwie viel spannender und dann habe ich irgendwie diese ganze Spielwelt überhaupt nicht mehr in mich reingelassen.
Ja, aber ich fand gerade diese Adventures, wo man halt drüber nachdenken muss und die Rätsel knacken muss und so. Also die einzige Spielkategorie, die irgendwie noch spannend blieb, obwohl man irgendwie schon in die Programmierung oder sonst was abgetaucht ist. Insofern, da gibt es schon...
Ja, ich finde, also genau, du hast halt so ein bisschen halt so diese Story, die ist auch irgendwie immer so ein bisschen noch so interessant. Die ist halt nicht so mega vordergründig, dass du die jetzt die ganze Zeit irgendwie vor Augen schwirrt, aber so, ich habe mich auch dabei, ich bin dann relativ weit so beim ersten Schuss so gekommen, also beim ersten Anspielen, dann bin ich auch so an einer Stelle so klemengenümer, ich gucke jetzt nicht im Internet nach, ich gucke jetzt nicht im Internet nach, weil früher, als ich Monkey Island gespielt habe, da musste man wenn dann warten, dass es in irgendeiner Spielezeitschrift mal wieder den nächsten Teil vom Walkthrough abgedruckt wurde. Da gab es das auch noch nicht im Internet. Und ich wollte das halt jetzt auch hart so wie früher halt spielen, und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, fuck it, dann mache ich jetzt aus und gucke morgen wieder, und dann habe ich wirklich so noch beim Einschlafen drüber nachgedacht und dann morgens beim Frühstück so ah, das habe ich noch nicht probiert und dann zack, ging's weiter.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch mit das geile an so crowdfunded Spielen. Also bei Book of Unwritten Tales 2 war das so, dass die Backer haben es halt früher bekommen. Und wenn du das Spiel dann früher bekommen hast, dann gab es im Internet auch keine Anleitung. Das Spiel war halt so neu, da musste man, musste es selber rausfinden. Und das ist dann schon geil.
Ja, und wie gesagt, da sind halt auch wirklich sehr viele Nerd-Sachen drin. ASCII-Decoden, einfache Verschlüsselungen knacken, Passwörter rausfinden und so Zeug halt.
Läuft auf Windows, Mac und Linux, glaube ich.
Ja, Steam.
Wird es nicht für iOS?
Noch nicht, wahrscheinlich. Auf dem Mac im Apple Store gibt es das ja auch, glaube ich, habe ich gesehen. Das kommt bestimmt noch lange noch auf iOS.
Also ich habe ja Monkey Island auch nie gespielt, aber ich habe irgendwas, aber ich weiß leider den Namen nicht mehr. Damals habe ich dann noch auf dem Nintendo DS von einem Freund gespielt. Das war auch super fesselnd, so ein schönes Point-and-Click-Adventure. Ich glaube, er hat mir erst zu einer Larnpartie gegangen, hat mir seinen DS dagelassen und ich habe es ihm dann am nächsten Tag wiedergegeben, so hier, ich möchte bitte das nächste Spiel.
Ein Kollege von mir, der hat einen Three-Headed Monkey auf dem Schreibtisch. Das fand ich auch ganz geil.
Ja, so Monkey Island ist Monkey Island 1. Da gibt es ja auch diese Remastered-Version. Die hatte ich bestimmt hier auch schon mal erwähnt, wo sie die alten Wasserfarbzeichnungen, sagen wir das so? Watercolor Paintings, das Stylebook genommen haben und haben das neu digital umgesetzt. Weil früher ging es nicht in 8-Bit natürlich so, sondern das sieht halt mega schön aus. Sie haben die ganzen Dialoge eingesprochen, sehr liebevoll. Und du kannst halt mit so einer Wischgeste, oder ich weiß nicht, wie das auf dem Computer funktioniert, kannst du auch noch zu der alten 8-Bit-Variante wechseln. Aber dadurch fühlt sich Monkey Island 1 in dieser Special Edition halt auch total modern an. Und das hab ich dann auch nach 15 Jahren mal wieder halt angefangen und war sofort wieder so im...
Ja, man bleibt wieder an den gleichen Stellen hängen.
Wie war das nochmal? Und vor allen Dingen sind die auch witzig, das ist ja noch dazu. Also genau, das ist also nochmal meine Empfehlung fürs Daddeln, falls jemand...
Auf jeden Fall...
.das noch nicht mitbekommen hat oder Zweifel hat, ob es gut ist, kann man machen. Roddy.
Tja, ich habe ein analoges Medienabspielgerät übergeholfen bekommen. Warum? Weil meine Mutter das Ding nicht mehr haben wollte. Und der war auch nicht mehr so ganz in Ordnung, da kam nicht mehr allzu viel Musik raus. Und es hat mich eine Weile gekostet, herauszufinden, was es ist. Funktioniert hat dann einfach, ein neues Tonabsystem einzubauen. Ich spreche von einem Platten-Spieler. Ich bin jetzt das erste Mal überhaupt in meinem Leben Besitzer eines Platten-Spielers.
Du hast ja auch Platten.
Ja, ich habe ein paar Platten mit dazu gekriegt.
Howard Carpendale und die wilde Herzbumpf.
Das geile an dem Teil ist, jeder, der den sieht, denkt sich so, was ist denn das? Das ist nämlich ein tangentialarm Platten-Spieler. Hier habe ich das Bild. Das Gerät heißt Duda Revox B790, wer es mal nachgucken will. Normalerweise hat man ja bei einem Platten-Spieler der Drehteller, wo die Platte drauf liegt, und dann hat man diesen Arm, der irgendwo rechts hinten angebracht ist und dann mit der Nadel da in der Rille drin rumkratzt. Was eine relativ einfache Methode ist, jetzt irgendwie Ton aus der Platte zu kriegen. Aber du hast natürlich das Problem, dass du diese sogenannten Skidding-Kräfte hast. Dadurch, dass die Platte der Nadel so ein bisschen Widerstand bietet, aber weil der Tonarm eben schwenkt, ist die Bewegungsrichtung der Nadel nicht immer komplett tangential zu der Rille. Das heißt, sie macht eine Kraft nach innen oder nach außen. Es gibt halt die billigen Platten-Spieler, die lösen das Problem, indem sie den Arm einfach schwer machen. Dann kratzt er nicht zur Seite weg. Dann gibt es auch welche, die mit irgendwelchen komischen Schnüren und Gewichten irgendwelche Ausgleichsdinge versuchen, diesen Arm die Kräfte auszugleichen. Dann gibt es eben dieses Teil. Und zwar ist es so, dass man da den Arm, das ist so eine Art Schiene, so eine Brücke, die klappt man so ganz über die Platte drüber. Und dann läuft auf so einem Schlitten, der läuft dann tatsächlich von außen zu innen von der Platte direkt in Richtung des Radius und hat senkrecht zu dem Radius dann den Tonabnehmer. Das heißt, der Tonabnehmer ist immer tangential, also die Nadel mit dem Tonabnehmersystem ist immer tangential zur Bewegungsrichtung der Nadel, sodass du keine Skidding-Kräfte hast. Und das Geile an dem Teil ist...
Aber bei den normalen Platten-Spieler ist doch vorne der Kopf auch nochmal so quer, also der läuft ja letzten Endes genauso.
Ja, aber wenn du dir überlegst, du hast den Drehpunkt des Armes irgendwo rechts hinten und irgendwo gibt es diesen Punkt, wo der Arm tatsächlich tangential zur Rille steht. Und weiter innen und weiter außen stimmt dieser Winkel aber nicht mehr. Der ist nicht mehr null. Das heißt, je nachdem wie das System abgestimmt ist, hast du entweder ganz am Anfang keine Kräfte oder in der Mitte oder ganz am Ende. Aber du hast halt nur den einen Sweet Spot, wo du tatsächlich keine Skidding-Kräfte hast. Also es gibt ja so Plattenspieler, die mit extrem langen Armen auftauchen, weil je länger der Arm ist, desto geringer wird dieser Fehlwinkel. Und dann hast du halt, wie gesagt, dieses Tangentialsystem. Da hat jetzt jemand ein Foto gepostet. Man sieht es recht schön. Der Arm selber wird von einem Motor bewegt. Und was man auf diesem Bild aber nicht sieht, ist in dem ganzen System, auf dem Tonabnehmer Ding Sie selber, ist eine Infrarot-Leuchtiode und ein Plastikteil mit einem Schlitz. Und auf dem Schlitten sind zwei Fototransistoren drauf. Und immer wenn der Arm so leicht aus der Senkrechten geht, dann kriegt eine der beiden Fotodioden Licht. Und dann wird der Motor angeworfen, um den Schlitten wieder auf die richtige Stelle zu positionieren. Also er regelt aktiv die Position auf diesem Arm nach. Das ist völlig absturz. Und das Teil, was man auch sieht, hat halt dieses komische Strohpoblitzlicht nicht, weil der quarzgesteuert den Plattenspettteller regelt. Also irgendwie, das war wohl, glaube ich, so ziemlich der Peak der Hi-Fi-Branche, Plattenspieler zu bauen, dieses Ding. Seitdem ist irgendwie nichts mehr gekommen, hat man so das Gefühl. Super Teil.
Und jetzt sitzt du da zu Hause und hörst dir deine Kraftwerkplatten an?
Nee, ich hab keine Kraftwerkplatte zu Hause. Also, ja...
Also Hörerspenden.
Wo du das jetzt gerade mit diesem Modell ausbringst, es gibt jetzt gerade so eine Kickstarter-Kampagne, da geht es auch um einen Plattenspieler. Und das finde ich auch ein sehr interessantes Ding. Das Projekt nennt sich Wheel und ist ein Plattenspieler von unten. Das heißt, du legst die Platte da drauf. Ich bin mir gerade nicht ganz... Also man kann das Ding auch senkrecht betreiben.
An die Wand hängen oder was?
An die Wand hängen und da spielen lassen. Und die Nadel kommt sozusagen von der anderen Seite.
Aber das ist auch tangential arm, wenn du da mal hinguckst.
Genau, und das ist auch tangential. Und dann würdest du sagen, also mir ist nicht ganz so sicher, ob sie da irgendwie jetzt mit Luft arbeiten, um die Platte festzuhalten, weil die hat ja dann unter Umständen auch so ein bisschen...
Ansaugen.
Sie ist so wellig und so weiter. Also muss ja in irgendeiner Form... Wenn du von unten die Nadel dagegen drückst, darf das Ding ja nach oben nicht einfach wegfliegen. Vielleicht ist da noch ein Clip drauf. Ich hab's noch nicht so ganz verstanden. Vielleicht wird's einfach oben mit diesem Schnupsi, glaube ich, festgeschraubt. Genau, das kann sein. Und dann hast du sozusagen überhaupt gar keinen Arm mehr. Also du hast schon einen, aber der ist halt hinten. Also unten. Hinten oder unten, je nachdem. Von wo du guckst. Ist auch cool, oder? Keine Ahnung, ob das funktioniert. Aber wie das so ist mit Zündkirsch-Zeitaprojekten...
Wahrscheinlich klemmst du die Platte in der Mitte ein.
Genau, du musst wahrscheinlich mit diesem Schnupsi in der Mitte einmal so festschrauben oder festklicken oder irgendwie sowas. Aber es sieht geil aus. Weil es ist designmäßig, minimalistischer geht es ja wohl kaum. Einziges Problem ist halt immer noch eine Platte.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, was ich mir jetzt, was ich da bei der Platte relativ, oder bei dem Plattenspieler mir relativ schwierig vorstelle, ist, wie kriegst du die Platte sauber? Also normalerweise tust du ja die Platte drauf, dann wirfst du das Teil an, dass es sich dreht und dann hast du dieses längliche Bürstchen, mit dem du dann einmal über die Platte drüber bürstest, damit du dann den ganzen Staub von der Platte runter gebürstet hast.
Im Idealfall hat das Ding einfach eine eingebaute Bürste. Ja, dann geht ja dann auch wunderbar. Du kannst ja von unten halt auch gleich putzen. Die ganze Zeit.
Da ist so ein Drobo auch noch gleich mit eingebaut. Auf der anderen Seite des tangentialen Arms. Der den Staub wegsaubt. Meinst du Rumba? Ja, Rumba. Drobo stimmt, das war das andere Ding, diese ganzen Namen. Rumba, ja, Rumba.
Rumba.
Genau, also da jetzt noch Geld drauf zu schmeißen, ist wahrscheinlich sinnlos, weil da schon genug...
Naja, wenn man davon dann eins kriegt. Aber vielleicht sollte man erstmal warten, dass die tatsächlich auch ein Produkt irgendwie, ein benutzbares...
Naja, sie haben irgendwie 424.000 Euro bekommen von 50.000, die sie haben wollten.
Meinst du, es könnte hinhauen?
Könnte, also ich meine, wenn sie es damit nicht schaffen, dann schaffen sie es irgendwie gar nicht.
Ja, und eins der Probleme, warum ich dieses Ding nicht zum Laufen bekommen habe, ist unter anderem auch, den gab es ursprünglich mal in zwei Varianten, nämlich mit einem Moving Magnet Tonabnehmer und einem Moving Coil Tonabnehmer. Und ich war mir nicht klar, was da drin verbaut ist, und dachte dann immer, es liegt an dem Vorverstärker, den ich da dran hänge, dass das nicht funktioniert, aber daran lag es dann irgendwie doch nicht.
Insofern, naja.
Also es lag am Tonabnehmer, aber einfach weil der halt nicht mehr in Ordnung war. Irgendwo hab ich gelesen, dass die, wenn die wirklich alt sind, die Tonabnehmer, dass dann die Gummipöppel, dieses ganze Ding, irgendwie halten, die Nadel da halten, dass die fest werden, und dann bewegt sich da nichts mehr, und dann hört man halt auch nichts. Jetzt funktioniert alles. Ich hab irgendwie vor, naja, vor zwei Wochen oder so, hab ich da ein kurzes Video bei Twitter gepostet, als kleinen Themenvorschlag für die nächste Sendung. Ja, doch funktioniert. Und der klingt auch relativ gut, also dafür, dass er ein Plattenspieler ist.
Du hast schon hier so ein paar Leute getriggert mit deinem...
Naja, nun, ich meine, es ist halt ein analogisches System. Also du hast halt diese ganzen analogen Probleme, wie Rauschen, Einstreuung, Verzerrungen aller Art, Gleichlaufschwankungen, dann hast du Abnutzung der Platte, dann hast du halt Rumpeln. Also, dass ein Plattenspieler auf Anhieb gut klingt, ist halt nicht normal. Also, da musst du halt einen guten haben. Und vor allen Dingen auch eine Platte, die noch nicht runtergeleiert ist, sonst ist da nichts mit Platte, klingt besser. Also, das ist irgendwie so.
Eben hatte hier gerade einer im Chat eine interessante Erklärung. Muss noch mal kurz hochscrollen. Ein kleines Stück hier. Ja, genau. Es gibt einen Haufen Musik, die auf CD und digital nur so falsch gemastert zu kriegen ist, weil sie eins und eins vom Schallplattenmaß immer nur mit Schallplatte im korrekten Sound kriegt.
Ja, am Anfang haben die die CDs falsch gemacht. Ja, das Problem ist ja, dass du, wenn du ein Masterband für eine Schallplatte herstellst, dass du das ja so machst, dass das hinterher die Schallplatte richtig klingt. Und wenn du dieses Masterband dann aber, so wie es ist, direkt auf eine CD brennst, dann klingt das halt so, wie es vorher klang, damit es hinterher auf Platte richtig klingt. Und nicht so, wie du es hören willst.
Musst du sozusagen nochmal so eine Kalibrationsstufe rausnehmen oder rückgängig machen?
Zum Beispiel Bass ist halt relativ sensitiv auf der Schallplatte, weil so viel Bass wummern quasi dann auch die Rille da.
Das Problem ist folgendes, dass die Auslenkung der Rille ist umgekehrt proportional zur Frequenz. Deswegen, ja, also tiefe Frequenzen machen sehr breite Wellen in der Rille drin. Deswegen hast du ja auch diese RIA Kurve, dieses R-I-A-A, was man nur von den Raubkopierer Hetze da kennt, diese Bude da.
Record Industry Association of America.
Genau, die haben ja irgendwann mal diese Filterkurve definiert, nach der du die Bässe absenkst. Das heißt, bevor die Platte geschnitten wird, werden die Bässe abgesenkt und du hast hinterher in deinem Platten Vorverstärker das umgekehrte Filter drin, um die Bässe wieder hochzuheben. Deswegen hast du ja auch so ein Problem mit Rumpeln. Weil so ein klein bisschen Rumpeln wird von dem Filter natürlich sehr stark verstärkt.
Naja, analog halt.
Analog halt. Allerlei analoge Probleme. Du hast halt auch diese Sachen, Stereo zum Beispiel. Ursprünglich die Monoplatten, da war ja die Spur rechts-links. Also die Auslenkung der Spur war rechts-links. Und als irgendjemand angefangen hat, Stereo zu machen, musst du ja irgendwie die zweite Spur mit reinkriegen. Und dann haben sie sich entschieden, die Differenz zwischen rechts und links als Höhenspur zu schreiben. Das heißt, du hast die Summen-Spur rechts-links und die Differenzspur hoch- runter. Und dadurch, dass du dann aber die Magnete im 45°-Winkel anordnest in dem Tonabnehmer, bekommst du halt wieder rechts und links raus. Das ist nur, wenn das nicht ganz passt, dann hast du halt keine Kanaltrennung mehr. Also bei der CD hast du ja diese 96 dB Rauschabstand. Und das sind auch die 96 dB Kanaltrennung, die du hast, kriegst du bei einer Platte nicht hin. Gute Geräte schaffen halt 60, 70. Mehr ist halt...
Ich frage mich, warum es denn keine Schallplattenspieler gibt, die das einfach mit Laser machen. Gibt es. Aber?
Kann keiner bezahlen. Also es gibt da irgendwie einen Typen, der hat wohl zehn Jahre lang daran geforscht, wie man sowas macht, so ein optisches Abtastsystem und verkauft das jetzt, ich glaube es kostet gut 20.000 so einen Plattenspieler. Na ja, als die Technologie so weit war, hat es halt keinen mehr interessiert.
Du wirst im Chat gerade korrigiert. Angeblich ist die Summe oben unten und Stereo zweimal schräg.
Stereo ist zweimal... Summe war oben unten?
Also Stereo wäre dann links, rechts.
Mein größeres Problem mit meinem Platten-Spieler ist, dass wenn du über den Dielenboden sehr elegant schleichst, rumpelt es. Also die Platte springt halt ständig. Das ist so ätzend, weil wir so einen extremen...
Wie bei der Waschmaschine? Wie bei der Waschmaschine, so eine Matte.
Darunter liegen.
Ich schleiche immer jetzt schon dran vorbei, wenn ich Platte höre.
Eine große Sandkiste und den da reinstellen.
Oh, ja super.
Mega praktisch.
Na ja, aber Sand dämpft Vibrationen relativ gut weg.
Das ist das, was mich gerade sehr stört.
Also auf jeden Fall irgendwie Masse. Und die dann einigermaßen weich lagern.
Bei Modulor gibt es auch schöne Moosgummimatten in verschiedenen Stärken. Die funktionieren auch schon mal ganz gut, um so Vibrationen aus empfindlicher Elektronik zu filtern. Oder von.
Ich erinnere mich noch an eine Schulparty, wo jemand auf die schlaue Idee kam, die eine von den beiden Boxen mit auf das DJ-Pult zu stellen. Und es ein unglaubliches Feedback über den Plattenspieler gab.
Irgendwie muss so Gabber erfunden worden sein.
Ja, Gewicht noch drauflegen gehört ja auch zu diesen Sportarten. Es gibt ja so Leute, die so noch irgendwie eine fette Betonplatte irgendwie oben auf ihre Platte drauflegen. Also Stahl oder so was, keine Ahnung. Die Laufhaube zu erzeugen.
Na ja, du musst natürlich schon die richtige Abstimmung zwischen der Feder und der Masse haben, damit du dann... Du willst ja die... Du hast ja inherent eine Schwingung und du willst die Schwingung möglichst weit runterkriegen. Also auf eine niedrige Frequenz. Deswegen tust du viel Masse hin, aber du musst halt gleichzeitig eine weiche Federung haben. Viel Masse nützt dir nix, wenn das trotzdem direkt auf dem Boden steht. Granitboden. Auf dem Holzboden.
Ja, erst mal genug 20. Jahrhundert Technologie.
Ancient Technology.
Naja, ist auch okay.
Ja, hat aber auf jeden Fall Spaß gemacht.
So, jetzt kann Letty auch nochmal ein kurzes Thema wegschaufeln.
Ja, ich freue mich, dass ich unter die Lehrenden gegangen bin. Oder gerade gehe. Ihr euch auch?
Natürlich.
Ach, das ist schön. Ich bin, wie vielleicht schon häufiger erwähnt, in einer Hochschule, in einem Fachbereich für Design. Und fast, also ich habe eigentlich keinen einzigen Designer, der bisher noch kein Interesse an Coden hat, da gefunden. Einige trauen sich das vielleicht noch nicht. Aber ich hatte echt ein Problem am Anfang. Ich hab letzte Woche angefangen, den Kurs zu halten. Es geht vor allen Dingen über Informationsvisualisierung und da speziell mit D3.js, was ja grad so der de facto heiße Scheiß ist, wenn es um Visualisierung im Web geht. Und hab erstmal zu viele Leute in meinem Kurs gehabt. Das wird ziemlich cool. Viele Leute haben Interesse daran, Coden zu lernen, zu verstehen, wie komische Nerds denken, um auch mit denen interagieren zu können. Also Designer sind ja jetzt nicht nur dafür da, um irgendwas hübsch zu machen, sondern auch wie Tim sich so häufig aufregt über UIs. Das ist die Schälte, nochmal bitte nachhören.
Nein, das wollte nur darauf referenzieren, wer das nicht gehört hat. Da haben wir uns sehr ausführlich auch damit beschäftigt. Aber was heißt denn zu viele?
Also ich hab halt einen kleinen Raum und als einzelne Lehrkraft mit drei Stunden Slot kannst du ja nicht 50 Leute in der Übung bedienen. Ich hab das so ein bisschen geteilt in, nennen wir es Vorlesungen, wo sie Input bekommen, über Techniken in D3 oder wie man generell codet, Coding-Strategien, Datenstrukturen und so was. Und der überwiegende Part soll natürlich sein, so ein Hands-on, codet selber, probiert raus, rumspielen mit Daten. Und das ist natürlich super anstrengend. Ich hab jetzt eine Gruppe von 20, 22 Leuten und das ist halt für eine Person viel zu viel, weil du nicht jedem gerecht werden kannst. Also kannst du sowieso nicht. Aber es sind halt viele Fragen, die aufkommen, wo du halt einfach mal helfen musst, wenn jemand zum ersten Mal codet. Oder ich hab heute gedacht, dass schon jeder mal eine Konsole benutzt hat. Was muss ich hier reintippen? Was ist denn die Tabulatortasse? Aha, okay. Und wenn ich hier drauf drücke, wow, Autovervollständigung. Ich dachte mir so, okay, wir gehen vielleicht nochmal kurz zurück zu den Basics.
Deswegen mache ich ja meinen Kurs. Ich hab am Anfang auch versucht, so ganz anspruchsvolle Sachen zu machen. Dann bin ich ja jetzt irgendwann bei diesem, ich erkläre mal das Internet von A bis Z. Weil ich dann auch gemerkt habe, oh, in meiner Bubble nehme ich auch die ganze Zeit an. Also jeder wisst ja wohl, was ein Cookie ist oder so. Oder meine Lieblingsfrage zum Einstieg, um so zu gucken, wer so mehr checken halt als die anderen, ist dann immer so, okay, wer von euch weiß denn, was der Unterschied zwischen World Wide Web und Internet ist? Und dann ist plötzlich so dieser leere Blick in die Runden gesorgen, wie, da gibt es einen Unterschied. Und dann weiß ich auch jedes Mal wieder in jedem Semester aufs Neue.
Meine Lieblingsfrage, du weißt ja.
Da drüben sitzen die Halbchecker.
Und ich denke, das ist in der Tat, das glaube ich, richtig wertvolle Angebot. Bei verkopften Scheiß kann ja jeder erzählen, aber die Grundlagen mal richtig auf die Backe zu kriegen, da kannst du halt auch die ganzen Heißluftwedler, die kriegst du halt auch schnell rausgefiltert, indem du einfach mal so ganz grundlegende Sachen hinterfragst. Und ich bin immer wieder erstaunt, wie wenig die Leute so ihr Handwerk so drauf haben. Und dann so ein bisschen derailing zu machen, macht doch richtig Spaß.
Bei mir im Kurs ist ja explizit für Anfänger, da wird ja auch gar nichts groß erwartet, aber ich bin trotzdem immer wieder erschüttert, weil eigentlich alle so 90% ihrer Kommunikation über Internet abfeiern. Hier Linus hatte doch auch irgendwie diesen tollen Tweet, wo seine Steuerberaterin irgendwie eine neue E-Mail-Adresse bekannt gegeben hat und im CC alle kunden. Das ist nicht mehr das Einmaleins, das muss in die Schule, das muss ins Bildungssystem.
Das ist das 1 bis 10.
Es ist wirklich unfassbar, dass das im 21. Jahrhundert immer noch passiert. Dass da kein Bewusstsein vergibt, keine und so weiter. Und es geht dann eben so weiter mit ach wie der Computer, Konsole, Terminal und so. Wenn man dann so zeigen kann, was da alles so geht, was im User-Interface sonst nicht geht und so.
Wenn du jetzt schon so überbucht bist, du erwähnst das aber jetzt nicht um noch weitere Teilnehmer.
Nein, nein, nein. Was mein eigentlicher Punkt ist, warum ich es aufbringe, ist, wie schwer das halt ist. Was Huckel auch meinte, du hast deine Bubble, du kennst alles, du kennst dich mit dem Scheiß aus. Brich das aber mal runter auf jeden anderen Student, der eben zum ersten Mal codet, der sich vielleicht super mit Gestaltungssachen auskennt, aber nicht mit Coden und das aber für ihn z.B. essentiell wichtig ist als Teil seiner Ausbildung. Also bei uns gibt es halt z.B. keinen festen Lehrplan. Jeder kann das wählen, was er will, was danach halt auch heißt. Jeder hat ein ganz eigenes Profil, was er sich da zusammenstellt, was er kann. Aber von vielen kommt es explizit so, sie wollen verstehen, wie Programmieren funktioniert. Jetzt nicht nur speziell Visualisierung, was ich jetzt anbiete, sondern auch wie Algorithmen so allgemein, wie man das so verstehen hat, wenn man über Algorithmen spricht. Die Hochschule hat sich im Zuge von Brexit und Trump-Wahl auf die Fahnen geschrieben dieses Semester unter dem Schwerpunkt, Politik des Designs laufen zu lassen. Dass sie sich auch kritisch mit dem auseinandersetzen, was sie machen. Von vielen kommt dieses, wir müssten uns doch genauso die Frage stellen, für wen designen wir hier gerade irgendwelche Werbung. Wie zum Beispiel für die Bundeswehr, die dann über Trojaner wollte immer bekämpfen. Cyber, Cyber! Für die Werbung gestaltest. Das finde ich schon sehr spannend.
Das finde ich interessant, dass das in solchen Kreisen ein Thema ist.
Absolut, absolut. Und die sind auch super begierig, Input von anderen Leuten zu bekommen. Und um meine Studenten auf ein Minimum herunter zu reduzieren, habe ich ihnen auch gesagt, wer in meinem Kurs teilnehmen will, muss mir ein Letter of Motivation schicken, mit einem Bild von sich. Ich bin halt auch super schlecht mit Gesichtern. Einige kenne ich mittlerweile schon, aber ich finde es unangenehm.
Es ist ganz cool, wenn man sein eigenes Addressbuch schon mal am Start hat.
Ja, genau, das ist ziemlich cool. Und ich finde es auch schön gegenüber den Studenten, wenn man sie dann doch mal mit Namen ansprechen kann.
Das schaffe ich zum Beispiel in den meisten Semestern nicht.
Das ist insofern ein guter Move, so zu starten. Aber so eine Motivation einzufordern, finde ich auch gut. So als Qualifikation auch?
Nee, habe ich nicht gemacht. Also sie sollten mir das schon schreiben. Einige haben natürlich nur eine einfache Motivation geschrieben. Aber ich habe auch Sachen bekommen, wo ich echt sehr gut gelacht habe.
Die hören jetzt vielleicht auch zu, ne?
Nee, ich glaube nicht.
Ihr seid alle special.
Du erinnerst dich ja eh an keine Namen.
Nee, ich erinnere mich ja eh an keine Namen.
Jetzt zu spezifische Inhalte halt.
Nee, nee, aber ich hab halt wirklich schon Dinge, die einfach super frech auch geschrieben wurden. Also so, warum sie denn unbedingt in diesem Kurs sein sollen, halt auch ein bisschen, sei mal, frecher, aber inhaltlich auch stark. Also eben so, ja, ich will Code verstehen, ich finde das ist wichtig als Designer, weil erst dann kann ich eigentlich, Interface war glaube ich eine Studentin, die im Interface-Kurs vor allem ein Bachelor-Kurs ist und sie meinte halt, ohne dieses Wissen, wo sind Limitierungen beim Programmieren, kann ich eigentlich keinen Design machen, kann ich eigentlich keine Interface sein, weil dann verstehe ich nicht, wo ist hier gerade die Limitierung und warum erzählt mir der olle Nerd, es geht nicht. Dann ist es eben nur dieses, es geht nicht, aber sie versteht nicht, warum geht es eigentlich nicht. Das fand ich schon ziemlich cool.
Überall. Bei VUGA, die Game Designer, die keine Ahnung von Programmieren hatten, die haben sich halt wirklich die absurdesten Dinge. Dann waren wir halt immer die Programmierer, die sagten, ja, in Software kann man alles machen, aber es macht an der Stelle jetzt technisch keinen Sinn. Dann versuchst du, das zu erklären, wohingegen die Game Designer, die halt auch selber schon ihre kleinen Adventures programmiert haben, mit denen kannst du halt einfach so eine Ansage machen, das geht das und deswegen nicht, ach so, alles klar, verstehe. Das waren mir auch immer die allerliebsten auf jeden Fall.
Ja, das ist super. Also ich hab ja auch unterschiedliche Forschungsprojekte und das letzte, da hatte ich, sag ich mal, bis zum Schluss von dem Themengebiet her, war es halt relativ komplex, dass wir das nicht komplett durchstiegen haben. Aber das nächste Forschungsprojekt ist halt auf Kulturdaten, so zum Beispiel Bibliotheksdaten mit Büchern. Ja, irgendwie haben alle im Team schon mal ein Buch in der Hand gehabt. Und sind halt eh alle bibliophil. Das heißt, wir haben ganz eigene Ideen, weil du einfach die Nutzung kennst, wenn du dann jemanden hinsetzt, der einfach Bücher kacke findet. Und der soll dann da nicht nur eine Visualisierung bauen, sondern einfach den Nutzer zu verstehen, wie er vielleicht denkt. Ein bisschen schwierig dann. Deswegen, ja, ich finde auch, das muss man eigentlich überall haben. Und ich bin total glücklich über diese Vorlesung, auch wenn sie immer drei Stunden lang, heute sogar fast vier gingen. Ja, letzte Woche. Ich habe jeden Mittwoch Vorlesungen. Bis in Juli. Aber es ist cool. Und das Einzige eben so dieser Realitätscheck mit, was können die Leute eigentlich und wie weit bin ich in meinem Kopf schon wieder, ist natürlich echt ein großer Unterschied. Und ich habe jetzt halt auch gesagt, weil ich gemerkt habe, selbst die einfachen Sachen brauchen einfach länger zum Erklären. Und denkste, du schmeißt ja ein Stück Kot hin und sagst, nehmt das mal so und dann fragt sich, ne ne ne, dann wird wirklich alles hinterfragt. Und du denkst dir dann so, wow, krass, ihr wollt echt alles haargenau jetzt wissen und nicht erst nächste Woche. Das ist super, genau.
Das ist wirklich super. Also was noch schlimmer ist, wenn die Leute das alle so hinnehmen und du weißt schon, ich hab euch gar nicht genug gesagt, um es zu verstehen, nickt nicht.
Nickt nicht. Ja, das ist auch, in jedem Semester ende ich irgendwo an irgendeiner Stelle, dann damit erst mal zu erklären, wie ein Computer an sich so funktioniert, also was das überhaupt alles soll. Weil ich in jedem Semester immer so diesen Punkt irgendwo erreiche, wo ich so denke, wenn ihr das jetzt wirklich verstehen wollt, warum und wieso die Dinge so sind, dann müsst ihr mal kurz darüber sprechen. Nach fünf Stunden geht die Klammer wieder zu. Weil ich mich das selber mal interessiert hatte, also dieses ganze Paket-basierte Internet und so weiter, warum und wieso ist das alles so, dann so Circuit-Switching, Packet-Switching, dann hab ich das irgendwie auch so versucht, so zu erklären, dass nicht so viele Nachfragen kommen, sondern irgendwie, dann kann man doch nachfragen, dann muss ich mir auch tausende Analogien ausdenken, wie stellt euch vor, jeder hätte seinen eigenen Postboot und würde nur eine Postkarte tragen hin und her, das ist ja total ineffizient, dann fängst du an so zu rudern.
Hör mir auf, wie würdest du als praktisches Beispiel, ich hab heute so ein bisschen Schleifen, bin ich durchgegangen und hab so exotische, was heißt exotische Lieder, die du einfach nicht so sehr brauchst bei Visualisierung, nur mal kurz erwähnt, so eine Wild-Schleife, brauchst du halt nicht so häufig, oder wer hat das?
Exotisch? Exotisch, ich wollte gerade sagen, was für exotische Schleifen kennst du denn?
Wild-Schleifen?
Naja, du nutzt es halt dann doch nicht so häufig. Ja, brauchst du nicht so häufig bei, also ich müsste echt mal einen Search auf meinem Workspace machen.
Wir können irgendwann noch mal eine ganze Sendung nur über Iteration machen. Das gibt auf jeden Fall eine Menge, ja.
Ja, aber dann hab ich ihm zum Beispiel diese Do-While gezeigt und er hat dann auch erklärt, wo der Unterschied ist. Und meinte er, könntest du noch mal so ein Beispiel? Ich hab das glaube ich nicht. Und ich dachte so, uh, was hab ich denn für ein griffiges Beispiel, wo ich genau will, dass es einmal durchführt. Auf jeden Fall einmal, aber vielleicht auch danach nie wieder. Es ist mir aus Verrecken nichts eingefallen. Genau, da rudert man, fängt man an zu rudern.
Aber ich mach das jetzt ja glaube ich schon seit acht oder neun Jahren. Nee, warte, warte. 2008.
Es wird nicht weniger.
Aber dadurch hab ich jetzt so mittlerweile so mal für die Standard-Strengen, die immer wieder kommen, da hab ich jetzt so meine ganzen Erklärungen und Beispiele, tausenden Flavors irgendwie parat. Aber ab und zu passiert es dann trotzdem nochmal, dass dann so, ah, diese Nachfrage hab ich noch nicht. Die, die ist neu. Dann sitzt man wieder da, versucht's, ohne zu brechen.
Ja, weil du sagst, das ist eine ganze Vorlesung, eine ganze Sendung über Loops, da meinte dann halt auch jemand so, wie kann ich mir das eigentlich vorstellen mit so einer Iteration? Nimm so eine Box, wo Dinge drin sind, und du willst die nacheinander rausnehmen.
Weil genau solche Fragen, muss ich sagen, das finde ich am geilsten. Also umso bekloppter die Frage ist, umso mehr du merkst, weil zwei Dinge habe ich gelernt, über das Lernen und Lehren. Also erstmal grundsätzlich, man lernt durch nichts so gut wie durchs Erklären. Und man erklärt am besten, wenn man in der Lage ist, zu verstehen, warum jemand etwas nicht versteht. Weil das ist das, was mich noch viel mehr immer angepisst hat als Leute, die irgendwas nicht raffen, ist, wenn Leute, die was erklären sollen, nicht raffen, was sie zu erklären haben. Weil sie einfach nicht verstehen, was nicht verstanden wird. Und wenn man das, glaube ich, auch im Kopf so ein bisschen, vielleicht ist das auch eine Anlage oder keine Ahnung oder ein Erfahrung, auf jeden Fall denke ich, muss man seinen Kopf einfach umdrehen und erstmal sich selber an die Kandare nehmen und sagen, ich muss mich jetzt hier erstmal konzentrieren, um überhaupt erstmal zu verstehen, warum wir hier aneinander vorbeirehen. Weil was hilft's, neunmal kluge von mir tausendfach vorbereitete Slides zu zeigen, wenn Grundannahmen manchmal auch nur Terminologien, Doppeldeutigkeiten auf einmal im Raum sind oder auch einfach nur kulturelle Erfahrungen, die einfach durch spätere Geburt irgendwie, ja? Weil man einfach der Meinung ist, das müsste man doch mitbekommen haben, Terminal und so.
Ja, Modem. Ich komm jetzt ja mit dem Kurs immer mehr in die Grenze, wo immer mehr Leute drin sitzen, die keinen Modem und keinen Kabel durch Wohnzimmer und Telefonleitungen blockieren und so das nicht mehr kennen.
Verstehen dann den ganzen Carrier-Witz hin. Aber das ist auch ein gutes Training und das ist etwas, wo ich mir immer versucht habe, viel Mühe zu geben, in so einen Verständnismodus zu kommen. Und das hat mir dann wiederum weiter geholfen, weil ich dann auch irgendwann aufgehört habe, im falschen Moment zu reden. Also das ist ja auch so ein Grundfehler. Als Jugendlicher hält man sich ja sowieso für Geilsten. Weil man schneidet Sachen so schnell und man ist ja überhaupt cool. Und dann die alten Säcke, die haben ja eh alle keine Ahnung und reden ja nur dummes Zeug und kennen ja auch den ganzen hippen Scheiß nicht. Und dann ist man halt irgendwie so überheblich. Und diese Überheblichkeit führt dann eben auch schnell dazu, dass man eben nicht zuhört. Sondern einfach die ganze Zeit nur noch sich selber produziert und raushaut und sich dabei selber nochmal so geil findet. Ja, es ist ja auch dann so eine Endlosschleife, in der man dann irgendwie hängen bleibt. Und irgendwann, ich weiß nicht mehr, ich glaube, Pawel hat mich irgendwie, glaube ich, geheilt. Pawel war ja auch schon ein paar Mal hier. Ich finde es immer ganz interessant, wenn Pawel dann hier ist und dann kommen so in den Kommentaren so Leute, die so, der sagt ja kluge Sachen, du da auch, und dann so, ich kann das nicht hören, der redet ja so langsam. Ja, ich weiß. Pawel redet sehr langsam. So, und ich hab viele Gespräche geführt damals mit Pawel, weil wir halt im gleichen Laden waren. Und ich merkte ja dann immer so, Pawel setzt so einen Satz an. Und zwar halt wirklich wie so ein Kreuzfahrtschiff. Erst mal so ein paar Seile losbinden und dann so, ja fahr doch! Aber wenn das Ding dann halt einmal in Fahrt gekommen ist, dann war es ja auch nicht mehr aufzuhalten. Und irgendwann habe ich mich einfach so in Gedanken dann einfach so an die Hafenwiese gesetzt und mir das ganze Treiben einfach angeschaut. Und die Zeit genutzt, einfach mal selber nachzudenken. Über das, was ich vielleicht dann, wenn irgendwann die Drehung durchgeführt ist, noch mal so per Flaggenalphabet, bitte in diese Diskussion da reinwerfe. Und das hat mich enorm geschult. Also ich bin einfach ruhiger geworden und habe einfach angefangen so. Und merke dann auch so, wenn man den Leuten mal zuhört, und zwar nicht nur so akustisch zuhört, gibt es ja auch so Überhektiker, die hören einem ja eigentlich nur zu, um die Sprechpause abzupassen, um dann sofort wieder ihren Wortschwall reinzuquetschen. Das ist so eine Unsitte. Aber wenn man dann einfach diese Zeit nutzt, zuzuhören und auch darüber nachzudenken, was die anderen Leute einem sagen, sehr hilfreich. Also es ist wirklich erstaunlich, was man auf einmal, zumal man ja dann auch...
Was für Weisheiten gebraucht werden.
Ja, jetzt sind wir nämlich auch wieder bei dem Punkt, weil ich ja dann, während dieses Zuhörns, dann irgendwie so, so wie ich gerade versuche, die ganze Zeit mein Thema hier an den Start zu bringen, vollkommen ineffektiv, weil passt überhaupt nicht zur Empfänger. Wir kennen ja das Problem aus dem Internet. Du kannst da noch so geil deinen Protokoll ins Netz strahlen. Wenn da irgendwie ein anderes Protokoll erwartet wird, dann wird halt irgendwie nichts draus. Das ist alles schon ganz hilfreich. Insofern, wenn du schon ein bisschen irgendwas drauf habt, irgendwie fang mal an zuzuhören, Leuten was zu erklären, hilft.
Absolut. Und dafür hab ich jetzt auch, weil wie kann man das besser managen? Seine Vorlesungssammlung und was du so halt an Content bereitstellst, als über GitHub. Da hat man endlich mal eine vernünftige Versionierung und alle haben immer das alles up to date und man muss keine Folien vorbereiten.
Sinnvollen Anwendungsfall für die Scheiße.
Wie, man muss nichts vorbereiten?
Naja, nichts vorbereiten. Ich schmeiß mal den Link, falls das jemand interessiert auch, wenn's Schleck... Genau. Na ich hab halt einfach nur Markdown-Files und GitHub rendert Markdown-Files ja wirklich exzellent. Das heißt, ich hab keine Folien... Und ich hab jetzt einfach nur GitHub und scrolle durch. Es ist so großartig. Also ich mein, du brauchst halt auch keine Folien, die du irgendwie sinnlos durchklickst, in denen du Sachen nicht richtig rauskopieren kannst. Deswegen fand ich dann jetzt irgendwie die Idee, mal über Markdown das Ganze zu probieren. Wesentlich reizvoller. Ja, genau. Du verschwendest keine Zeit, irgendwie groß zu suchen nach, wie kann ich das mal probieren. Also, Tim, meine Ordner-Struktur ist 01 und so weiter. Das sind die einzelnen Vorlesungen. Und dann gibt es halt noch verschiedene Ordner. Also ja, genau, Lectures, meine Notizen zur Vorlesung ist jetzt noch nicht ausformuliert. Eigentlich würde ich das halt ganz gerne am Ende der Vorlesung auch mit all den Anmerkungen, die ich so von Studis bekomme, was schwer zu verstehen war, etc. Also wirklich so auch mal runterschreiben, nicht unbedingt Blogposts. Ja, ich halte die Vorlesung auf Englisch. Was mich heute in die Prädule brachte, wie heißt noch mal eigentlich das Ist-Gleichzeichen auf Englisch? Und all diese komischen, bescheuerten Klammern. Das war dann so ein bisschen so ein ach wir ignorieren das einfach, wir gehen jetzt einfach drüben hinweg. Das hat auch glaube ich niemand mitbekommen. Oder manchmal helfen die dann doch sowieso.
Wie heißen die ganzen Klammern vor allen Dingen? Das ist am schlimmsten.
Also die normalen Curly. Ach so nennt ihr das. Das nennt ja jeder wieder anders.
Und dann gibt es halt die Curly Braces, dann gibt es die Angle Braces oder Angle Brackets und dann gibt es die Square Brackets. Also es gibt sehr viele unterschiedliche Ausdrücke.
Gibt es eigentlich den perfekten englischen Ausdruck für Schnuffi?
Ich würde ihn einfach auch auf Englisch Schnuffi nennen.
Was ist Schnuffi jetzt?
Naja, es ist ein universelles Wort.
Eine metasyntekraktische Variable.
So könnte man das einfach sagen. Hier, Schnuffi, und alle wissen nicht, was ist meine. Fuh, na Fuh ist nicht so süß wie Schnuffi.
Was meinst du denn hier?
Aber Schnuffi ist doch eine Person, oder? Eine langsame.
Schnuffi? Nein, ich meine Schnuffi. Was ist denn ein Schnuffi?
Ich nutze Schnuffi immer als Platzhalter.
Eine metasyntekraktische Variable.
Also nenne ich es einfach Schnuffi.
Bestimmt gibt es eine Liste der metasyntekraktischen Variablen und ihre Übersetzung in der Wikipedia.
Das klingt nach einem guten Artikel für meinen nächsten Arbeitstag.
Das ist sogar sehr, sehr wichtig, dass die Leute das verstehen. Also eine metasyntekraktische Variable zu verstehen an sich, also als Konzept, ist schon mal total wichtig. Weil wie soll man denn sonst, ich meine, man benutzt das ja eigentlich den ganzen Tag mit den ganzen Dingsies und Schnuffies und dem Kletterradansch.
Kann jetzt mal jemand den Unterschied zwischen einem Schnuffi und einem Nupsi erklären?
Das ist kontextsensitiv. Gut. So viel zum Lehren und Lernen. Wollen wir noch mehr so Kleinscheiß machen, bevor wir zu den dicken Paketen kommen?
Können auch zum dicken Paket kommen.
Aber ich sehe schon, am Ende kriegen wir das wieder nicht unter.
Ja, ich hab noch eine Frage. Das geht ganz schnell. Ich hab ja dieses Color-Theme fürs Terminal und den Wim-Editor und damals auch für Textmade mal mir ausgedacht. Das SMYCK Color-Theme, color.smyck.org. Darfst du gleich nochmal reinwerfen? Ja, ich wollte das eigentlich für mich selber dokumentieren, damit ich das nie wieder verliere und überall zur Anwendung bringen kann, wo ich es gerne hätte. Das war so die Zeit, wo Textmade 1 noch ganz beliebt war. Dafür habe ich dann auch das Theme damals gleich mitgemacht. Das kommt mal ein bisschen runter, da sieht man das sozusagen so in Aktionen. Und das erfreut sich tatsächlich, auf GitHub habe ich letztens festgestellt, mannigfaltiger Beliebtheit. Und es gibt immer mal wieder so Tweets, die mich so erreichen, so So glad that I found this color-theme, bla bla bla. Irgendwie, ohne dass ich mich da groß bemühe, aber es wird immer mal wieder gefunden und gemocht, so aus ähnlichen Gründen wie ich das gut finde. Und jetzt ist eigentlich mein Problem. Ich kümmere mich wirklich nur um das Terminal-Theme und also für Mac OS und das Vim Color-Theme. Weil die anderen Sachen benutze ich gerade nicht so viel. Deswegen, da ist jetzt gerade noch ein Text-Made-1-Theme drin, aber das ist nicht mehr vollständig sozusagen. Jetzt überlege ich die ganze Zeit, weil auch ganz viele Leute mir Pull-Request schicken, so ich hab das für Eclipse jetzt gemacht, ich hab das jetzt für diesen Editor und so weiter. Und das kann ich halt nicht, also ich will das nicht in das offizielle Repo einfach so reinmergen, ohne es zu testen. Aber irgendwie fände ich es schon gut, wenn es eine gesammelte Stelle gibt, wo es sozusagen gibt, also quasi so ein Contrib-Folder könnte man für Open Source Projekte, wo halt hast du deinen, was weiß ich, Postfix und dann gibt es noch einen Contrib-Folder mit den ganzen Plugins, die man noch dazu nehmen kann. Und jetzt ist meine Frage eigentlich, was ist denn so das beste Open Source Modell, um so ein Contribution Repository zu machen? Also soll man ein extra Repository machen oder mache ich einen Contrib-Folder im gleichen, also in meinem Haupt-Repository und sage einfach, alles was hier drin ist, ist user-contributed? Oder irgendjemand meinte hier Git-Subtree oder Git-Submodule?
Keine Git-Submodules.
Ja, das dachte ich mir auch, aber weil ich noch nie so ein Projekt hatte, wo ich meinen Hauptteil habe, aber auch irgendwie da was so mit reinmachen wollte, wollte ich mal so die Frage in die Runde werfen, was vielleicht...
Also sagen wir mal so, wenn du das als als Subfolder machst, dann musst du dich letzten Endes darum kümmern, sämtliche Pull-Requests, die da an dich herangetragen werden, dann auch zu mergen. Sofern du der einzige Committer bleibst. Aber dann musst du dir halt überlegen, ob du den Aufwand machen möchtest. Wenn du jetzt ein zweites Repo machst und den emsigsten Leuten da das Repo überhilfst, dann läuft das eventuell von alleine.
Ja, also mein Plan war jetzt eigentlich, weil ich das auch eine Farbe habe, ich nämlich kürzlich leicht angepasst, damit das für Endcurses, Interfaces optimaler zu lesen ist. Und dann dachte ich mir auch, ich hab schon angefangen, ich mach noch mal so ein Dokument, wo ich sage, was denn eigentlich die elementaren Bestandteile dieses Color Schemes für Terminal als auch für Programmiersprachen, also das Keywords, diese Farbe haben sollen, Strings und Zahlen sollen diese Farbe haben, weil je nach Programmiersprache ist das auch immer so ein bisschen anders, aber so für den Gesamtflow einmal noch mal so eine schöne Definitionsliste oder einen Serviervorschlag, damit dann die Leute sozusagen, wenn sie sagen, ich will das jetzt für Eklipse oder für Atome oder für sonst was bauen, dass sie sozusagen nicht groß jetzt in irgendwelchen Wim-Files oder so suchen müssen, sondern einfach sehen, Ahja, Strings sollen die Farbe haben. So und so und dann tickert man das so runter. Das wollte ich jetzt noch machen und dann ja wahrscheinlich, ja mach ich doch mal, mach doch einen RFC aus deinem Color Scheme, sagt einer. Nee, die Farben sind schon richtig. Die brauchen keinen Kommentar mehr.
Du dokumentierst das einfach mal als solches. Ich meine derzeit hast du ja jetzt in deinem Readme ein paar Screenshots und so sieht das irgendwie aus. Aber du hast es halt nicht mal richtig durchspezifiziert hingeschrieben. Ich weiß nicht, ob das auf dieser Webseite dazu der Fall ist.
Also da sind die Farben, wenn du da drüber hoverst, dann kommen die noch mal als Hexcode da. Aber ich muss das jetzt noch einmal so...
Einmal aufschreiben und ehrlich gesagt, what can go wrong? Ich meine wir reden hier von Color Schemes für bestimmte Editor. Wenn du den Aufwand treibst, die Speck zu machen, in der einfach steht, das hat so auszusehen, das hat so auszusehen, die Farbe ist und das bezieht sich auf die und die und die Dinger. Ich meine, es ist ja auch immer noch so ein bisschen abhängig von der Sprache, die du da letzten Endes visualisierst, das kannst du gar nicht alles im Griff haben.
Genau, deswegen sage ich ja Serviervorschlag.
Ja genau, andererseits gibt es ja durchaus den Bedarf, alles auch an einem Ort zusammenzutragen. Und von daher würde ich einfach sagen, mach mal eine Speck in deinem Rhythmi, definier es einfach mal genau, das ist vielleicht etwas Arbeit. Dann mach für jedes Programm, machst ein Folder, dazu selber noch ein kleines Rhythmi im Sinne von, von wem ist das und was der Status ist, irgendwie antestet, keine Ahnung. Und dann werft ihr doch alle rein, die ganzen Eclips und hast sie nicht gesehen und Emacs und Pipapo und Editors, wie sie alle heißen. Im schlimmsten Fall ist da was falsch und dann wird es jemand korrigieren und dann wird es richtig.
Also aber du meinst im gleichen Repo?
Ja, ein Repo to lose them all.
Ich würde ja denken, okay, sagen wir mal jetzt, mein Anwendungsfall war ja, du hast ein Mac, willst irgendwie dieses Color Scheme in deinem Terminal haben, vielleicht auch für einen Wim, nimmst du das Repo, bist du glücklich, fertig. Wenn du jetzt auf deiner Plattform mit deiner Editor bist und dann mach ich einen Link auf das Contrib Directory und das kann Gigabyte groß sein und Myriaden und Milliarden von Subfiles haben, aber mein, also wenn ich sozusagen auf dem neuen Mac das installiere, will ich nicht.
Gigabyte groß, Color Scheme?
Weiß schon, aber ich will, also ich denk mir halt so, ich will doch eigentlich jetzt nur dieses kleine Repo da mit diesen zwei Files klonen und nicht irgendwie hunderttausende Editor.
Ja, wenn du Glück hast, wird dein Color Scheme das 99 Bottles of Beer der Color Schemes.
Mir geht's ja gar nicht um Weltrum jetzt, so in dem Sinne, ich bin nur eine schöne Organisation des Ganzen, nochher. Weil, wie gesagt, es ist ja hier irgendwie 934 Leute haben das gestartet und 130 Folks, Donner Schock.
Siehste mal und genau das ist so ein bisschen, also das Konzept und Prinzip leidet hier, glaube ich, mehr unter vielen Folks, wo dann keiner mehr so richtig weiß, was Sache ist. Wenn es einen Ort gibt, wo die Leute sich das Thema runterladen und daraus auch immer wieder aktualisieren. Okay, here we go. Ich meine, du könntest natürlich... Du könntest dir auch noch einen SMYCK GitHub-User anlegen, der dann irgendwie oder das vielleicht bis übertrieben wird. Du könntest einfach verschiedene Repos machen natürlich für die einzelnen Languages oder zumindest zwischen deinem Huckles Original und Vanilla, aber bei der Größe der Dateiten, ich meine, wir reden hier von ein paar hundert Bytes, irgendwie scheiß drauf.
Ja, den Einwand hätte ich jetzt auch noch gebracht, also von Gigabyte redet ja keiner.
Also wenn das mal Gigabyte sind, dann hat dein Color-Theme sozusagen auch schon wirklich die Weltordnung unter sich angeordnet.
Also meine aktuell noch favorisierte Version ist tatsächlich noch das separate Repo, wo wie du sagtest Roddy, vielleicht ich dann noch so irgendwelchen Leuten einfach sage hier, wenn da was kommt, Merch halt rein und sag ist halt Contrib. Na gucken, okay ich frage aber auch so ein bisschen die Hörer, falls da noch jemand irgendwie Ideen oder...
Also das Einzige, was ich mir noch vorstellen könnte, was sinnvoll ist, ist das dieses Dokument, dieses Manifest, das SMYCK Color Manifest, dass das halt ein einzelnes Repo ist, dass du halt, weil dieses Pfeil als Ground Truth vielleicht ein eigenes Repo ist, wo halt nur selten was geändert wird.
Und dann würde ich meine OSX Terminal und Vim-Sachen auch eher in das Contrib Repo mit rein checken.
Genau, in die Distribution. Ja, okay, gut. Ich kann mir halt auch vorstellen, dass wenn das abhebt, dass die Leute dann auch Installer für den Kram basteln und so. Also, ja, möglich, also, don't underestimate.
Das Schöne an diesem OSX Terminal Ding ist, dass du das runterlädst und einfach doppelt draufklicken kannst.
Du meinst Installer, man lädt sich das Color Scheme runter und dann installt er die ganzen Programme dazu.
Genau, die ganzen Defendants.
Oder so rum.
Läuft denn dein TextMate 1.0 mit 2.0?
Ich glaube ja, aber das Problem, was an TextMate mich gerade nervt, die Syntax-Definitionen sind relativ mächtig. Also du kannst pro Sprache auch sehr ins Detail gehen. Aber zum Beispiel ist eine Sache, die ich bei TextMate nicht hinbekomme, dass die Funktionsdefinitionen und der Funktionsaufruf unterschiedlich farbiert sind, coloriert.
Du kannst Hilfe gebrauchen.
Genau, und deswegen, ich hab jetzt schon am Wochenende eine Stunde wieder da reingesteckt, um rauszufinden, wie das bei TextMate zum Beispiel geht. Hab's aber nicht geschafft. Und dann kam so dieser kleine Frust, ich will mich eigentlich nur um Vim und OS X Terminal kümmern und der Rest bitte anderweitig. Das Problem ist aber auch bei diesem Farbschema und deswegen hab ich so ein bisschen Sorge, eigentlich kann es mir auch egal sein, wenn das ein bisschen abweicht, weil zum Beispiel Mac Vim hat anderes Farbmanagement als Mac OS selbst. Das heißt, wenn ich im Color Picker von OS X die Farben so, wie ich sie gerne hätte, auswähle, dann werden die in Vim anders gerennt. Deswegen sind die Farben, die in dem Vim-Themen drinstehen, die sind von mir quasi mundgepinselt korrigiert, damit die so aussehen wie im Mac OS Farbmanagement. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt hingehst und...
Das Farbmanagement deines Editors funktioniert nicht.
Das heißt... Genau, und dann nimmst du halt Eclipse oder was auch immer und die machen dann nochmal ihr Java-Gui-Color-Management, und wenn du die Hex-Codes da eintippst, dann sieht das wieder ganz anders aus. Und das ist sozusagen mein... Als Gestalter im Herzen ist das sozusagen das Problem, womit ich noch ein bisschen hadere, wie ich damit halt umgehen möchte. Es gibt halt auch keinen Weg, Farbe so richtig absolut gültig zu definieren. Das hängt halt immer vom Betrachter und dem Gerät und dem OS und dem Programm und so weiter ab.
Das ist echt nervig.
iTerm hatte das nämlich auch. Deswegen hatte ich da auch eine Zeit lang mal iTerm benutzt und da sind die Farben dann auch wieder anders. Ich hoffe, das haben sie mittlerweile korrigiert, aber boah, ich wollte nur ein Farb-Thema bis Terminal, das ist da schon ausgeartet.
Ja, Perfektionismus ist eben ein bisschen anstrengender.
Na ja, anyway, das war ja nur das kurze Thema. Wenn ihr als Hörer noch irgendwelche Vorschläge habt, könnt ihr mir die gerne per Twitter oder irgendwie so noch zukommen lassen oder in den Kommentaren von der Freak Show. Ich schau da mal rein. Und ansonsten, Hippie-Coding mit dem Farbschema eurer Wahl.
So, jetzt kann ich ja mal ein bisschen berichten.
Wollen wir das große, die Nachricht als erstes?
Können wir machen.
Die ist ja auch nicht so groß.
Das machen wir jetzt mal.
Das muss schon sein.
Genau. Apple macht den Mac Pro, Pro Again. Hier nachhaltig gefordert. Also was ist passiert? Es gab ein...
Roundtable?
Ja, so einen kleinen geschlossenen Presse-Event, wo so vier, fünf Journalisten geladen wurden, damit Apple mal so seine Story erzählen kann und die kurze Version ist. Apple scheint langsam begriffen zu haben, dass sie sich da in eine Sackgasse bewegt haben.
Kurzfristig. Kurzfristig gesagt haben, scheinbar auch.
Es scheint noch nicht so lange her zu sein. Ich glaube, das hat auch so ein bisschen was mit der Antwort auf das MacBook Pro zu tun gehabt. Also diese negative Rückmeldung der Community mit Leute geht es noch. Das hat sie verstört. Und in dem Zuge ist ihnen wohl auch klar geworden, dass es so mit dem Mac Pro nicht so weitergeht. Was auch immer sie da vorher gedacht haben, ob sie wirklich der Meinung waren, sie könnten das Ding irgendwie auslaufen lassen, die Leute würden dann schon irgendwie mit iMacs glücklich sein und mit MacBooks und so weiter. Jetzt scheint sich das zumindest eingehend geändert zu haben, dass sie sagen, ok, alles klar, the Mac Pro is dead, lang lebe der Mac Pro, dieses bekloppte Design, die Tonne in die Tonne. Wobei, ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube es zwar schon, nein doch, das Ding verschwindet, ich glaube das Ding verschwindet, die baut hier nicht noch.
Die Ansage war, dass sie sich mit diesem Formel-Design in die Ecke designt hätten und dass sie einfach so, wie das Teil gebaut ist, halt einfach nicht die neuen Karten und Prozessoren einbauen können. Das haben sie ja so gesagt.
Aber sie haben auch gesagt, dass sie durchaus eine Kundschaft hatten, die damit auch glücklich wurde. Das glauben wir auch. Das sind nicht wir, aber das sind auch nicht andere, aber es gibt so Leute.
Also da kann ich kurz mal rein grätschen vielleicht, weil wir hatten so ein bisschen die Diskussion bei uns im Lab und wir haben so eine Mülltonne bei uns im Lab stehen und der Vorteil von dem Ding ist halt in der Tat, man kann es halt schnell auf eine Konferenz mitbringen, wenn du ein großes Setup für eine Visualisierung hast, also mit mehr als zwei, drei Monitoren. Und das natürlich, du kannst ja ins Handgepäck mitnehmen, also das kannst du halt auch nicht mit jedem etwas leistungsstarkeren Gerät. Also guck nicht so, Tim, es ist in der Tat so. Du wuchst schockiert.
Nein, das ist genau das, was auch meine Vermutung war. Weil also, meine wir wollen gerne die Kiste eigentlich eher unter den Tisch stellen. Das Ding ist dafür gebaut worden. Das Ding ist halt mehr ein Desktop. Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und ist von daher halt sehr platzbar, leise auch. Das sind ja alles gute Sachen. Ist ja nichts schlecht daran, dass ein Rechner leise ist und dass er trotzdem eine gewisse Performance dabei bringt. Ist auch nicht scheiße, dass er gut aussieht. Ob der das jetzt tut, das ist jetzt nochmal so eine Sache. Ich denke auch dieser Trashcan-Monika...
Ich glaube, du hättest die ganze Zeit mit Lettys Wasserflasche schauen.
Ja, ich trinke für gewöhnlich immer aus einem Mac Pro Gehäuse.
Also dein Wasser war noch nie so kühl und so leise.
Noch nie so leise.
Letty Pro.
Letty Pro. Also ich möchte ja auch eine Wasserbehälter haben, an der ich Dinge anschließen kann. Also muss ja immer erweiterbar alles sein. So mit den ganzen Anschlüssen.
Sechsmal Gardena oder so.
Zum Beispiel.
Also was haben sie angekündigt? Sie haben angekündigt, erstens, es wird einen neuen Mac Pro geben.
Halleluja!
Nicht mehr dieses Jahr. Er wird irgendwie modular sein. Er wird auch seinen eigenen Bildschirm mitbringen. Also keinen eingebauten. Es wird auch wieder einen Bildschirm geben von Apple. Ich mutmaße mal der 5K-Monitor, den sie jetzt irgendwie schon seit einem Jahr haben. Warum auch nicht? Ich meine, ich brauch sie eigentlich nur hinstellen. Fertig. So und die eigentliche Frage ist natürlich, was wird jetzt an dem Ding dann anders sein als bisher? Weil, dass sie jetzt komplett zu dem guten, alten Cheese Grater, Alu Mac Pro zurückgehen, glaube damit rechnet niemand und das wäre eigentlich auch Quatsch.
Aber es wird sicherlich so was Ähnliches sein. Also Griffe dran zu haben ist sinnvoll. Ein großes Gehäuse zu haben, wo man Sachen reinbauen kann, ist sinnvoll. Sie haben extra gesagt, der soll modular sein, sodass man ihn updaten kann. Das heißt, du wirst irgendeinen M2-Slot für SD-Karten haben. Du wirst vielleicht auch ein paar Bays für normale Laufwerke haben. Dann kannst du Steckkarten reinstecken. Hallo, das Ding wird aussehen wie ein PC, aber halt schöner designt, weil Apple halt designt.
Also wo ich zum Beispiel mir nicht so sicher wäre, ist, dass wir einen Rechner erhalten, in dem so offene, schwärende PCI-Slots rumlungern. Wäre ich mir nicht so sicher.
Wenn du da alle halbe Jahre deine Karte, deine Grafikkarte tauschen willst, dann brauchst du einen Slot dafür.
Und wenn du mehr als eine Karte willst? Nein, nein.
Zwei Sachen musst du unterscheiden. Wenn man die Grafikkarte tauschen kann oder wenn du die Grafikkarte tauschen willst, das sind zwei komplett andere Sachen. Sie haben nicht versprochen, dass du selber die Grafikkarte tauschen kannst. Sie haben bestenfalls versprochen, dass man die Grafikkarte tauschen kann. Ob diese Grafikkarte von Nvidia direkt irgendwie, klicke ich mir auf Amazon, eine neue PCI-Karte ist oder ob es in irgendeiner Form Apple-Stecker geben wird, in dem die Grafikkarte da sozusagen reingefahren wird, ist offen.
Also wenn ich Intel in der Schublade schon den neuen Connector hat, der jetzt irgendwie so, wir wollen jetzt den Nachfolger des PCI-Express, irgendwas Busses bauen und dafür gibt es einen neuen Connector und den haben sie in der Schublade und der kommt dann im halben Jahr. Und Apple hat jetzt von denen mal die Sonne gezeigt bekommen und dann bauen sie das Teil da ein, dann kann ich mir keinen Weg um den PCI-Express herum vorstellen. Kann ich mir nicht. Also ein proprietärer Apple-Stecker, also aus der Zeit sind wir jetzt raus so ein bisschen.
Na wieso? Es gibt ja jetzt schon Alternativen.
USB-C, ja gut, aber...
Nein, nicht USB-C. Thunderbolt 3 ist PCI-Express, die M2-Slots sind PCI-Express. Also es gibt schon Alternativen.
Ja, aber du kannst in den M2-Slots keine Grafikkarten-Boliden-Dingsy reinschrauben.
Nein, den M2-Slots kannst du nicht machen. Ich sag nur, es gibt alternative Steckerformate. Ich weiß doch, was das für ein Hessell ist, in diesen Rechner eine PCI-Karte reinzubauen.
Deswegen sage ich ja.
Dann musst du da hinten drücken und ran schrauben und so weiter. Das ist einfach nicht Apple-like.
Nein, deswegen sage ich ja, wenn Intel so etwas schon in der Schublade hat, die Pläne schon hat, wir wollen jetzt diesen Connector, der endlich mal funktioniert und nicht dieses ständige, ich knackele die Karte rein, bis sie dann passt und muss sie oben mit der Schraube festschrauben. Wenn die das mal in den Griff kriegen, dann wird Apple sicherlich diesen Connector benutzen. Aber Apple wird nicht seinen eigenen Connector designen. Das sehe ich nicht.
Hab ich auch nicht gesagt, dass sie das tun. Ich habe nur gesagt, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, dass wir einen Rechner bekommen werden, der solche PCI-Slots hat, wie wir das heute sehen. Es wäre viel besser, du hast ein modulares Casing, wo du so eine Karte reinsteckst, wo du auch so eine Grafikkarte reinsteckst, die nicht mit ihren eigenen kleinen drei Miii-Ventilatoren auf der Karte draufkommt, sondern die sich in so ein thermales Design einpflegen und einfach von allem mitgekühlt werden. Und dann brauchst du vielleicht eine spezielle Adaptierung, aber ist zumindest möglich. Und wenn Apple auch selber committet und sagt, wir werden hier einmal pro Jahr das Schnellste, was es auf dem Markt gibt, einfach mal liefern und fertig, dann schreit auch keiner.
Aber das klingt für mich noch viel unrealistischer, als dass sie, also so wie das jetzt so klingt, dieses kleine, ja stimmt, war jetzt nicht so gut mit dem und so, und wir bauen euch jetzt einen modularen Rechner wieder. Also die haben ja auch gesagt, sie haben ganz viel mit ihren Profs da geschnackt, was sie denn gerne hätten und die haben bestimmt nicht alle gesagt, ja, also Apple, es wäre richtig geil, wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie so ein System hat, wo wir wieder nicht die Karten selber wechseln können und wieder nicht selber irgendwie die Hardware updaten können, sondern zu euch in den Laden rennen müssen. Und die haben garantiert genau gesagt, alter, wenn da neuer Grafik-Polide draußen ist, wollen wir den reinschrauben. Alter, wenn da neuer Audio-Hardware da ist, wollen wir die reinschrauben.
Ich könnte mir aber auch vorstellen, dass es so wie mit den Festplatten, dass es dann einfach solche Base gibt, wo du die Karte reinsteckst.
Solange, also mein Punkt ist...
So ein Adapter und dann steckst du das da mit rein.
Mein Punkt wäre halt vom User und nicht, weil du ja meintest, dass Apple das vielleicht dann im Zweifel machen muss und du...
Also meine Meinung ist, Apple kann sich's nicht leisten, gegen einen Industriestandard konträr zu entwickeln. Und wenn der nicht von Intel kommt, dann kommt er wahrscheinlich nirgendwo her.
Welchen Industriestandard?
Was auch immer dann PCI ablösen wird.
Nein, es wird alles PCI sein.
Ja, elektrisch schon, aber ich rede jetzt vom Connector und von der eigentlichen mechanischen Bauweise. Du hast ja vollkommen recht, wenn du sagst, du willst eine Grafikkarte haben, die in einem, wie soll ich sagen, in einer Bay drin ist, die die Grafikkarte so kühlt, dass die Grafikkarte selber keine, keine Mücken, nach Mücken klingenden Lüfter hat. Nur Apple kann sich es nicht leisten, so etwas gegen einen Industriestandard zu entwickeln, sondern es kann nur gehen, wenn sie sagen, so hier Nvidia, hier Intel, hier AMD, wir setzen es in ein Boot und wir machen das jetzt. Und wenn, wenn, wenn da ein ordentlicher Standard bei rauskommt, dann bauen wir den Mac Pro, wo wir uns dann hinstellen können, wir sind die Ersten, die das machen, und das ist die beste Idee und überhaupt, und ihr werdet sehen, alle anderen werden das auch so machen. Sondern sonst wird es nichts.
Also, Glaskugelnotation Nummer eins.
Was wir nicht sehen werden, denke ich, sind dreieinhalb Zoll Drive Base, oder? Auch für dich die ganz geil.
Ich würde es nicht per se ausschließen, aber ja, ich weiß nicht. Also ich kann mir vorstellen, so ein Mac Pro, also wenn man so ein Cheese Grater, wie er immer genannt wird, die Käse reibe. Wenn du so ein Gerät hast und das geil findest, dann unter anderem, weil du da halt ein paar Platten reinschrauben kannst. Wenn du Video machst, keine Ahnung, jeden Tag irgendwie eine halbe Stunde auf YouTube hoch lädst oder irgendwie sowas. Wenn du richtig Videoproduktion machst, dann willst du natürlich auch den Plattenplatz haben. Klar, es gibt für all das externe Lösungen. Aber, ne?
Also zum Beispiel, ich meine, ich hab zwei SSDs und zwei große Platten drin. Die eine große Platte ist eine 3TB Platte, die quasi interne Backup Time Machine ist. Und das ist einfach nur großartig, dass die intern ist, die Time Machine Platte, und nicht irgendwo da rumdödelt und dann wieder ranstöpseln und dann diese Kabel suchen und keine Ahnung. Also zumindest zwei solche Slots fände ich schon geil. Vielleicht sollten wir auch... Was wünschen wir uns vom neuen Mac Pro? Fragen statt zu mutmaßen, was sie denn wirklich tun. Also ich hätte tatsächlich gerne... Sie können gerne so 2,5 Zoll Slots und zwei 3,5 Zoll Slots reinbauen.
Wobei ich mir die 2,5 Zoll Slots wiederum nicht vorstellen kann. Also wenn du mal guckst, was richtig rotierende 2,5 Zoll Platten kosten, dann kriegst du die nicht zu dem Preis, also wenn du sie nackt kaufst, kriegst du sie nicht zu dem Preis, wie wenn du sie kaufst mit USB-Gehäuse außenrum. Also es hat überhaupt keinen Sinn vorzusehen, dass man 2,5 Zoll Platten nachbaut.
Das ist halt nur das SSD-Standardformat für selber.
Ja, aber dann kannst du halt auch M2 Slots vorsehen. Dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass sie 4 M2 Slots reinbauen. Und dann, naja, das ist so...
Ich werd das gleich eh noch erklären in unserem Clip mal. Genau.
Also dass sie 2 oder 4 M2 Slots vorsehen, damit du entsprechend viele SSDs in diesem Format da reinpacken kannst. Das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen. Und vielleicht fliegen dann die 3,5 Zoll Slots raus. Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn du wirklich viel Platz brauchst, und der muss jetzt nicht super schnell sein, dann ist so eine 3,5 Zoll Platte auch irgendwie immer noch eine gute Alternative.
Ja, da macht aber auch nur das 3,5 Zoll Format Sinn.
Ja, ok, ich war von M2, hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Ja, 3,5 Zoll kannst du ja jetzt so eine 6 oder 8 TB Platte kaufen für wenig Taler. Und dann hast du die so als... so. Aber in dem Moment, wo man auf SSD schielt, ich glaube da ist einfach dieser Drive-Formfaktor, das ist jetzt over. Ja, außerdem soll es noch einen iMac für Pro-User geben, mit dem schönen Hinweis, dass sie ja auch festgestellt hätten, dass immer mehr Pro-User auch iMacs benutzen. Ja, kein Wunder, wenn ihr Mac Pro so scheiße ist.
Wenn ihr nichts anderes zum Verkauf habt und der Gebrauchtmarkt für die alten Mac Pros im Preis nach oben geht.
Und ich meine gerade dieser 5K iMac, ich meine irgendwie 4 Pixel Retina. Na ja gut, aber nicht für jeden Pro ist ja die Grafik jetzt das Wichtigste. Das gibt es natürlich auf jeden Fall auch und das ist glaube ich auch da, wo es am meisten problematisch gerade ist. Aber man hat ja auch manchmal einfach nur, soll schnelle CPU haben, soll irgendwie ordentlich durchatmen, soll irgendwie alle schnitten haben und soll einen geilen Monitor haben und darf dann auch ein paar hundert Euro mehr kosten. Und das ist ja eigentlich bei dem iMac schon gegeben. Und ich wundere mich halt auch, wenn sie sich dazu nicht äußern wollten, was mit dem Mac Mini ist. Weil sie meinten ja zumindest, der wäre jetzt nicht tot. Er wäre Teil des Line-Ups. Jetzt können sie den aber nicht auch noch drei Jahre lang irgendwie so in seinem Zombie-Modus da vorhalten, weil das Ding ist ja auch heftig in der Kritik, weil der aktuelle Mac Mini schon alle enttäuscht hatten, die vorher Mac Minis hatten, weil dann irgendwie keine Dual-Quad-Core-Optionen mehr und du kriegst nicht mehr so Platten rein und so. Den Mac Mini können sie meiner Meinung nach halt auch mal so mit M2 in mind bauen. Das wäre halt irgendwie auch mal so ein Statement. Dass du einfach so einen Mac Mini hast, der so ein bisschen SSD aufgelötet hat und dann kannst du aber da noch irgendwie solche M2-Karten reinschieben und aus dem Ding eine ordentliche Performance und Storage geben und vielleicht eben auch noch einen ordentlichen stromsparenden Quad-Core da rein und dann sind eigentlich auch schon wieder alle zufrieden. Weil sowas könnte ich zum Beispiel auch gebrauchen. Ich bräuchte mal so einen stromsparenden Rechner, so einen Mac, der immer läuft. Aber nur um so wichtige Dinge zu machen wie Syncing und Backup und Time Machine und diesen ganzen Bimm Bimm, da muss ich jetzt nicht unbedingt immer so einen Mac Pro laufen haben.
Dafür ist er super.
Dafür wäre er super, aber ich kaufe mir natürlich jetzt keinen Mac Mini.
Dann wähl mal nur einen von 2012.
Ja, eben. Und das mir dann nicht doch.
Doch, es ist das gleiche wie beim Mac Pro. Du willst keinen 2014 Mac Mini haben.
Ja, ist das gleiche, aber ein 2012 Mac Mini ist halt nicht in der Liga, wo ein 2012 Mac Pro ist.
Nee, das nicht. Ja, aber dafür verbraucht er auch weniger Strom. Das war ja das, was du haben solltest.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, da bin ich noch zu wenig, vielleicht auch persönlich zu wenig, investiert in Mac Mini, wenn ich das so sage.
Naja, entweder du willst wenig Stromverbrauch haben oder nicht.
Die Scheiße ist, diese sieben Jahre alten Rechner kosten ja auch immer noch horrende Summen, weil die einfach so nachgepackt sind.
Das ist bei den Mac Minis genauso.
Das meine ich ja. Die Mac Minis sind immer noch alle teuer. Uraltes Zeug ist echt unfassbar. Ja, also ich weiß nicht, kann man da irgendwie noch viel zu sagen, außer dass wir jetzt nochmal ein Jahr warten müssen, aber dass es vermutlich zumindest spannende Nachrichten gibt.
Das mit dem Jahr ist nicht, das haben sie so nicht gesagt. Sie sagten nur, nicht mehr dieses Jahr. Das kann auch übernächstes Jahr heißen.
Das bringen sie nicht.
Ja, sehe ich auch so, aber es ist nur so, dass sie gesagt haben, sie nicht nächstes Jahr.
Ich glaube auch, wenn das so weit weg wäre.
Dann hätten sie es mal auch nicht so weit aufreißen können. Sie wissen auch, dass sie sich jetzt selber enorm unter Druck gesetzt haben und dass sie jetzt liefern müssen.
Und zwar zacki. Meiner Meinung nach ist das Sinnvollste, was sie tun können, ist ein normales Desktop PC mit einem hübschen Gehäuse und gib ihm. Das ist genau das, was die meisten Leute da draußen einfach haben wollen.
Die jetzt mit den anderen Rechnern nicht glücklich sind, genau.
Genau, das ist das, was die Leute eigentlich haben wollen. Die haben ja auch nicht die Erwartung, dass der jetzt besonders so ist, sondern einfach mal eine ordentliche Büchse, die man sich unter den Tisch stellen kann, wo man alles reinschrauben kann, was man haben will und fertig. Das ist genau die Anwendung.
Genau, wenn du mich jetzt fragst, welchen neuen Mac, also welchen Ersatz für diesen Mac da unter dem Tisch, in modernen und ein bisschen Stromspannender, aber im Prinzip genau das.
Und es werden alle Mac Pro-Kunden da draußen sagen, wenn sie ein Gerät neu haben wollen, dann wie Cheese Grater, aber halt in schöner.
Ohne CD-Laufwerk.
Genau, ein bisschen kompakter kann ja schon auch sein, glaube ich einfach, aber wie gesagt, wir sagen ja nicht umsonst oder wir reden ja nicht seit Generatoren davon, wie du immer so schon sagst, wie toll dieses Gerät ist und was man da nicht alles mitmachen kann. Und genau, das ist das schönste, tollste Gerät, was Apple jemals gebaut hat.
Genau.
Wieder haben will.
Und weil es das schönste und tollste Gerät ist, habe ich mich auch dieses Themas in der letzten Zeit mal wieder angenommen und das bedeutet...
Das bedeutet...
Unsere beliebte Bastelstunde.
Und diesmal ohne Dennis, also du musst jetzt...
Liefern.
Aber es ist auch dein erstes Mal, insofern bin ich sicher, dass die Community dir wohlgesonnen gegenübersteht.
Naja, auf jeden Fall gibt es ja jetzt erstmal noch ein bisschen Feedback. Wir hatten ja hier schon viel darüber gesprochen, über dieses WLAN-Bluetooth-Modul, was wir uns ja dann letzten Endes, hab ja dann für dich mitbestellt, gekauft haben. Das ist quasi so ein aktuelles Kärtchen, wo nicht nur eben WLAN drauf ist, sondern eben auch noch aktuelles Bluetooth. Also es ersetzt die WLAN-Karte in den Mac Pro, wo der vorher, ich weiß gar nicht, wenn man die WLAN-Karte hat, was hat man dann? 802N wahrscheinlich, also so halbwegs brauchbares WLAN-Max da gegeben haben. Wahrscheinlich auch schon mit 5 Gigahertz, aber halt nix fancy Schmenzie-mäßiges. Und jetzt hat auf jeden Fall mit dieser neuen Karte hat man sozusagen das, was man so heute haben will. Also 802 11ac mit 5 Gigahertz und 3 Antennen. Die 3 Antennen sind ja da auch schon drin in diesem Macintosh von 2009, das ist unglaublich. Und außerdem hat der Mac auch schon Bluetooth, aber eben nur Bluetooth 2.0.
Also der 2012er mit 2012 Mac Pro hat 802N und Bluetooth 2.1 plus EDR.
Genau, das ist etwa der letzte Stand der Dinge gewesen. Und die Bluetooth-Karte hab ich drin, die WLAN-Karte hab ich nicht drin. So, jetzt kriegt man dieses Paket aus den USA, zahlt dann nochmal ordentlich ein vor Umsatzsteuer am Zoll, weil ist so.
Und hat einen spaßigen Vormittag am Zollamt.
Ja, das ging relativ fix.
Wenn man um 11. aufkreuzt, ist super, da ist keine Sau.
Ja, das ging ratzefatz. Wenn man sich vorher die FAQ durchliest und seine Rechnung und seine Paypal-Zahlung schön ausgedruckt auf den Tisch legt, dann geht das da ratzefatz schnell.
Ja, wenn man erstmal dran ist, ist ja auch kein Problem.
Wie gesagt, du musst halt zu Zeiten hingehen, wo die anderen Leute alle arbeiten.
Ja, einfach morgens hinfahren, war gar kein Thema. Ich war da nach 10 Minuten durch. So, dann hab ich's eingebaut. Das ist ja immer so eine Sache. Da musst du halt irgendwie so deine CPU-Schublade da rausziehen, die Kiste entstöpseln. Und ja, dann schraubst du dieses neue Modul da rein. Also ich hatte vorher noch kein WLAN-Modul, von daher musste ich nichts rausnehmen. Und ja, der Mac Pro hat da schon drei WLAN-Antennen rumliegen. Die muss man dann nur mal aus seinen Schlüpfer rausprokeln und dann halt auf diese Karte draufdrücken. Das heißt, du hast diese Minifitzel-Antennen-Kontakte auf dieser Karte drauf.
So dieses super Mini-Koax-Stecker.
Genau, dieses super Mini-Koax-Stecker. Das ist so ein bisschen, da musst du gut unterwegs sein, ein bisschen Konzentration und gutes Licht.
Tonabnehmersysteme wechseln ist auch nicht ganz ohne. Tonabnehmersysteme von Bandspielern. Ich sag nur, wenn du dich beschwerst.
Ja gut, hab ich auf jeden Fall hinbekommen. Und dann kommt ja dieses Teil noch mit zwei Verlängerungskabeln. Das erste Verlängerungskabel ist nämlich auch für die Antenne. Du musst ja, da da jetzt auch Bluetooth drauf ist, willst du unter anderem die Bluetooth-Antenne, die dein Rechner ja auch schon hat, benutzen. Die ist aber so weit weg, dass du die eben verlängern musst. Das heißt, da musst du dann nicht nur diesen Stecker auf die Platine draufkriegen, sondern da musst du den Stecker auf das andere Kabel draufkriegen. Das wird nochmal so extra fitzlig. Hab ich aber auch hinbekommen. Da war ich ganz stolz auf mich. Und außerdem musst du noch die alte Bluetooth-Karte ausstöpseln und durch die neue ersetzen. Das ist dann ein USB-Stecker, aber eben nicht so ein Standard-USB-A-Stecker, sondern eben so ein komischer... Platinen-Dings-Stecker. Sie liefern auf jeden Fall so ein Verlängerungskabel mit. Da steckst du halt auf der einen Seite auf deine neue Karte und dann an den Stecker, wo normalerweise eben die alte Karte dran hängt. Da werden halt nochmal so 20 cm überbrückten. Das ist alles wunderbar. Ja, zusammengebaut, eingeschaltet, alles lief. Also so... Out of the Box hab ich jetzt AirDrop, ich hab irgendwie meine AirPods am Start. Das Ding kann jetzt irgendwie alles, das macht irgendwie AC, W-Lanen.
Hast du auch mehr als vier V-Modes? Das war doch das letzte Mal das Problem, dass du nicht alle V-Modes ansprechen konntest.
Letzte Mal im Sinne von...
Vor drei Wochen oder wann das war?
Ja, das ist das einzige Problem, das ich noch habe, ist, dass mit dem neuen Bluetooth-Modul die Stabilität meiner V-Modes schwankt. Ich hab noch nicht ganz rausgefunden, woran es liegt. Ich musste alles neu perren, weil es ein komplett neues Bluetooth-Modul ist, neue MAC-Adresse und alles. Ich hab das dann auch mal so deep resettet. Das scheint mir aber ein spezifisches Problem mit diesen V-Modes zu sein. Ich muss jetzt noch mal gucken, ob das mit neueren V-Modes sich genauso verhält wie mit älteren V-Modes. Das hab ich noch nicht so ganz rausgefunden. Das ist auf jeden Fall noch eine der nervigen Aspekte, aber ansonsten ist der Tausch an sich schon mal ganz gut. Ja, und wo ich dann gerade dabei war, dachte ich mir, ich hab jetzt irgendwie meine schicke SSD-Platte, die ich mir mal gekauft habe, anstatt des CD-Laufwerks, oder parallel zum CD-Laufwerk angeschlossen. Weil da war ja noch ein SATA-Port frei. Also man kann ja zwei...
Ah, zwei optische Laufwerke können da ja rein, ne?
Genau. Für Leute, die viel DVDs kopieren und so weiter, war das ja irgendwie mal gedacht damals, als man sowas noch vielleicht in den Umständen mal getan hat. Das gab ja mal ein Mac Pro, der hatte nur ein Laufwerk, und dann kam die neue Version raus, und die hatte halt zwei Laufwerkschächte, warum auch immer. Naja, Dinge, die sie beim nächsten Mac Pro nicht unbedingt nochmal machen müssen.
Also Schächte für optische Laufwerke, ich glaube, da sind wir uns einig.
Wir können gerne draußen bleiben.
Da sind wir uns einig, das war mal.
Naja, und wie das nochmal so ist, wenn man erstmal die interne Festplatte gegen eine SSD austauscht, egal wie die an diesen Rechner angeschlossen ist, das ist ja alles schon so sehr viel geiler als der ganze Festplatten-Quatsch, den man vorher hatte. Worüber haben wir uns früher gefreut, wenn eine Festplatte so was wie 30 Megabyte, äh, nee, weniger, noch 10 Megabyte pro Sekunde war schon...
Das war schon länger her.
Das ist ja auch schon länger her.
Also, so modernere Festplatten waren schon ein bisschen schneller.
Ja, ich glaube 30.
30 war so das, was man so erreichen konnte. 40 vielleicht, also mit so normalen Festplatten.
Spinning Rust ist, glaube ich, immer noch so.
Ja, aber so SATA-Speed ausreizen bis an die Grenze mit Festplatten.
Not even close.
Fand einfach nicht statt.
Ja, ja, ne, natürlich nicht, weil die sind halt so langsam.
Genau, so, schraubst du dir so eine SSD rein, die einen SATA-Anschluss hat, machst du dann da 150 Megabyte pro Sekunde, dann denkst du dir nur so, Halleluja, wie geil schnell jetzt hier alles ist. Na, über SATA 2 geht halt nicht mehr. Eben. Und deswegen war ich erst mal glücklich. Und jetzt dachte ich mir so, hmmm, meine Platte kann aber mehr als 150 Megabyte pro Sekunde. Und zwar deutlich. Warum nutze ich das eigentlich nicht aus? Ah, mein Mac Pro hat ja gar keinen SATA 3 Interface. Und dann habe ich mal so ein bisschen geguckt und dachte mir so, hm, kann ja eigentlich gar nicht so schwierig sein. Natürlich gibt es tonnenweise so SATA 3 PCI-Controller, kriegst du dafür kein Geld hinterher geschmissen. Einzige Problem ist nur, dass wenn ich die Platten dann da oben lasse, dass ich dann irgendwie so...
Mit den Kabeln.
Mit den Kabeln, mit Verlängerungskabel. Da hatte ich mir dann schon so Verlängerungskabel rausgesucht. Das muss doch auch eine andere Lösung geben. Und dann habe ich so ein bisschen geklickt und habe dann tatsächlich ein Produkt gefunden, nämlich den Sedna SSD Adapter PCI Express SATA 3.
Oh, wie früher man schraubt die Platten wieder auf die Karte drauf.
Und das ist einfach so eine kleine PCI-Karte mit SATA-Controller und PCI. Und du schreibst dann einfach deine 2,5 Zoll Platte da einfach direkt drauf und steckst sie da rein. Und dann ist sie mit SATA 3 angeschlossen.
Bam-Blam.
Bam-Blam. Na ja, Gesägtun getan. Kam dann irgendwie aus Hongkong, reingesteckt, geil, 330 Megabyte pro Sekunde, so badam, mal so eben die Performance verdoppelt. Für 36,36 Euro. Fand ich irgendwie eine korrekte Investition. Den Slot hatte ich noch irgendwie frei. Und das waren dann irgendwie jetzt schon so zwei Pimp-Aktionen in a row, die ich da so gebracht habe, die relativ problemlos liefen. Und jetzt werde ich so langsam ein bisschen übermütig.
Hast du schon deine USB-C-Karte bestellt?
Ja, und dann habe ich mich vor allem mal in diese ganze... Das mit dem SATA ist doch eigentlich auch schon wieder durch. Und dann habe ich mal angefangen, mich mal so in diese aktuelle PC-Steckerwelt einzulesen.
Jetzt kommt da der M2.
Ja, jetzt kommt der M2, weil du vorhin auch schon so, ja, M2, wie war es? Hab ich da was verpasst? Genau so ging es mir irgendwie auch. Und dann habe ich mal irgendwie erst mal so ein bisschen versucht, rauszufinden, wovon wir eigentlich reden. So, und jetzt kommen die Begrifflichkeiten. Zwei Dinge muss man nämlich unterscheiden. Erstens, also kurze Anmerkung noch zu dieser Karte, die ich da gefunden habe. Das ist halt so eine billige Hongkong-Bude.
Schmeiß mal den Link im Chat.
Naja, genau, ich noch nicht im Chat-Rinde schmische. Die jetzt irgendwie günstig zu haben war. Es gibt natürlich aus der Apple-Hardware-Zulieferer-Abteilung von OWC und Sonnet, Tech in den USA, gibt es auch Karten, die auch das Gleiche machen. Und es gibt auch welche, wo man sogar zwei Platten draufschrauben kann. Wo man sich denkt, wieso nicht gleich zwei und so weiter. Das kann ja nicht das Problem sein. Erstmal sind die sehr schwierig zu kriegen und dann kosten die halt sowas wie 100 Euro für eine Karte, wo du eine Platte draufschreibst und 300 Euro, wo du zwei draufschraubst.
Also Leute, echt wirklich.
Deswegen war ich so froh, dass ich dieses billige Teil gefunden habe, was einfach mal das Richtige getan hat, keine Treiber einfach reinstecken geht. So, aber da dachte ich mir so, jetzt läuft also meine SSD auf SATA 3 Speed, aber immer noch so auf Maximum. Also guck, was kann denn das Ding eigentlich so liefern? Da geht schon noch ein bisschen mehr. Braucht man halt bloß mal irgendwie ein schnelleres Interface, gibt es aber halt einfach nicht mit SATA. So, wie macht man denn das dann heute eigentlich? Es gibt jetzt einen Nachfolger von dem PCI-Schlecker. Und das ist dieses M2, auch bekannt als Next Generation Format. FF, NGFF, das andere F nochmal, weiß ich nicht. Also erst hieß es NGFF, das findet man auch in vielen Produktbeschreibungen. Nein, nein, nein, NGFF, nicht durcheinanderbringen. Du weißt auch, man muss so erklären, dass man die Leute da abholt, die vielleicht stehen, weil ich stand da ja vor kurzem auch.
Next Generation Form Factor.
Form Factor, genau, das war's. Der Next Generation Form Factor heißt jetzt M2, nicht M2, also man sagt M2, aber schreibt es M2. Und M2 alleine sagt jetzt auch erst mal gar nichts aus.
Das ist nur ein Stecker, ne?
Das ist erst mal nur ein Stecker.
Und eine Bauform letzten Endes. Wie groß ist das Zeug, was man da reinsteckt?
Ja, wobei da gibt es dann auch nochmal verschiedene Varianten. Es gibt da verschiedene Breiten und vor allem auch verschiedene Längen. Auch wenn es nur eine Breite gibt, die sich eigentlich wirklich etabliert hat, das sind diese 22 Millimeter, also für diese Module. Und dann in verschiedenen Längen. Das heißt, wenn man so eine PCI-Karte kauft, die M2 aufnimmt, dann steht da normalerweise dabei, ist gemacht für 22,40, 22,80. Das ist halt immer so, wie lang das Ding ist.
Ja, es gibt diese halbe und ganze Länge.
Ja, aber wenn du nämlich ein SSD-Modul da reinstecken willst und viel drauf haben willst, dann brauchst du halt die volle Länge. Die dürfen nicht so dick sein. Und sind es also von daher vor allem lang. Und jetzt ist aber die Frage, was spricht man denn über diesen Stecker eigentlich tatsächlich? Und natürlich ist so dieses, naja, dann nehmen wir mal so eine SSD, eine billige, wird ja schon schnell genug sein. Da muss man nämlich darauf achten. Es gibt einfach eine Menge M2-PCI-Karten, also quasi ja nur Adapter. Denen macht nichts anderes, als die PCI-Signale auf diesen Stecker drauf zu legen. Mehr ist da nicht drauf. Aber die meisten, die du kriegst, oder viele eben, sind in so einem SATA-Modus. Dieser M2-Stecker, der kann nämlich mit seinem Vodi-Stecker auch nochmal so ein Keying haben. Dann gibt es sogenannte M-Keys und B-Keys. Und B macht halt SATA und M macht halt richtig PCI. Worauf man achten möchte, ist, man möchte gerne eine PCI-Card haben mit einem M2-Adapter, der dieses NVMe-Protokoll macht. Dann hast du halt schnell.
Oder wie jemand im Chat schreibt, Satan-Modus.
Genau, der Satan-Modus. Da hab ich auch mal was vorbereitet. Da muss ich jetzt dazu sagen, hab ich jetzt noch nicht getestet, aber das ist jetzt meiner Überzeugung nach das, wo ich jetzt überlege, das zu kaufen. Hier sieht man auch sehr schön, wie wenig an so einem Teil wirklich dran ist. Also sozusagen nur eine PCI-Karte, wo dann oben eben dieser Next-Generation-Form-Faktor, also dieser M2-Stecker drauf ist, und dann eben Platz, um da noch so ein Modul reinzustecken.
Da sieht man auch recht schön die drei Längen, die das haben kann. Da musst du dann entsprechend die Schraube an die richtige Stelle tun, dann hast du halt ein kürzeres oder längeres Modul da drin.
Genau, 2242 sind die kurzen, 2260 sind die mittleren, 2280 sind die ganz langen.
Was kann denn PCI an Datendurchsatz überhaupt maximal?
Naja, das hängt dann davon ab, ob du PCI 2.0 oder PCI 3.0 hast und natürlich dann auch, wie viele Lanes benutzt werden. Bei so einem Teil kommen in der Regel, bei so einem M2 Teil kommen irgendwie vier Lanes zum Einsatz und wenn du in unseren Mac Pro so eine Karte reinsteckst, die vier Lanes nimmt über PCI 2.0, dann kannst du da zwei Gigabyte pro Sekunde rüberschieben in beide Richtungen.
Die ist aber eventuell nicht kompatibel, weil das Mac OS diese Karten nicht mag.
Das Mac OS mag welche Karten nicht?
Diese M2 Karten. Das ist ja das Problem, was ich mit diesem PC hatte, den ich da zusammengesetzt hab und dachte, da machst du jetzt einen Hackintosh drauf. Das geht mit einer SATA M2 Karte aber nicht mit einer PCI M2 Karte. Also gibt es wohl inzwischen auch schon gepatchte Treiber und so weiter, aber das ist alles, also Apple verbaut die Karten aber nur mit speziellen Kennungen und so weiter. Also das ist so, da wäre ich vorsichtig.
Okay, das würde mich jetzt sozusagen auch mal interessieren, vielleicht irgendjemand aus unserem Hörerkreis da schon Erfahrungen hat, weil das wäre jetzt sozusagen mein Tipp, ne? So eine D-Log-Karte mit diesem NVMe Interface.
Also das Problem ist nicht das NVMe, sondern halt wirklich die Karte an sich.
Ja, und dann nimmst du dann halt, so, und dann würde ich halt dazunehmen, so eine Samsung 960 Evo.
Genau, die gibt es als einen Terabyte. Die habe ich zu Hause in diesem Skull Canyon Dengzi drin. Der hat ja zwei Slots für solche Karten. Eine habe ich reingebaut, allerdings nicht ein Terra, sondern ich glaube nur ein halbes oder so. Na ja gut, ist die schnell oder nicht? Man merkt nicht mehr, ob die schnell oder langsam ist, weil es halt sofort da ist.
Genau.
Und ich weiß auch nicht, wie schnell so ein Windows eigentlich normalerweise bootet. Insofern, aber also das schon, die sind schon schön, diese Karten.
Ja, also müssen wir jetzt vielleicht nochmal, ich frag mich, was da jetzt, an welcher Ebene da überhaupt noch...
Ich hab sie nur, wie gesagt, nicht zum Laufen gekriegt mit dem Mac OS zusammen. Also ich hab ein Mac OS...
Am Mac Pro?
Nee, auf diesem Hack-Enttäuschding. Ich hab's geschafft, den auf einer externen Festplatte mit USB zum Laufen zu kriegen. Das ging aber eben nicht auf der Karte. Deswegen, wie gesagt, da würde ich nochmal ordentlich nachrecherchieren, ob du die tatsächlich zum Laufen kriegst.
Also das würde mich auf jeden Fall auch interessieren, weil wenn das nämlich läuft, dann hätte man mal eben für so ungefähr 500 Euro Investitionen, eine Terabyte, SSD, die theoretisch, naja, fünfmal so schnell ist wie meine SATA 3.
Das wär doch schon mal was.
Nicht, dass ich das jetzt unbedingt brauche, aber der Gedanke ist geil.
Schneller geht immer.
Schneller geht immer. Vor allem, ich wundere mich ohnehin über so ein paar Flaschenhälse auf meinem System. Wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel, Reaper rendert irgendwas raus und es dauert einfach eine Viertelstunde, dann frage ich mich so, wo genau geht jetzt eigentlich diese Viertelstunde?
Warum dauert das so lange? Die Sendung war doch nur fünf Stunden lang.
Mit fünf Spuren oder vier heute aber.
Na ja gut, aber angenommen, er hätte viel zu rechnen, dann müssten ja die CPUs ausgelastet sein.
Sind sie aber nicht.
Nicht die Bohne. Die eideln vor sich hin. Dann kann es eigentlich nur IO sein, dann schaust du dir mal an, was da irgendwie...
Sprecherbandbreite könnte es vielleicht noch sein. Weil er muss den ganzen Kram ja einmal durch den Prozessor ziehen.
Meinst du, der Prozessor kriegt seine Daten aus dem RAM nicht schnell genug?
Ich weiß es nicht. Also er zieht die irgendwo von der Festplatte, nudelt sie einmal in den Prozessor, rechnet das zusammen, nudelt sie über das RAM wieder raus, wieder zurück auf irgendeine Festplatte. Also klar ist da irgendwo ein Flaschenhals. Und wenn du jetzt nicht fiese Effekte rechnest, ist es logisch, dass er die CPU nicht auslastet.
Also, das ist ein reines I.O.-Ding.
Also ich hab da mal was vorbereitet. Ich wäre froh, von jemandem zu hören, der vielleicht mit seinem Mac da schon entsprechende Ergebnisse erzählt hat oder auch nicht.
Vielleicht der von Dennis in der nächsten Sendung.
Mal gucken, wenn wir ihn überhaupt einladen.
Schockresistent.
Wäre auf jeden Fall interessant. So oder so ist mir in dem Moment klar geworden, dass M2 eigentlich...
Das ist das, was man haben will.
Das ist das, was man eigentlich in so einem neuen Mac Pro auch haben wollen würde.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das wäre richtig geil. Also nicht nur für SSDs, sondern für alles.
Also ich würde nicht wundern, wenn sie da vier von den M2 Slots rein tun würden. Weil das wäre the way to go.
Ja und dann so zwei statt den optischen Laufwerken, zwei Legacy, 3,5 Zoll Slots noch.
Du gibst die Hoffnung nicht auf. Ehrlich gesagt ich auch nicht, aber wir werden sehen.
Wie gesagt, was du ja meintest für Video und so, da zahlst du halt echt viel Kohle auf den gleichen Speicher. Und der ist dann nicht so, also ist halt Flash-Speicher ist halt auch noch deutlich volatiler als so eine gute alte Metallscheibe.
Klar, wenn du viel Speicher brauchst und der muss nicht super schnell sein, dann ist so...
Und verlässlich vielleicht sogar noch dazu.
Ist so eine rotierende Platte vielleicht doch noch gar nicht so übel.
Jetzt hat Nvidia auch noch angekündigt, ganz passend, dass es demnächst auch noch Grafikkarten gibt mit Macintosh Support von ihnen. Also die Grafikkarten gibt es schon länger, das ist diese Pascal-Architektur und jetzt haben sie dafür auch noch Treiber rausgehauen.
Hallo, ihr baut doch einen neuen Mac Pro, wir haben hier ganz tolle Karten für euch.
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass sie auch mal ganz gerne zugekommen möchten. Aber das bedeutet, dass ja im Prinzip die Auswahl von Grafikkarten, die man jetzt im Mac reinschmeißen kann, das ist vor allem diese ganze GTX 1000 Tralala-Serie und jetzt die neue super schwarze Tiktan XP, die irgendwie ganz viele Flops und Shader und Hass nicht gesehen hast, alles so Zahlen, mit denen ich nicht groß was anfangen kann, auch vielleicht nicht unbedingt brauche, aber keine Ahnung, könnte durchaus auch noch mal das eine oder andere beschleunigen. Mit anderen Worten, wer noch auf den Mac Pro wartet jetzt die nächsten zwei Jahre, kauft sich am besten einfach einen sieben Jahre alten Computer, wirft da ein bisschen China rein und alles ist super.
Ein bisschen China reinwerfen?
Aber eine USB-C-Karte hast du dir noch nicht besorgt? Eine USB-C-Karte, also du als alter, flammender USB-C Befürworter?
Na, ich hab halt kein USB-C Device.
Aber es ist doch die Zukunft.
Siehst du genau, das ist das Problem mit USB-C.
Aber uns hier die ganze Zeit den USB-C Honig ums Maul schmieren, wie toll das ist. Und dann das Ganze aussitzen. Ja, ja.
Um nochmal zu ranten über diese fuckige Situation mit diesem nicht guten MacBook. Wie kann man nur diesen HDMI-Stecker absägen oder den Adapter da rausschmeißen? Du hast mal auch gesagt, das wäre auch eine coole Entscheidung, dieses HDMI-Teil rauszuwerfen.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Moment, meine Empfehlung bezüglich der neuen MacBooks war, don't buy it. Das ist das, was ich gesagt habe. Und das ist auch das, was ich getan habe.
Daran kann ich mich nicht erinnern, dass du gesagt hast, don't buy it.
Ich habe gesagt, die Cursor-Tasten gehen gar nicht. Diese Escape-Tastensituation geht gar nicht. Und dann geht noch so einiges anderes nicht. Nur mit den Ports komme ich ja prinzipiell klar. Aber ich bin auch nicht so bekloppt und kaufe mir gleich die erste Generation. Ich meine Leute, hallo.
Ich habe mir die auch nicht gekauft.
Ihr lasst euch das doch alles irgendwie in den Hintern stecken. Also, meckert nicht. Ich kann es nochmal wiederholen. Das geht nicht. Man kann diese MacBooks nicht kaufen. Die haben keine korrekten Cursor-Tasten und keine korrekten Escape-Tasten. Damit ist die Nummer einfach durch. Ports, ja, USB-C wird irgendwann alles sein. Aber derzeit habe ich nichts zum Anschließen mit USB-C. Also brauche ich auch keine USB-C-Karte.
Ich würde jetzt echt gerne noch mal ein paar Beiträge aus der. Letzten. Mit den Indie-Manties aus dieser Sendung? Ich meine, vielleicht täusche ich mich auch.
Nein, nein, nein.
Das ist eine Wahrnehmungs-Show.
Nein, das ist eine Wahrnehmungs-Show, weil die Frage war...
Die habe ich aber auch, die Wahrnehmungs-Stimmung.
Warte mal, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich so schlimm?
Du hast es gerade eben schön auf den Punkt gebracht. Ich habe kein USB-C-Gerät. Und ich wüsste auch nicht, wo ich eins herkriegen sollte. Außer jetzt irgendwie dieses Spritzbesteck. Du kannst deinen Adapter in jedes Loch stecken.
Wenn du aber an den Punkt ankommst...
Ja, du kannst den Adapter auch ins Loch stecken.
Du kannst 4 Gigabit Internet-Ports anschließen. Ich finde das nach wie vor cool.
Ja, weil es für dich ein Problem anderer Leute ist.
Als Strategie finde ich das cool, dass sie die Produkte schon mal draußen haben, die den Markt so weit bereinigen, dass man so in 3 Jahren auf USB-C wechseln kann.
Ich war letztens im Hotel. Ich habe mir das MacBook ja geben lassen. Ich dachte mir, was brauche ich für einen Adapter? Erstmal USB auf USB-C. Dass du normale USB-Oldschool-Geräte benutzen kannst. Was brauche ich sonst noch? Ich probiere es erstmal ohne alle sagen, man braucht kein Internet. Dann habe ich mir noch einen Display-Port-Adapter für das Display besorgt. Dann fuhr ich zu einem Event nach Köln, der in einem Hotel stand, mit den dort ansässigen Konferenz-Beamer-Systemen. Die halbe Firma hat sich zu Beginn des Events großflächig ausgetauscht. Wer denn welchen Adapter, für welches Beamer-Gerät. Da hatte diese Beamer natürlich VGA Everywhere. Manche hatten auch HDMI, das stimmt nicht. Aber es gibt auch bei diesen Adaptern sehr wenige HDMI-Adapter, die auch was taugen.
Selbst die Apple-Adapter sind nicht übermäßig gut.
Genau, und die wenigsten können 60 Hz bei 4K. Das ist nicht, dass die Beamer das jetzt in dem Fall konnten. Aber es gab selbst die Adapter, die es gab, haben nicht alle funktioniert. Also dass sozusagen noch ein weiterer Trial and Error bei allen möglichen Kombinationen von Geräten existiert. Und ich war echt schockiert, dass ich im Jahre 2017 immer noch VGA-Beamer... Also ich wollte es ja auch... Es gibt eine Sendung bestimmt, wo ich sage, das hat doch jetzt wirklich keiner mehr. Doch, es ist die Realität. Kurz darauf habe ich mir also jetzt das komplette oder das fast komplette Adapterspritzbesteck jetzt auch bestellt, weil ich es eingesehen habe. Wenn man mit dieser Welt interfacen will mit diesem Gerät, kommt man einfach nicht drum herum. Und es wird auch noch lange so bleiben. Ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz lange.
Ich habe mir nur einen einzelnen HDMI-Schnupsi jetzt erstmal besorgt, damit ich wenigstens in der Firma einfach das Gerät mitnehme. Da ist nur der kleine HDMI dran und dann kann ich überall irgendwo anschließen.
Weißt du, wo jetzt meine ganzen Geräte tatsächlich auf der Arbeit angeschlossen sind? Am Display. Weil das Display hat einen eingebauten USB-Hab. Das heißt, ich brauche nur einen USB-C-USB-Adapter der ich in meinen MacBook einführe und kann dann immer noch meine ganzen echten Geräte des Alltags anschließen. Die Zukunft von gestern schon heute.
Die Zukunft der Beamer hat eben nicht auch nochmal... Also ich hab so einen kleinen Test-Run gemacht mit der Beamer-Situation in der Fachhochschule und geguckt, welche Adapter denn zu meinem MacBook passen könnte. Surprise! Der Beamer hat es geschafft, meinen MacBook erst nur zu freezen und danach komplett abstürzen zu lassen. Und ich dachte mir so, schön, danke! Schönes Gerät hab ich hier. Schöner HDMI-Adapter im alten MacBook Pro, der überall funktioniert hat.
Hast du den geklickt, den ich dir gesagt hatte?
Genau, Huckel hat mir einen von Club empfohlen.
Club 3D?
Club 3D. Den hab ich klicken lassen und der sollte morgen in meiner Abwesenheit ankommen. Und ich werde dann berichten, ob ich...
Also ich hab mir den von Anker geklickt, weil ich eigentlich von Anker immer sehr viel halte. Und der... Der ist bis jetzt ohne Probleme unterwegs. Die Apple-Teile sind auch so geil. Du steckst dich das erste Mal rein und will erst mal ein Firmware-Update für den Adapter machen. Denkst du so, das kann doch wohl nicht Spaß sein.
Ich kann mir voll liefern, wenn keine liefern. Das wär scheiße.
Was ich auch noch entdeckt hab und ich...
Du kriegst das Beef Jerky nicht.
Eine. Was?
Du hast gesagt, du hast schon zwei weggepresst.
Nein, das war doch nur Spaß da. Hinter deinem Rechner liegt die andere. Hast du denn? Ne, aber das Classic ist das Beste.
Um dann mal kurz vom Beef Jerky wegzukommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr dasselbe Problem habt, aber wenn ich meine externen Tastatur und Maus anschließe, meine Maus braucht in der Tat erstmal so fast eine halbe Minute, um sich anzuschließen.
Zum Booten?
Nee, ich hab diese...
Maus-OS.
Diese kleinen Aufsteckadapter und die funktionieren tadellos.
Ich hab ein Trackpad, das funktioniert tadellos über Bluetooth. Ich werde noch zum Bluetooth-Fan.
Oh nee, das kommt...
USB-C macht mich zum Bluetooth-Fan. Wer hätte es gedacht?
Nee, ich hab alles mit Kabel und mein Bluetooth versuche ich immer aufzustellen.
Diese... da gibt's ganz viele... Ich guck mal gerade, welchen ich hab. USB-C, USB-A, USB... Äh, so eine Aufstecker, die sind... Die funktionieren sehr gut.
Also ich hab nämlich auch die von Apple und das ist ein Horror.
Warte, kommt sofort in the Chat. Also das ist eine Variante davon. Ich hab, glaub ich, von einer anderen Marke, aber ich glaube, die sind alle brauchbar. Drei, zwei, eins, Link incoming. Ja, also diese Club-3D-Adapter, die taugen bisher alle, finde ich ziemlich gut. Und Display-Port hab ich von, ich glaube, iTech, hab ich jetzt aber gerade nicht hier. Funktioniert auch gut. Und mein VGA-Adapter, das ist ja fast das schönste Stück, weil der hat so ein Metallgehäuse. Tcho-Tech. Aber wirklich, das ist...
Kannst du alle mal reinschmeißen in die Links.
Ich benutze übrigens auch den im Monitor eingebauten USB-Hub aus genau den gleichen Gründen wie du.
Also das Ding ist halt irgendwie, jetzt ist das Gerät schön schmal und leicht, und jetzt schleppst du das ganze, das gleiche Gewicht sozusagen in eine Extra-Tasche mit rum. Also du hast wirklich überhaupt null gewonnen.
Ja, hab dich mal nicht so.
Hab du dich mal nicht so, du alter USB-C-Verweigerer.
Ich hab noch nicht mal Retina.
Also ich hab...
Du hast doch der Beef Jerky.
Aber nicht Classic.
Ich hab auf jeden Fall mal diesen, auf dem Kongress gab's doch diese Aufkleber-Stiftung, Warentest, nicht so geil. Und so einen hab ich erst mal drauf gemacht.
Den hätt ich auch gern.
Wo gibt's den denn?
Gab's auf dem Kongress eine Stiftung, Warentest, nicht so geil. Diverse Kollegen haben schallend gelacht.
Ja, ich hab auch vorhin gelacht, als du das ausgepackt hast. Ich such die ganzen Adapter auch noch mal raus, obwohl mir die Hörer ja dann trotzdem wieder tausende Twitter-Nachrichten schreiben. Aber ja, USB-C, Desaster...
Das geht dir nur so lange, bis du den Adapter gefunden hast, der einfach funktioniert.
Das nächste Problem ist, dass dieser Connector halt einfach physikalisch heiße ist. Hatte ich ja schon in der Sendung davor erzählt, dass die Kabel dann, also wenn du so einen Ständer benutzt, um dein Notebook auf ergonomische Höhe zu bringen und dann diese ganzen schweren Adapter da so runterbammeln, war es nicht das Gefühl, dass diese Adapter fünf Jahre von hier immer noch sicher sitzen.
Da hab ich meine Thermostasse drunter gestellt.
Ja, genau, so fang ich nämlich auch an, dass jetzt irgendwelche Bücher, die rumliegen oder so unter meiner Adapterstelle, damit die nicht diesen Connector verformen. Das ist wirklich...
Aber da war das Thunderbolt schlimmer.
Das war... ja, ja, auch.
Ich hab jetzt Ethernet über Thunderbolt 2 und der Thunderbolt 2 Adapter steckt in dem Thunderbolt 3 Adapter drin. Ja, weil die haben ja von der IT, haben sie mir halt unter anderem auch ein Thunderbolt 3, sprich USB-C Thunderbolt 3 auf Thunderbolt 2 Adapter mitgegeben. Und ich hatte noch den Thunderbolt 2 auf Ethernet Adapter, den man ja in der vorherigen Generation schon brauchte, und dann hab ich die ineinander gesteckt, funktioniert super. Also ich bin zufrieden mit dieser Kombination. Sieht lächerlich aus. Das tut es.
Ja, also ich bin auch nach wie vor nicht überzeugt, und jetzt haben wir schon drei nicht überzeugte...
Hast du denn auch schon die E-Mail von Apple bekommen? Sind sie zufrieden mit ihrem neuen Mac?
Nee, da ich den ja...
Und was kann man klicken?
Leider nicht nein, Arschloch. Aber ich habe...
Die fragen einfach nur so und...
Du kommst auf so ein Formular und kannst halt deine Zufriedenheit angeben und danach hast du so eine Freitextfläche.
Hast du sie ausgetocht?
Aber natürlich.
Was hast du geschrieben?
Was hab ich denn so dringend gehabt?
Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal. Jetzt bitte.
Rent mit Ansage, bitte.
Ja, ohne geht das nicht. Ich hab irgendwie wirklich so stichpunktartig irgendwie, touchbar ist sinnlos, fehlende Escape-Taste macht MacBook unbenutzbar ohne externe Tastatur. Dann, dass die Tastatur viel zu laut ist für den Alltag. Das stimmt. Die Tastengröße wohl eher so ein bisschen unästhetisch und nutzertechnisch auch nicht so geil ist. Ich hab mich in der Tat auch kopiert noch gehabt, was ich denen geschrieben hatte. Dann auch natürlich die Cursor-Tasten, dass es eher so ein Desaster ist. Die scharfen Kanten des MacBooks schneiden mir mal erheblich in meine Arme rein.
Brauchst du auch eine Apple Watch wie Roddy, die deine Halsgelenke schont?
Das darf man ja schreiben. Wenn ich mich hätte ritzen wollen, hätte ich ja nicht so viel Geld für ausgeben.
Kann man günstiger haben, nennt sich Rasierklingel. Das fand ich auch wirklich sehr furchtbar. Ich kann nicht mehr so richtig blind tippen mit der Tastatur, ist mir aufgefallen.
Hast du auch das Prell-Problem? Das ist jetzt der Beef Jerky-Test. Kurz runterschlucken. Wenn man da so raufklackert auf diese Tasten, dass bestimmte Tasten ab und zu doppelt auslösen.
Das hab ich noch nicht gefunden.
So hart hau ich nicht drauf, aber bei mir ist es so, dass ich ja immer die externe Tastatur habe. Außer ich bin in einem Meeting und hab dieses Teil dabei. Und dann hat das so ein Zen-Modus. Man legt so die Hände so auf die Tastatur und drückt dann ganz bewusst, ganz sanft die Tasten alle einzeln nacheinander runter, damit sie keinen Lärm machen. Und man kann tatsächlich, also in diesem Zen-Modus, das hat was. Also es hat was Meditatives, diese Tasten extra langsam und extra sanft anzudrücken und es funktioniert.
Bist du so in dem Zen-Modus, bis dass du mit deinen Handgelenken das Touchpad benutzt und aus Versehen irgendwelche Gesten auslöst, die denn mit dem, im Einklang mit deinem zenartigen Tastentippen irgendwelche ganz anderen Befehle auslösen?
Das ist mir ehrlich gesagt noch nie passiert, dass ich mit den Handgelenken das Touchpad ausgelöst hätte.
Oder wenn ich so ein bisschen Staub wegwischen will und dann über die Touchbar gleite und da auch mein Logscreen und alles mögliche drin ist, letztens ist mir die Touchbar abgestürzt.
Ach, das war ein schöner Tag.
Wie sah das aus?
Also es war nur ein Button. Ich hab jetzt umgestellt auf Control Keys Only, also keine Application spezifischen Sachen mehr auf der Touchbar, sondern heller, dunkler, lauter, leiser. Die ganzen Sachen sind jetzt bei dir voll drauf. Und es leuchtete nur noch der zuletzt gedrückte Knopf und alles andere war schwarz. Und dann dachte ich mir so, ich würde jetzt aber gerne heller machen und tippe dann so hin und dann leuchtet da auch nur noch diese Taste auf. Also man musste raten, wo die Tasten sind. Und ich weiß nicht, wie ich es dann gefixt hab. Entweder hab ich Log In, Log Out oder das Dock abgeschossen. Eins von diesen üblichen Dingen. Wenn irgendwas woanders hackt, dann schießt man das Dock ab oder den Feinden und dann geht's wieder irgendwie. Sowas in der Richtung muss ich da auch tun. Und dann kamen sie wieder. Aber das ist auch so echt...
Du hast langsam mal wieder Zeit für die Turbotaste. IBM, die haben noch mal den... Kannst du mal überlegen? Es gab den IBM PC-AT. Das war der Nachfolger des IBM PC. Also des Ur-PCs.
Der hatte sechs Megahertz.
Der PC XT war die zweite Aus-... war die Extended-Version von dem PC. Der war nur mehr ausgebaut, das war aber im Prinzip immer noch der IBM PC.
Genau, aber der AT war ja schon der 286er, glaube ich.
Genau. Das war sozusagen Second Generation. War ja dann auch die letzte Generation, weil dann ging das halt mit den ganzen Klonen los und dann haben sie versucht, mit PS2 hinterherzukommen. Und das hat ja alles nicht funktioniert. Egal, alte Scheiße von damals. Auf jeden Fall kamen dann die ganzen Kloner und haben dann den 82-286er mit 8 Mhz und dann auch mit 10 und 12 Mhz gemacht. Unglaubliche Maschinen. Also wirklich ein Speed, höllisch. Da es aber Software gab, die sich sozusagen fest auf die Geschwindigkeit des ATs irgendwie eingeschossen hat, mit Software-Timing und so weiter, haben dann die ganzen Klons eine Turbotaste bekommen, mit der du dann wieder auf 6 Mhz zurückschalten konntest, falls dir dann die Software zu schnell läuft. Konntest du sie dann wieder langsamer machen.
Beziehungsweise bei Spielen.
Aber deswegen denke ich da überhaupt drauf. Daneben gab es dann auch noch eine Resett-Taste, eine ordentliche. Das gehörte sozusagen zur Standard-Ausrüstung. So Reset und Turbo, was natürlich immer ein bisschen blöd ist, wenn man so vor seinem Desktop-Tuch, so mit dem Knie mal eben so die Kiste gebootet. Aber vielleicht könnten sie ja die Touch-Bytes auch noch mit so einer Resett-Taste und vielleicht halt auch noch mit der Turbo-Taste ausstatten.
Nee, was ich am geilsten fand, waren ja diese diese PC-Gehäuse, die dann so zwei 7-Segment-Teile hatten, die die Megahatze, die Taktzahl angezeigt haben. Und das war ja alles Schmu, weil du hast ja, wenn du das Ding aufgemacht hast, konntest du ja mit Jumpern einstellen, welche 7-Segment-Dinger an sind, bei welchem Tasten stand.
Da gab's dann auch so PC-Hücker, die haben dann auch eine schöne hohe Zahl eingestellt und die Leute haben sie gekauft. Ja, so einfach ist das. Aber wir waren ja beim MacBook Pro. Sind wir durch mit dem Rand für die Woche?
Na ja, eins noch, wenn man Xcode, den Debugger benutzt. Vorher war halt Stepover, Stepin und Stepout auf F6, F7, F8. Und das ist halt jetzt auf der Touchbar. Und das kannst du nicht mehr blind bedienen.
Weil man es nicht mehr fühlen kann.
Nee, du musst halt jedes Mal gucken, wo drücke ich hin, und dann hast du halt auch kein haptisches Feedback, dass du jetzt eine Taste gedrückt hast. Also das geht halt überhaupt gar nicht. Geht halt nicht. Das ist eine Touchbar, geht halt nicht.
Ich bin gespannt, wann sie die nächsten Roundtable machen. Den Touchbar-Roundtable.
Genau.
So, nächstes Thema. Jetzt haben wir verschiedene Möglichkeiten zur Auswahl.
Wähle das Spannendste aus.
Naja, vielleicht wollt ihr ja nochmal was reinwerfen.
Kurz, kurz, kurz, kurz, warum nicht? Elektroauto Disruption hab ich da hingeschrieben. Es gibt ein unglaublich schönes YouTube-Video von einem Vortrag, von einem Typ, der über Disruption spricht. Und mal so schnell die vier Elemente anspricht, das ist schon ein Jahr alt, wo er sagt, wie entwickeln sich Kosten von Batterien, wie entwickeln sich die Kosten von elektrischen Autos und wie entwickelt sich Self-Driving, wie entwickeln sich die Kosten von Solar Energy und kommt darauf, in zehn Jahren werden eigentlich keine Verbrenner mehr verkauft. Wenn die Trends so weiterlaufen, wie sie jetzt laufen, dann zahlt niemand mehr so viel Geld für einen Verbrennungsmotor, wenn er ein Auto mit Elektro halt für die Hälfte des Preises kriegt. Achso, vielleicht soll ich den Link noch reinwerfen. Der lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, das Ding anzugucken.
Ich hab dafür immer so stumm durchgescrollt, da war einiges dabei und ich kann auch nur sagen, da ist wahrscheinlich eine Menge dran. Ich merke das ja jetzt auch. Ich hatte ja letztes Mal hier, glaube ich, auch von den neuen Elektrorollern berichtet. Da hatte ich mich ja gerade mal frisch angemeldet und so von meiner Onboarding-Experience erzählt. Mittlerweile bin ich die ja auch alle gefahren.
Hast du direkt aufgebordet? Nein.
Auf jeden Fall, Berlin sind wir ja insofern wirklich gesegnet. Also hier gibt es einfach so viele Carsharing Modelle.
Nenn es verwöhnt gesegnet, ist glaube ich der falsche Ausdruck.
Ne, ab jetzt sind wir auch gesegnet. Weil, das ist... Ich bin wirklich, ja, es ist wie Tupperware, ja. Ich bin einfach begeistert.
Wann kaufst du dir einen Thermomix?
Auf jeden Fall, kurzer Recap. Es gibt hier in Berlin jetzt zwei Elektroroller-Auslei-Systeme. Das eine heißt EMI, vormals EMIO. Das sind eher so oldschoolige, Vespa-artige Plastibomber, die etwas untermotorisiert sind, auch einen relativ hohen Kilometerpreis haben, wie ich finde, mit 19 Cent. Wenn man mal bedenkt, dass Kato Go für ein Auto 24 nimmt, also nur 5 Cent billiger.
Aber nicht Kilometer, sondern pro Zeit.
Entschuldigung, pro Minute. Habe ich Kilometer gesagt? Pro Minute ist das alles. Dafür aber kein Mindest-Kontent. Also kein Mindest-Kontingent. Du kannst also dich da draufsetzen und mal 5 Minuten durch die Gegend düsen für einen Euro und dann bist du irgendwo.
Mindest-Kontent ist ein schöner Versprecher.
Und dann hatte ich mich ja noch für Q angemeldet, aber bis zu dem Zeitpunkt der Sendung, glaube ich, noch keine Fahrt getätigt. Das habe ich jetzt mittlerweile getan. Und wow, also die Dinger sind echt scharf. Also erstmal, die sind so richtig neu. Und ich habe da mal ein bisschen hin und her gegoogelt, was denn das eigentlich für Geräte sind. Und zwar kommt das alles von einer taiwanesischen Firma, die heißt Gogoro. Und das coole ist, wenn du hinten die Sitzbank aufmachst, hast du da zwei Akkus drin. Das sind einfach solche, ja, Zylinder, kann man nicht sagen, also so Quadra, so längliche Teile mit Öl. Also Akkus in einer überschaubaren Größe, gut händelbar, kannst du halt einfach so nehmen und rausziehen. Und das eigentliche Mobilitätskonzept hinter diesem Produkt ist nämlich, dass in Teilbahnen, die in größeren Ballungsräumen, wo genau weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber halt so in großen Städten, kannst du dieses Teil kaufen und Gogoro hat die ganzen Städte übersehen mit Wechselstationen. Das ist so ein bisschen wie so ein großer Cola-Automat, nur dass da halt Akkus drin stecken. Du fährst dann mit deinem Roller vor, sitzt Bank auf, Akkus raus, zack, steckst du da rein, ziehst die zwei neue raus, zack, steckst sie wieder rein, sitzt zu, zehn Sekunden später hast du wieder 100 Kilometer Kapazität. Und die Dinger stehen halt irgendwie alle paar Kilometer rum. Also mindestens 50.
100 scheint mir viel, aber 50 scheint mir realistisch, 100 scheint mir viel.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo habe ich jetzt die 100 her? Egal, ich behaupte jetzt erstmal 50, das schaffen die Dinger auf jeden Fall. Und ja, und selbst wenn es nur 40 werden, wenn du sozusagen as you go, so, könnte man wieder neue Akkus gebrauchen, fährst halt irgendwo nochmal so um den Quark und dann zehn Sekunden später bist du schon wieder voll geladen, ist einfach mal super. Hier läuft es natürlich anders, hier fährt so ein Onkel mit dem Auto rum und stopft die Dinger, die halt nicht mehr so viel Akku haben, einfach wieder voll, so dass die halt immer geladen sind, wenn du sie anbietest. Aber was ich halt noch viel geiler finde, ist, die sind einfach mal super modern, also die haben irgendwie alles und das alles so voll integriert, das ist einfach, also ich mag ja so ein neu auch, also es gibt ja viele, die hängen so einen alten Charme und es muss ja aussehen wie in den 50er Jahre, weißt du, sonst ist es ja auch kein richtiger Roller und ich denke mir halt nur so, nee, ich möchte ein Gerät haben, was einfach seine Funktion spricht.
Also entweder ein echtes Gerät aus den 50ern oder ein modernes Gerät, aber nicht was was Neues, was so aussieht, als wär's als das, finde ich immer ein bisschen blöd.
Genau, das ist so ein bisschen gefaked und die Teile ziehen gut, die sind auch, du hast auch keinen Schlüssel, also bei Emy nimmst halt noch so einen Schlüssel raus, so wie bei, hier auch bei Flinxer, da hast du ja immer den Schlüssel im Handschuhfach mit so einem kleinen RFID-Chip noch mit dran und hier machst du mit der App, unlockst du das Teil, dann kannst du am Lenkartaste drücken, geht die Sitzbank auf, holst deinen Helm raus, steckst die Tasche rein, zack, setzt dich drauf, ziehst einen Bremsen, machst die Klappe, machst einen Ständer rein, ziehst die Bremsen und drückst in der Mitte einfach den Go-Button und dann... Und dann bist du fesselos. Und die sind super schnell, sind irgendwie so in 0,0 sind die irgendwie auf 50, das heißt, du kannst einfach mit dem Verkehr super mithalten. Einziges Manko gerade noch ist, dass sie sich manchmal ein bisschen zickig hat, die App beim zurückgeben. Weil sie dann so meint, ja stell dich mal schön neben dein Roller. Irgendwie. Ich steh neben meinem Roller. Sie bietet mir dann sozusagen das nicht so an. Also da machten sie am Support aber auch schon so den Eindruck, als ob sie das Problem kennen. Und ja, und die Jungs, die sitzen da auch ganz hart dran. Kann ich mir gut vorstellen, wie hart die gerade Thermik haben. Aber ist auf jeden Fall die Sache wert. Und irgendwie finde ich den Gedanken ganz geil, mir auch selber so einen Roller zu kaufen. Da habe ich mal so ein bisschen geschaut, was das alles so kostet. Und es gibt eigentlich gar nicht so viel. Was sehr interessant ist, ist dieser Uno. Das war auch mal so eine crowdfundete Nummer. Der Uno, hier Erdgeist hat den, den kennst du wahrscheinlich auch. unomotors.com Da bist du dann, der sieht irgendwie ganz schick aus. Der hat irgendwie auch so eine ganz interessante Mischung aus neu und alt. Ist jetzt nicht so falsch. Bosch Motor. Bosch Motor. Und den bestellst du irgendwie, konfigurierst du online und dann kriegst du irgendwie so eine Kiste direkt vor die Tür geliefert. Weiß nicht genau, dauert dann ein paar Wochen. Wenn du den dir in einer ordentlichen Konfiguration zusammenklickst mit schnellem Motor und vielleicht noch mit dem zweiten Akku, bist halt auch irgendwie auch schon so bei dreieinhalb. Und der macht dann so mit dem Akku, macht da wohl so 40 Kilometer und mit dem zweiten halt 80.
Also der erste Google-Hit zum Thema Go-Go-Ro sei zugesagt werden 100 Kilometer Reichweite bei 40 Stundenkilometer konstanten Tempo. Das könnten über den Daumen gepeilt im Stadtbetrieb praxisgerechte 60 Kilometer bis zur nächsten Station sein.
Da hatte ich die Zahl her.
Also ja, das klingt realistisch.
Genau, in Taiwan werden die auch schneller, wenn sie die anders getunet. Hier sind die natürlich auf 50 begrenzt, also offiziell ja eigentlich 45. Ihr zeigt 50 an, weiß jetzt nicht genau, was stimmt. Vielleicht zeigen sie einfach 50 an, der fährt 45, damit die Leute denken, sie fahren 50. Du kriegst den wohl in Taiwan auch in einer 95-Stunden-Kilometer-Variante. Was natürlich für so einen kleinen Roller echt geil ist. Also ich mein, das ist auch geil gefährlich.
Du brauchst halt einen Führerschein dafür, ne?
In Deutschland würdest du einen anderen Führerschein dafür brauchen, in Taiwan wahrscheinlich nicht.
Genau, den hat in Deutschland halt, ja Gott, nicht alle, sagen wir mal so, nicht alle.
Aber wer in Berlin ist, kann das sehr empfehlen, vor allem die Dinger sind billig, du zahlst halt 10 Cent pro Minute, musst halt 30, 10 Cent pro Minute, also zahlst 3 Euro in einer halben Stunde. Und das ist aber auch die Mindestabnahme. Das heißt, wenn du eine Fahrt machst, zahlst du auf jeden Fall so viel wie quasi die Bahn.
Das war jetzt aber, welcher war das jetzt?
joincoo.com und das, also die verwenden die Gogoro-Roller, eben in dieser Flotte. Und wenn man sie selber einkaufen will, kann man die leider nicht kaufen, diese Gogoros sind nicht zu haben. Das hätte ich jetzt mal richtig scharf gefunden, aber die werden hier nicht angeboten. Ich vermute mal, das ist jetzt hier sogar die erste Nummer, mit der sie hier Fuß auf Deutschland, vielleicht sogar Europa setzen, keine Ahnung, ist auf jeden Fall ganz interessant. Da passiert auf jeden Fall eine Menge. Und wenn dieser Scaling-Faktor, dieser Disruptionsfaktor jetzt sich mal so auf Elektroroller umgesetzt, du hast jetzt den Vortrag gesehen, was bezahlen und Kurven gezeigt werden, ging das in wesentlichen Leistungsfähigkeit.
Naja, jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass ich die Zahlen bestimmt alle nicht richtig zitieren kann, ging es vor allen Dingen darum, dass Akkus billiger werden und zwar, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, 7 bis 12 Prozent pro Jahr. Was bedeutet halt dadurch, dass sie halt jedes Jahr um den Prozentsatz geringer werden, halt sehr schnell den Bereich erreichen, wo die Akkus halt nicht mehr der Hauptkostepunkt an so einem Auto oder an so einem Roller sind. Und dann geht es halt ab, weil Motoren sind halt dann, also Verbrennungsmotoren sind halt dort doch relativ teuer zu bauen.
Und vor allem teuer zu warten.
Teuer zu warten. Solar wird halt auch ähnlich schnell billiger und ja, keine Ahnung, also in fünf Jahren hat wahrscheinlich jeder so ein Roller. Ne, ich weiß es nicht. Also Berlin ist jetzt auch nicht so eine Rollerwetterstadt, also wenn ich es mal so sagen darf.
Es gibt jeden Frühling von ehemaligen Arbeitskollegen das Anrollern.
Ja, man kann, mal ehrlich, also wenn das deine einzige Option ist, dann kannst du schon drei Viertel des Jahres damit fahren, problemlos.
Ja, natürlich. Es ist nur so, dass es in Italien oder so ist es halt Lifestyle, weil du wirklich rund ums ganze Jahr angenehm mit den Dingern fahren kannst, was du halt hier nicht kannst. Also da kannst du halt, wenn's gut läuft, ein halbes Jahr angenehm fahren und wenn du dich nicht so hast, vielleicht dreiviertel Jahr, zehn Monate, aber du kannst nicht das ganze Jahr damit fahren.
Wir werden aber noch eine andere Generation erleben. Erinnerst du dich noch an diesen C1, dieses Motorrad von BMW?
Was irgendwie ein bisschen hässlich war, fand ich.
Ich fand das eigentlich ganz geil, mit dieser Kabine drum herum.
Ja, ganz geil, aber trotzdem irgendwie hässlich. Na ja, nur meine Meinung.
Geht dieses eine Ding von Renault nicht in eine ähnliche Richtung?
Renault hatte auch so was überdachtes.
Was ich an dem C1 immer so strange fand, war, da konnte zwar eine zweite Person mitfahren, aber die saß dann außen hinten drauf und musste einen Helm tragen.
Wie hieß denn dieser alte Kabinenroller?
Metzer Schmidt Kabinenroller? Nee, den meinst du wahrscheinlich nicht.
Die Isetta.
Ich hab neulich erst eine hier gesehen.
Die Isetta und da gab's aber doch noch einen anderen hier, der Metzer Schmidt Kabinenroller.
Metzer Schmidt Kabinenroller, ja.
Genau, Metzer Schmidt Kabinenroller. Sowas in Elektro, was du einfach wegparkst wie so ein Dreirad vielleicht, bzw. diese BMW C1 war für mich schon so ein bisschen so, das ging schon hin, hat schon so langsam den Komfort von Auto mit den Vorteilen von Motorrad. Also durch diese Gurtkonstruktion zum Beispiel brauchtest du ja keinen Helm tragen.
Ja, weil du hattest den Überrollbügel.
Du hast einen Überrollbügel, was auch vollkommen okay ist. So, dann sitzt du da halt drin und du musst halt nicht diesen blöden Helm aufsetzen. Du kannst Kopfhörer aufsetzen, kannst Mützen, alles, also du kannst sozusagen deinen Kopf...
Du kannst deinen Lifestyle voll ausleben.
Den Apple Kopfhörer Lifestyle.
Ja, mit den neuen Airpods kann ich ja auch während des Elektroroller-Fahns irgendwie noch Podcasts hören, weil die passen halt unter den Helm. Und die Ticker sind nicht so laut. Also da passt echt vieles zusammen auf einmal. Na ja, so was fände ich auf jeden Fall ganz cool. Und ich wäre jetzt nicht... Also wenn es diesen C1 als Elektroroller gäbe...
Gibt es den noch?
Nee, den haben sie glaube ich irgendwie eingestellt. Da haben sich viele drüber lustig gemacht, aber ehrlich gesagt, das fände ich mal wirklich ein cooles Device. Und wenn man den vor allem noch seitlich vielleicht ein bisschen zumachen könnte, dass man dann eben auch noch eine Heizung an den Start kriegen kann. Also einfach so zwei Radautos.
Also ich fände eine Finne Exeter in der Tat mit Elektro, weil die süß.
Ja, ne? So ein ganz knuffiges Teil.
Die Nautszone ist aber nur eine Tür.
Der ist jetzt beim Motorroller auch nicht größer.
Ja doch, da hast du immerhin noch ein Rad vorne. Die Exeter, da sitzt du ja quasi direkt auf dem Rand.
Kann man alles lösen.
Ja, beim Motorrad fliegst du im Zweifelsfall über das Lenkrad.
Und bis dann machst du eine geschickte Seite und sitzt dann bei irgendjemandem auf dem Dach.
Ich möchte jetzt zum Thema Anachronismus und Elektromobilität gerne noch anführen, wie mein Traum EE-Fahrzeug aussieht. Und zwar hat auf dem letzten Firmen-Event jemand einen Vortrag gehalten zu seinem Elektroauto-Umbau. Also er hat einen Volvo S80 genommen und hat ihn in drei Jahren mühevoll selber in ein Elektroauto verwandelt, was zu bizarren Workarounds führte, weil zum Beispiel so Sachen wie ABS sind halt mit Motorsteuerung und so weiter halt irgendwie verkuppelt. Also wenn irgendwie der Motor meldet, hier Zündsteuerung und so alles gaga, dann sagt auch das ABS, irgendwie bin ich hier gerade ganz woanders. Das heißt, er musste mit Arduinos, hat er auch gemacht, sozusagen dem ABS vorgaukeln, also die Signale senden, die ein laufender Motor dann senden würde, damit das alles so funktioniert. Und er hat es auch geschafft und dann dachte ich mir aber auch schon vorher, eigentlich, ich hab gar keinen Bock auf so einen Tesla mit diesem ganzen LED-Schüssel und dem iPad in der Mitte und hier noch ein Blinklicht und da noch ein Computer, der einem sagt, man soll nicht schnell fahren und dass man nicht angeschnallt ist und dass man dies nicht machen soll und das nicht machen soll, sondern was ich gerne hätte wäre so was wie ein Saab 900 mit so angelaufenen Armaturen.
Das ist doch auch so eine fahrene Schrankwand.
Ja, irgendwie sowas, wo du noch einen richtigen, so einen klackenden Schalter hast, der sozusagen die Batterien freischaltet für die Benutzung der Elektromotoren und wo du so analoge Voltmeter und Amperemeter quasi in den Armaturen hast, statt deiner Zeiger- Tankanzeige. Also gar nicht so Steampunk-mäßig, auch überhaupt nicht künstlich aufgesetzt, sondern einfach das, was da in diesem Fahrzeug passiert, einfach aber so mit dem derzeit angemessenen Messinstrument dargestellt.
Also so ist es 70er Jahre Hi-Fi.
Ich fände das mega charmant. Einfach so eine alte Karre mit irgendwie angelaufenen Armaturen und macht so einmal klack an so einem Drehschalter und die Nadeln tanzen los und das wär das wär meins. Und das ist auf jeden Fall natürlich, wie du schon sagtest, ich will Zukunft aber nicht in so einem alten Korsett verpackt, aber ich fände, das wäre noch so eine charmante Variante davon. Und gerade so ein Saab halt auch, weil der ja wirklich innen drin einfach so ein bisschen so Alien-mäßig oder Raumschiff-mäßig auch aussehen im Vergleich zu den meisten anderen Autos. Also ich hatte das Vergnügen eine Zeit lang damit mal rumfahren zu dürfen und das wäre so der ideale Kandidat für so eine Maßnahme.
Ja, ein Freund von mir, der hat ja mal angefangen, ein Trabi umzubauen auf Elektro, aber er ist dann irgendwie nicht weit gekommen. Vor allen Dingen hast du das Problem, dass der Trabi halt, wenn du den nicht im Original-Zustand hast, halt auch nicht zugelassen bekommst, weil er keine ordentlichen Bremsen hat und keine ordentlichen Dies und keine ordentlichen Das und so weiter. Und wenn du erst mal anfängst an dem Teil zu schrauben, kriegst du es nie wieder zugelassen. Das ist irgendwie, naja, aus guten Gründen glaube ich, aber auch.
Anyway, wie auch immer.
Genau. So, ich hab noch was. Genau, jetzt müssen wir erstmal hier schön unsere Themen ein bisschen sortieren. Ich hatte ja berichtet, dass ich da dieses kleine Finanzproblem hatte.
Steuern.
Man hatte in dem Zuge ja diverse Forschungen begonnen und hier in dem Rahmen auch ein paar Tools vorgestellt. Vor allem hatte ich gepriesen als wertvolle Werkzeuge einerseits Receipts, die App, die quasi so Rechnungsbeläge einsammelt und einem mal ordentlich durchpriemelt. Und wenn man halt neu reinschmeißt und erkennt die Rechnung schon, dann auch gleich automatisch zuordnet und die Beträge raussucht und pipa po, dann habe ich halt hier erstmal mich so zwei Monate lang eigentlich eingeschlossen und nichts anderes gemacht, als diese ganzen grauenhaften Papierstapel digitalisiert und damit halt wunderbar geordnet bekommen. Und auf einmal hatte ich einfach so eine Nachschlage-Datenbank über was ist eigentlich passiert in den letzten Jahren. Es war einfach ein Fest.
Ich habe gesehen, du bist in den Credits von Receipts mit drin.
Bin ich?
Und im About-Dialog steht ein gewisser Herr Tim Fritlav. Oh, wirklich? Das hast du wohl ordentlich Feedback gegeben.
Ja, ja.
Ich kann nicht anders. Also da bin ich dann auch wirklich ein bisschen so Pearl Harbor-mäßig drauf. Ich komme so aus dem Nichts und...
Und hinterher ist alles in Schutt und Asche.
Stimmt. Na gut, das wäre jetzt nicht nötig gewesen. Viel wichtiger finde ich, dass so einige Features von denen, die ich vorgeschlagen hatte, das ganz gut in die App gemacht haben. Da wird auch noch eine Menge dran gemacht. Genau, und dann habe ich mich auch noch mal intensiver mit MoneyMoney, also meiner bevorzugten Banking-App ausgenommen gesetzt.
Anyway, geh weiter. Sorry, es wird schon spät.
So spät ist es noch.
Nee, nee, MoneyMoney.
Finanzsoftware. Ich hab extra vor 23 Uhr angefangen.
Aber wir sind schon weit im zweiten Bier.
Genau. Und das war sozusagen der Ansatz, diesen ganzen, also den ganzen Moneyflow, der so tatsächlich real existiert hat, den irgendwie in den Griff zu kriegen. Und das ist einfach. Man hat so viele Konten, da schiebt man dann irgendwie so Geld hin und her. Heutzutage kommt ja einiges zusammen, was ich alles so habe. Da hat man so ein PayPal-Konto, da hat man natürlich ein normales Girokonto. Da hast du für jede Kreditkarte, die du hast, da hast du halt noch mal irgendwie ein eigenes Konto. Dann hast du hier nochmal was aufgemacht, dann hast du Fletter hier, Fletter da, Fletter alt, Fletter neu. Mit irgendwie Fletter mit seinen zwei Konten. Das ist ja alles Konten. Da muss man alles irgendwie erst mal sortiert bekommen. Skrill, was man dann nicht alles noch ausprobiert. Dann hier nochmal so eine N26-Testphase und so. Man denkt sich ja nichts dabei. Dann steht man da und da noch einmal.
Dann kommt der Kongress.
Dann muss man auf einmal alles dokumentieren und jeden Geldflow zwischen diesen Konten auch irgendwie in den Griff kriegen und auch irgendwie auf Null gerechnet bekommen. Na ja, dann war auf jeden Fall relativ bald klar. Nur so mit komischen Mac-Tools, die jetzt so ein bisschen irgendwie das so halbwegs in Überblick bringen, so allein kriegste halt noch nix, ne?
Du brauchst die Cloud.
Nee. Ich brauch die volle seriöse Schwere einer richtigen Buchhaltungssoftware. Ja, weil ich dachte mir so, jetzt hab ich irgendwie schon angefangen, jetzt noch Steuerberater und so, das macht nur Ärger. Also entweder man macht das alles so. Und na ja, dann musste man sich da halt irgendwie auch nochmal alles reindenken. Und dann hab ich mich irgendwie mit einer Software namens Monkey Office angefreundet. Schon gehört? Das ist so Software für Buchhalter. Auf dem Mac. Also läuft auch auf Windows, aber läuft halt auch auf dem Mac. Ist so, schon so ein bisschen wie eine Mac-App.
Kann Spuren von nativen Bedienelementen enthalten.
Wenn man so ein paar Jahre zurück der Style...
Geht Apfelkomma?
Schon mal nicht so schlecht. Das kriegen die wenigsten Cross-Plattform-Apps hin.
Ja, ist so mostly harmless. Man merkt schon, dass es jetzt auch so ein Nutzerkreis hat, der teilweise nicht andere Vorstellungen hat, wie Software zu funktionieren hat. Das sind natürlich Cross-Plattformen und so weiter. Egal, ich will gar nicht so viel über das User-Interface reden. Für mich war ja die Herausforderung erst mal eine ganz andere. Wie kriege ich jetzt diesen ganzen Scheiß, den ich in diesem anderen Programm habe, die ja sozusagen meine Wahrheit bedeutet haben, da. Rein?
Nein.
Und dann musst du ja deine groben Vorstellungen von was Flo hier so bedeutet, musst du dann irgendwie so in konkrete Steuerbuchungen überführen. Soll-Konto, haben-Konto, Steuersatz, Split-Buchung, alles so schöne Begriffe, mit denen man gerne morgens kuschelig mit dem Tee in der Hand aufwacht und sich irgendwie glücklich strahlend auf den Balkon stellt und ins Alpenpanorama schaut. Und tatsächlich half mir dabei schon mal eine Funktionalität, die jetzt, sagen wir mal, nicht der totale Überflieger ist, aber sie war immerhin da, weil du kannst nämlich diesen Importer von dieser Buchhaltungssoftware in so einer Art Visual Basic-artigen Sprache programmieren, die jetzt, sagen wir mal, jetzt so rein programmiertechnisch keine sonderliche Eleganz an den Tag legt, aber zumindest so halbwegs dir die Möglichkeit gibt, halt so Records entgegenzunehmen. Und es ist dann so out of the box, auch mit Money Money, Exportformaten, kommt das irgendwie erstmal ganz gut klar. Das heißt, dann kommen diese ganzen Daten angeflogen, da stehen dann deine ganzen Kategorien drin, die man so zugeordnet hat, so wie Geldtransit und Privatentnahme und, ach, was ein schöner Begriff ist, großartig. Und dann kann man um sie hergehen und sagen, ja, irgendwie IF, wenn dieses, dann jenes, und dann hier irgendwie Kostenstelle und da, kategorie zu ordnung und so weiter. Und dass es sozusagen alles gleich so in diese richtigen Buchungskategorien reingeht. Das heißt, das ist ein Kontenrahmen, den guten SKR 04. Und dann muss man sozusagen... Ihr wisst, wie es läuft. Das ist diese Kontenrahmen, also Kurz, Crashkurs, Buchhaltung.
Man hat...
Nein, man muss als Erklärender auch wissen... Man muss einfach die Schnauze halten.
Ich dachte, wir das nicht vorhin mit dem Zuhören.
Ich nehme gerne den...
Hart aus, es wird gleich nerdiger.
Okay, also Crashkurs, 5 Minuten.
Das ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Eigentlich erfasst man alles in so ganz einfachen sogenannten T-Käuten. Das heißt, was man irgendwie soll und haben. Und dann hast du das immer doppelt. Das ist die sogenannte doppelte Buchführung. Das heißt, wo du einmal soll haben Buß hast, woanders haben soll. Und das musst du irgendwie alles aufgeben. Das heißt, du hast verschiedene Konten, die haben alle so Zahlen. Die sind für unterschiedliche Dinge da. Das heißt, du überweist Geld von deinem Girokonto auf ein anderes Konto. Und dann muss das über solche Konten in deiner Buchhaltung auch abgebildet werden. Das heißt, du hast ein vierstelliges, also immer mit einer vierstelligen Nummernbezeichnung genanntes Konto. Das steht halt für dein Girokonto und ein anderes steht dann für dein Paypal-Konto. Und wenn du dir von Paypal da was hin überweist, dann muss das da halt so abgebildet werden. Das heißt, du musst quasi so dein Money-Money-Kategorie, hier ist das Konto Paypal und ich mach jetzt hier ein Geldtransit, das musst du sozusagen dann übersetzen. Und dann hab ich das irgendwie so mit diesem Import-Skript irgendwie so hinbekommen, dass ich tatsächlich in der Lage war, so mit einem halbwegs überschaubaren manuellen Aufwand diesen ganzen Kram einfach zu übernehmen, indem er so ungefähr 90% von dem ganzen Kram mehr oder weniger automatisch übernommen hat. Mit der einzigen Einschränkung, dass über den Weg, den ich da gegangen bin, der sogenannten Bank-Einzug, also so machst du es quasi wie so ein Konto-Auszug und dann musst du da wie so ein bekloppter Storisch die ganze Zeit Enter drücken für jede einzelne Scheiß Buchung, weil er es nicht automatisch übernehmen will. so 20 Minuten lang drückst du einfach nur so return und ab und zu kommt mal eine Fehlermeldung so, ah hier muss mal was angepasst werden und so. Dann dachte ich mir so, das muss doch irgendwie auch noch besser gehen und dann hab ich mal irgendwie so die Money-Money-Leute angeschrieben und hatte eigentlich so relativ wenig Hoffnung, weil ich hatte so ein kleines Detailproblem, mal so, hm ja, so mit eurem Exportformat geht da nicht noch was anderes. Ja klar, wir haben ja noch die API.
Ich so, was wie, die API.
Ja hier und dann kannst du da einfach mit Lua dein eigenes Export-Skript machen. Und dann so ist es. Du kannst in diesem Money-Money quasi direkt in Lua in diese ganzen Innereien eingreifen. Crash Course Lua, was ist Lua? Lua ist eine Sprache, die genau dafür gemacht ist, in Programmen die interne API quasi fern zu bedienen.
Was ist hier deine letzte Sendung?
Hat meine letzte Sendung auch Lua? Genau, ja richtig. Reaper, Ultraschall, richtig genau. World of Warcraft macht Lua, viele Games machen Lua, Lua ist überall und ich glaube wir hatten Lua ja auch schon irgendwie mal da. Und ich hatte noch nie so richtig den Anreiz.
Ich kann mich an den Lua nicht erinnern, den wir schon mal da hatten.
Doch, wir hatten Lua auch schon mal an irgendeiner anderen Ebene. Hatten wir das auch schon mal da. Auf der Metaebene mindestens. Naja, auf jeden Fall, diese Sprache ist beherrschbar. Die ist wirklich super einfach zu erlernen und sie ist halt schnell und sie ist irgendwie sehr stringent. Und vor allem führt es immer dazu, dass Programme, die halt sich so in den Lua-Kern reinlenken, das sind so 120 Kilobyte Randtime, das ist sozusagen quasi nicht. Und dann hast du relativ klare Definitionen, wie du jetzt so deine internen C oder sonstige Datenstrukturen halt abbildet, also wie musst du Strings und Zahlen und Floats und so weiter und komplexe Datenstrukturen abbilden und dann definierst du halt deinen API und machst quasi die inneren Zugriffen. Und jetzt kannst du halt wirklich in diesen Export reingehen und lässt dich quasi aufrufen. Das heißt, der Export wird vom User-Interface aus angestoßen. Da taucht dann dein Export-Script als eine der Optionen auf und dann sind das einfach solche Callbacks in deinen Code rein und dann suchst du dir halt irgendwie mit dem API die Daten so zusammen und schreibst sie so zusammen, wie du sie haben willst. Und das hab ich irgendwie die letzten 24 Stunden damit verbracht, diesen ganzen Importer-Script-Kram, den ich vorher in der Buchhaltung gemacht habe, jetzt quasi in Money Money in Lua zu machen, wo ich mich nicht mit diesem komischen Visual Basic direkt rumschlagen muss. Und läuft. Und jetzt wird's richtig geil, weil jetzt muss Nibch nicht mehr die ganze Zeit Enter drücken, sondern im Idealfall, da ist noch ein bisschen Refinement nötig im Idealfall, kann ich jetzt irgendwie immer so zum Ende des Quartals, muss einfach zwischendurch nur jede Buchung, die so reinkommt, einmal in die richtige Kategorie reinschmeißen. Und dann sag ich einfach so Export und dann macht so und dann haut er sich irgendwie 5000 Records in die Buchhaltung und dann muss man noch ein bisschen nachbürsten und noch ein bisschen cammen. Und dann noch mal eine Schleife zu binden und dann war's das mit der Steuererklärung.
Steuererklärung.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich da nicht schon früher angefangen hab. Ja, vor allem man versteht dann langsam auch mal was. Und dann konnte ich auch endlich mal irgendwie so Sachen nachrechnen. Also ich meine, die Komplexität der ganzen Zahlungsvorgänge, das macht man sich ja manchmal gar nicht klar. Also was das alles so für Abhängigkeiten hat. Was man dann irgendwie so, ja, und du kriegst ja noch was von mir hier und dann da noch die Hälfte und hier ein Projekt aufteilen und da noch mal was erstatten und hier die Rechnung und dann hast du dann mal so ein Event und dann überlappt sich das irgendwie alles zeitlich.
Man kennt das ja.
Na, ich hab das jetzt zumindest. Also ich sag mal, bei Selbstständigen ist das jetzt durchaus der Fall. Und wenn man halt auch noch so die ganze Zeit so vernetzten Kram macht, mit allen möglichen Sachen, hier Logbook, Nespolit 200, solche Events, wo dann halt auch mal so kurzfristig viel Geld reinkommt und wieder rauskommt, weil er halt irgendwie Tickets und Miete bezahlt und tausend Geschichten und T-Shirts und dann Subscribe, auch solche Events, wo du irgendwie Catering hast und Fahrtkosten und Pipapo und irgendwann verlierst du einfach total den Überblick. Du checkst halt einfach gar nichts mehr. Aber wo wirklich dann der Moment der Wahrheit gekommen ist, das ist diese Buchhaltung. Weil da muss alles aufgehen. Wenn da nicht die Null, die Null muss stehen. Das ist wie beim Fußball eigentlich. Und wenn die Null da nicht steht, weißt du einfach, da ist noch was faul. Und dann forscht man so lange nach, bis man das gefunden hat und dann passt das. Das ist großartig. Ja, ich weiß, ist nicht so das sexy Thema für 23 Uhr, so Buchhalter. Das ist so ein bisschen wie bei Multi-Python. Ich möchte Löwenbändiger werden. Aber am Ende dann doch vielleicht nur Chartered Accountant.
Also doch, vielleicht überkommst du mich auch. Dann weiß ich, Freak Show Episode 196 wird mir weiterhelfen.
Vor allem möchte ich noch sehr viel mehr Programme sehen, die irgendwie diesen Lua-Krempel sich reinholen. Weil es gibt einfach so viele Programme, die eigentlich mit dem, was man so in ihnen zelebriert und zusammensammelt, so richtige Datenschätze sind. Und dann steht man immer da und kriegt diese Daten aber dann nicht in anderer Form raus, um damit vielleicht andere Modelle zu beflüttern.
Wurde Lua nicht genutzt für den Kongress? Irgendwas für den Kongress? Für die Darstellung auf dem Biemann? Das weiß ich nicht genau, weil wir hatten mal versucht mit Lua ein Projekt zu machen für die Republik, diese Faltplatt-Anzeige von vor 2 Jahren. Und ist dann aber glaube ich was anderes rausgeworden. Also eine andere Sprache, nicht Lua. Deswegen war ich jetzt irritiert, dass Lua gut ist mit Rechen und API Sachen. Ich hatte das mehr unter der Kategorie Grafik-Fu eingeordnet.
Lua ist tatsächlich explizit entwickelt worden, um so als Embedded-Sprache in komplexen Systemen zu sein. Das war so das Design-Game. Das heißt, sie wollten eine stabile Sprache machen, die auch einfach ist, die sich sehr schnell compilen und extrem schnell ausführen lässt. Also Lua ist auch einfach schnell. Das heißt, du hast da keinen großen Overhead mit dem ganzen Climb-In und die halt sich mehr oder weniger einheitlich in alles einbetten lässt. Und das ist eigentlich aufgegangen. Du findest sehr, sehr viele Programme. Und das ist halt auch gerade bei so komplexen Programmen, die halt wichtige Dinge tun, wo man aber normalerweise nur mit der Maus rumschubst und so weiter. Aber man weiß, eigentlich baut man jetzt total geile Datenstrukturen auf und will die halt auch mal anders haben als vom Programmierer gedacht. Und das ist dann genau der Moment, wo so ein scriptigen Interface greift. Und dieses Apple-Script, was Apple halt irgendwie seit Jahren irgendwie vor sich her geschoben hat, das ist halt einfach ein stinkendes Stück Scheiße. Also da kann man einfach nichts mit anfangen.
Ja, aber ich meine, Apple-Script ist das einzige, was Apple noch mehr vernachlässigt hat als den Mac Pro.
Ja, da ist was dran. Aber ich meine, dieser alte Apple-Script-Gruhe ist ja jetzt gegangen. Dafür haben sich jetzt irgendwie dieses Team von dieser Workflow-App eingetreten. Ich hoffe, dass das irgendwie Gutes bedeutet für die Zukunft.
Wenn Sie Apple-Script endlich mal aufgeben würden, dass...
Ja, aber gegen was?
Swift?
Wahrscheinlich dependen noch so viele Software auf Apple-Script.
Könnte sein, dass sie das machen.
Na ja, gut. Swift ist immer so eine inherent-kompilierte Sprache.
Naja, aber egal.
Halt dich so für ein Scripting-Workflow für ein bisschen Overkill, aber...
Wenn es einfach ist, eine einfache Syntax hat und du klare, definierte API-Sachen hast, warum nicht? Ich meine, die Sprache ist letztlich egal, sie muss nur sehr definiert sein. Ich hatte gerade auch heute so eine Diskussion, ob man denn da nicht JavaScript nehmen kann. Also was unterspezifizierteres kann man sich für diesen Fall eigentlich gar nicht suchen. Also die Übertragbarkeit.
Na PHP vielleicht noch.
Ja genau, so in der Kategorie. Also mit diesem ganzen Web-Wahnsinn, glaube ich, kommt man da nicht hin. Lua kommt halt von den Entwicklern, von Leuten, die diese ganze funktionale Programmierung und so weiter eher als Hintergrund hatten. Obwohl Lua jetzt keine funktionale Programmiersprache ist und die auch sonst viele Dinge nicht mitbringt, sondern eher einfach sagt, wir haben hier einen grundlegenden Datentyp, das sind die Tables und damit kriegt man schon irgendwie alles hin. So ein bisschen wie Erlang. Einfach nur deine Daten mal ordentlich aufräumen und gut iterieren können, gut kombinieren können, dann braucht man diesen ganzen Objekt-Quatsch einfach gar nicht. Alles viel zu kompliziert. Und Lua macht das halt mit Tables. Soviel zu dieser Thematik. Sollten Leute auch Lua begeistert sein und vielleicht auch mit Money Money Lust haben, da ein bisschen rum zu experimentieren, habe ich da immer gerne ansprechbar. Kommt da einfach mal hier in den Metaebene Slack zum Beispiel und dann kann man sich da...
wird Lua generdet.
wird Lua generdet und so weiter. Mir hat da heute auch schon ein Lua-Nerd im Slack schon einen schönen Back ausgemerzt. Und dann lief auf einmal.
Ha, Themen-Sprung. Jawohl, so ist es.
Für eine Woche, nee für neun Tage, habe ich mich entschlossen, kurzfristig in den schönsten Ort dieser Erde mit dem schönsten Wetter dieser Erde, Südengland. Haha, das ist ja ein bisschen ein bisschen unbekannt, weil wir die Hörer sicherlich wissen, gehe ich ja im Sommer immer gerne segeln und hatte mir letztes Jahr schon eine Grenzfest vorgenommen. Ich will diesen Segelschein jetzt mal machen, damit ich im Zweifel auch mal selber auf eigene Faust Boote leihen kann im ersten Schritt, um dann selber mal so Tours zu machen, Touren. Und ich habe mich ja, weiß nicht, ob ich das schon mal erzählt habe, aber ich wollte ja den britischen Segelschein machen, weil der sehr praxisorientiert ist im Gegensatz zu manch anderem, vor allen Dingen dem Deutschen. Also die deutschen Segelscheine, das jetzt überspitzt formuliert, aber die lassen dich wirklich einmal alle Verkehrszeichen auswendig lernen und das da alles. Und bevor du überhaupt das erstmal auf so ein Boot laufen kannst und gegen die Briten halt sagen, pass mal auf, das sind die wichtigsten Regeln, die du immer parat haben solltest und normalerweise macht man formlos von eh so seinen Plan, wo es hingehen soll. Und dann guckst du auf die Karte und wenn da irgendwelche Zeichen drauf sind, die du nicht kennst, guckst du halt formlos nach, was die bedeuten und schreibst dir das mit auf deinen Plan drauf, dass du da aufpassen sollst. Also es ist sehr viel pragmatischer und es geht auch sehr viel mehr ums praktische Segeln, weswegen der Schein oder deren Scheine von der Royal Yachting Association halt weltweit schon am anerkanntesten sind. Und dementsprechend will ich den auch. Und jetzt geht's los mit der ersten Stufe, dem sogenannten Dayskipper. Das heißt, da soll man dann nach Möglichkeit noch nicht nachts segeln, weil das nochmal so eine eigene Themenkarte ist quasi. Und ja, da bin ich jetzt neun Tage unterwegs. Im Schön in Südengland. Mit maximal beschissenen Wetterbedingungen. Aber der letzte Skipper meinte auch, bei der Holiday Tour, wenn man einen Schein macht, du kannst ja einen Schein auch Gibralter machen oder in Kroatien oder in Griechenland, überall wo es schön ist. Und der meinte aber, mach das mal in Südengland, weil da sind die beschissensten Bedingungen von allen. Da gibt es starke Ebbe und Flut, Strömung, Steine im Meer, schlechtes Wetter. Doppel in Southampton, wo wir segeln, da gibt es auch sogar eine Doppelflut und nur eine sehr kurze Ebbe, also auch keine regelmäßigen Zeiten. Und wenn man da segeln kann, dann kann man überall segeln. Sehr praktisch. Dementsprechend habe ich mal diesen Rat befolgt. Davon abgesehen, hatte ich eigentlich schon in der Freak Show hier, hatten wir da eigentlich Elisas Segelabenteuer 2017 schon mal angesprochen? Ich glaube ja, das ist dann auch noch Ende des Jahres, nicht Ende des Jahres, aber Ende des Sommers. Aber dann braucht man das ja nicht noch weiter besprechen.
Gibt es auch irgendwelche Fragen?
Dein Buchrechnungs-Software durchbrauen.
Nee, ich hab dir zugehört, ich hab mich nur gerade gefragt, also ich hatte mich auch schon gefragt, warum England, aber das ist sozusagen jetzt genau der Deal, dass man da A. Englisch sprechen kann, B dass man alle Widrigkeiten, die nur irgendwie möglich sind, dann vor die Nase kriegt. Das heißt, du wirst da so richtig durchgeschüttelt.
Ja, so jetzt um diese Jahreszeit ist es da jetzt auf jeden Fall auch nicht. Eitel Sonnenschein, so wie im Mittelmeer, eigentlich die meiste Zeit zum Beispiel, also da bin ich ja die ersten paar Male gesegelt. Aber wo ist denn das genau? Na, es geht so Southampton los und geht dann so an der Isle of Wight da so raus und genau wegen dieser Isle of Wight gibt's da auch so diese Doppelflut, weil irgendwie bei Ebbe nicht alles Wasser durch diese Insel da Blockade irgendwie rausfließen kann und dann, wenn wieder die Flut kommt, dann stalled das erst so in der Mitte und dann kommt noch immer Wasser hinterher und dann gibt's noch mal einen Anstieg sozusagen. Und die Ebbe ist nur sehr kurz sozusagen in diesem Gebiet. Genau, da hast du sie ja schon mitten auf dem Schirm. Da, wo diese kleine Insel ist unten. Genau, und da geht's los. Und dann so in dem Gebiet halt in etwa. Also sie haben jetzt nicht genau die Routen oder so. Ich glaube, wir werden da schon jeden Abend auch wieder in diesen Hafen da rein, weil es ja auch der Day Skipper ist und nicht der Month Skipper. Genau, und wie gesagt, eben diese Royal Yachting Association. Also du kannst halt die Scheine schon auch überall auf der Welt machen. Das geht auch. Und es gibt auch einige Leute, die ich schon so dazu mal interviewt hab, die das in Kroatien und so gemacht haben. Aber da gibt es zum Beispiel keine Gezeiten. Insofern hast du dann, ich glaube, du kannst dann eben nicht mit deinem Schein in Gezeitengewässern ein Boot charten, was dann irgendwie auch wieder doof ist.
Ähm, wie, da gibt es keine Gezeiten.
Mittelmeer?
Ach so, Mittelmeer.
Ja, Kroatien ist im Mittelmeer.
Nein, vollständig.
Echt, da gibt es keine Gezeiten.
Na ja, also durch diese Straße von Gibraltar, da kommt vergleichsweise wenig Wasser durch.
Das kann sich nicht verstehen.
Also sicherlich gibt es da auch leichte Effekte.
Aber kann man sich das überhaupt wie Führerschein vorstellen, dass du auch ein paar Stunden am Tag haben wirst, wo du ja in der Schule sitzt?
Das ist Theorie und Praxis zusammen. Deswegen auch neun Tage. Normalerweise geht es immer nur eine Woche. Du kriegst deinen Theorie-Einlauf an Bord. Dann wird aber auch direkt das am Gerät vorgeführt. Wie gesagt, ich hab mir schon ein paar Segel-Programme angeguckt, was andere Länder auch machen. Die britische Art ist schon die sympathischste, wenn man hands-on los zeigt, wie das geht. Ich bin auf jeden Fall sehr gespannt, wie das ablaufen wird. Vor allen Dingen war auch witzig dieser Skipper, mit dem Elisa schon ein paar Mal gesegelt ist und mit dem ich auch zweimal schon unterwegs war. Der macht das ja auch seit 20 Jahren oder so. Dann hat er mit mir gechattet und ich habe ihn auch noch mal gefragt und dann meinte er, ja das ist super, dass du das machst in Südengland. Dann meinte ich nur so, ja, aber ich bin immer noch sehr nervös, ob der An- und Ablege-Manöver. Das ist für mich immer noch der größte Horror eigentlich am Segeln. Segeln auf dem Wasser, das kriegt irgendwie jeder hin. Nach einer Weile weiß man einfach, ok, da kommt der Wind her, da muss das Segeln irgendwie, da muss dieser Wind in dieses Segeln und das kriegt man schon hin. Aber in diesen Hafen rein und raus, das ist halt erstens sehr eng, dann ist das das zweite Problem, je langsamer du fährst, desto schlechter steuert das Ding halt, weil du ja die Strömung am Ruder halt brauchst und wenn du nur ganz langsam fährst, dann kannst du halt nicht lenken. Dann ist das Ding halt ein paar Tonnen schwer, also, weiß nicht, zehn oder so, keine Ahnung, oder mehr. Das heißt, es hat auch ein gewisses Momentum und dann sind halt diese Boote da dicht an dicht und die kosten teilweise halt Millionen und Abermillionen. Das heißt, wenn du da einmal dich so richtig hart vertust, dann hast du gleich ein millionenschweres Problem bzw. deine Versicherung. Und du dann auch. Und ja, dann gibt es halt so gerade in gezeiten Gewässern, wenn es dann so Strömungen noch gibt und das Boot dann rein oder rausgedrückt wird oder der Wind dir noch einen Strich durch die Rechnung macht. Wir waren bei den letzten vier Trips, da gab es immer mal so ein Mariner oder eine Situation, wo es einfach scheiße war, da anzudocken und der Skipper, dem habe ich das dann so geschrieben, der meinte, ja, but don't worry, John, for me it's the same, even after 20 years. Und ich dachte mir so, sollte mich das jetzt irgendwie beruhigen? Also was war jetzt die Message?
Meistens geht es gut.
Also es sieht auch, er macht das auch, er hat das auch immer absolut perfekt irgendwie hinbekommen, aber ich bin mal gespannt, ob ich das nach diesen neun Tagen dann auch so in etwa hinbekomme.
Hast du da eine Limitierung von Schiffsgröße oder sowas, was du dann nicht mehr führen darfst?
Also gibt es da sowas? Ja, so 45 Fuß bzw. 13 Meter ist eigentlich immer so die Einsteigergrenze. Ich weiß allerdings nicht, ob bei den höheren Jachtmasterscheinen oder Yacht, wie das in Englisch dann vielleicht pronounced wird, ob es da anders ist, aber bei den deutschen Segescheinen hast du erstmal so 13 Meter. Und dann habe ich mir so irgendwie witzigerweise, nicht witzigerweise, aber ich habe mal so aus Interesse geschaut, sowas andere, was man auf YouTube zum Thema Dayskipper Segeschein findet. Und da habe ich eine komplett eigene Nische von YouTube-Kanälen gefunden. Also wieder so ein komplettes Subuniversum, wovon man keine Ahnung hatte, dass es existierte. Und dann klickt man auf ein Video und kriegt dann auf der nächsten Startseite irgendwie tausende Recommendations. Und man stellt fest, da gibt es einfach eine eigene Community, eine eigene Welt. Und das sind Aussteiger, die also auf dem Boot leben wollen. Paare in der Regel, die also ihren ganzen Besitzstand verkaufen. Dann auf Bootjagd gehen, das alles auf YouTube, also mit Video dokumentieren. Und dann auch alle ihre Abenteuer sozusagen, die sie dann auf diesem Boot erleben, verfilmen. Und davon gibt es unfassbar viele YouTube-Kanäle. Und einer besser produziert als der nächste, natürlich. Wo du echt so denkst, ich muss auch irgendwie auf einem Boot leben. Das ist wirklich... Natürlich, natürlich.
So ein bisschen Traumschiff für Arme.
Nee, es gibt auch... Ich hab wirklich nur so grob mal durchgebraust, weil so viel Zeit hab ich dann doch nicht. Aber da gab's auch schon natürlich Videos mit Drama und Tränen. Und wenn dann halt irgendwie der Mast dann doch gebrochen ist. Oder irgendwie so, weißt du? So ist es wirklich. Und jetzt noch der Abschluss-Knaller eigentlich für mich war, dann gab's so ein Video von britischen Pärchen. Und die erzählen auch alles schön. Und wie sie das so alles gemacht haben, haben sie ein Segelschein im Boot gekauft und hier und da hingeflogen. Und dann waren sie irgendwo in Griechenland. Und dann endet ihr Video damit so, ja, und dann sind da die Fischer, die dann ihre Leinen da ins Wasser werfen auf ganz spezielle Art. Und was machen die Briten dann? Sie sitzen dann da und singen quasi wie so ein Fußballfan bei jedem griechischen Fischer, der seine Leine reinwirft und machen so so typische Klischee, britischer Tourist besoffen auf dem Boot sitzen und rumgrillen, während die Einheimischen ihren Lebensunterhalt. Ich meine, das machen wir sicherlich auch andere Nationen, aber es war so das perfekte Touri-Klischee-Ende noch dieses Videos, aber das war nur eine Episode.
Ja, wer weiß, vielleicht machst du ja dann auch bald deine eigene Soap.
Oder trinkst auch Bier und grüllst, während andere fischen.
Also Bier hab ich auf den Segelbooten sicherlich das eine oder andere Mal getrunken, gegrüllt hab ich, glaub ich nicht. Also auf jeden Fall nehm ich euch dann auch alle, dann machen wir Freak Show on a Boat.
Oh ja bitte.
Der von euch wird sehr krank.
Hätte ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Aber es ist doch eh, du musst einfach nur was essen, meinte mein Vater. Man sollte nicht aufhören mit dem Essen und man soll irgendwie durchkommen.
Ich fürchte, dass man ohne Essen auch nicht richtig kotzen kann, oder?
Ja und ich wünschte, ich hätte ein Foto davon. Der Skipper, also Elisa kommt ja ursprünglich aus Polen und ihre Skipper-Freunde dementsprechend auch. Und er hatte letztes Jahr so ne Süßspeise. Es war so ähnlich wie Götterspeise, aber flüssiger. Und wird auch heiß serviert. Es war irgendwie so ein, so nicht Pudding, es war eher durchsichtig rote Farbe, gab es auch irgendwie einen anderen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die sowas Ähnliches auch haben wie in Schweden mit den heißen Suppen, mit den heißen süßen Suppen.
Und er meinte halt, das Gute an diesen, also er hat uns das alles so gezeigt und ob wir auch was wollen, wir so alle, sieht jetzt nicht so geil aus. Und er meinte, ja aber das ist das Coole an diesen, das Coole an diesen Sachen ist, das schmeckt rein genauso wie raus. Und wir auch wieder so, alle so, hm, weiß nicht, ob das jetzt ein cooles Video ist. Und eine, die letztes Mal mitgesiegelt ist, die hat das dann gegessen. Und der wurde dann bei stärkerem Wellengang auch schlecht und meinte dann irgendwie so, kannst du mal kurz das Steuer halten und hat sich kurz übergeben und ist dann wieder ans Steuer und setzte sich dann so dahin und meinte, it really tastes the same way in and out. Und fand das halt gut, weil sie halt nicht diesen Kotzgeschmack hatte, sondern so ein schön artificielles, süß speisendes Geschmäck, sozusagen.
Bitte mach dich schlau, was das war.
Ja, es hieß irgendwie so wie Kischel oder Kischel, irgendwie so ein polnischer Kischel-Laut. Ich guck mal gerade auf jeden Fall noch nach einem Artikel zum Thema Seekrankheit, der sehr interessant war, den möchte ich euch dann abschließend noch zu diesem Thema vielleicht posten, falls ihr nicht noch weitere Fragen habt. Weil das ist wirklich das größte Drama und ich würde auch gerne mal eine statistische Erhebung sehen, weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass tatsächlich überwiegend Frauen Seekrank- oder Seekrankheitsprobleme haben, weil immer wenn ich so in meinem Freundeskreis frage, auch so Pärchen oder so, Bock auf Segeln? Ja, aber die Dame kann dann meistens irgendwie nicht und ich weiß nicht, ob das nur in meiner Bubble so ist oder ob das irgendwie, ob das generelles Problem ist, aber ich hab echt Probleme immer da zum Beispiel Freundespaare mit aufs Boot zu nehmen, aus genau diesem Grund, was mich etwas nervt. Also du hast keine Ahnung, ob du es...
Keine Ahnung, würde ich ausprobieren.
Und wisst ihr das, ob ihr seekrank werdet?
Also ich bin noch nie ernsthaft seekrank geworden. Ich weiß nicht, einmal unter Deck, auf so einem kleineren Ferkan, auf relativ rauer See, dann nach oben musste und mal ein bisschen Horizont gucken und dann ging's auch wieder.
Genau, das ist eigentlich so auch meine Kategorie. Also wenn mir unter Deck so ein bisschen übel wird, dann Horizont und frische Luft hilft eigentlich immer. Also ich hab bisher noch nicht mich übergeben müssen.
Der Horizont ist ja eigentlich auch an der Stelle entscheidend, weil es ist ja diese Misskommunikation zwischen Auge und sonstigen Gefühlen, was dafür führt, dass du kotzt. Dir wird ja nicht im einlichen Sinne schlecht, sondern das Hirn meldet, dass eine Gleichung nicht richtig aufgelöst werden kann. Das hatte ich ja im, hab ich glaub ich schon erzählt, als ich im Kotzbomber war, also, als ich da meine... Vomit kommet. Wo ich quasi an dieser Kampagne mitgemacht habe. Und da ist es ja genau das Problem, dass dieser Druck, der auf dir lastet, wenn du dann, also wenn sozusagen das Flugzeug hoch geht, dann wird der Druck so stark bis 1,8 g, dass dein Gleichgewichtsorgan dadurch außer Kraft gesetzt wird, dass es halt einfach diese Härchen zusammen gedrückt werden. Weil mehr als 1 g kennt das System halt einfach nicht. Wenn du in dem Moment dann halt blöde herumschaust mit deinem Auge und dir dann mal alles anguckst, wie interessant das doch ist, dann kommt so das Hirn mit, Information, Gleichgewichtsorgan heißt, nichts bewegt sich, Auge sagt, alles bewegt sich, du bist vermutlich vergiftet. Und wenn du halt keinen Referenzpunkt ausmachst, der dir sagt, es ist irgendwie alles noch gleich und ich kann dieses Schaukeln in Bezug setzen zu einem Horizont, zu einer Linie, dann denkt der Körper halt nicht, ihm wäre übel. Es ist ja eigentlich nichts mit dir. Es ist ja eigentlich alles okay, ne?
Aber ich hab tatsächlich schon auf dem Boot Leute, die auch auf Deck gesessen haben und Horizont geguckt haben und so, denen wurde halt trotzdem auch schlecht. Das alleine hilft jetzt auch nicht.
Das alleine nicht, aber es hilft. Wie sensitiv du bist, das ist ja wahrscheinlich noch mal eine andere Geschichte.
Ich hab jetzt ja auch mal kurz einen Artikel noch gepostet zum Thema Sea Sickness, wo sie so Regatta Crews quasi mal beobachtet haben und wie da so die Verteilung ist und wie man sozusagen auch mit der Kommunikation und Vorbereitung und Umgang und Ansageton an die Crew und so auch das abmildern oder verstärken kann. Also zum Beispiel war glaube ich in dem Artikel so auf Crews, die nicht so eingespielt waren, wo der Skipper halt irgendwie schon so mit harter Hand, die da auch irgendwie hier und dahin geschrien hat, dass die jetzt mal dat und dat machen sollen, dass da die Leute sozusagen eher anfällig waren als auf anderen Bohnen. Der Artikel war auch ganz interessant zu dem Thema. Was wolltest du sagen?
Ich bin irgendwann mal mit einem größeren Schiff nach Helgoland gefahren und da war also auch ordentlich Tünung. Und wenn dann dieses, du hast das Schiff, das ist das Gefühl, dass das Schiff immer hinten aus dem Wasser rauskommt. Dann fährst du so durch diese Welle, so durch, einmal so, Bumm, bist dann oben und dann wird es kurzzeitig ein bisschen leichter. Das ist das Gefühl, jetzt festhalten, sonst fliegst du vom Setz weg. Und dann geht's wieder so, Bamm! Und das war, da bin ich so ein bisschen an die Grenzen gekommen, aber es ging auch gut.
Ich war auch zweimal schon an der Grenze, aber es hat noch geklappt.
Also ich bin auch nicht so ein Freund von Achterbahnen.
Ja, ich auch nicht, aber nicht wegen dem...
Ich glaube nicht, dass man das vergleichen kann, oder?
Ich sag nur, das was Roddy gerade beschrieben hat, diese Momente der temporären Schwerelosigkeit...
Der Luftfunk!
Dieser Luftfunk und was der Magen dann halt so macht, auch im Flugzeug, das ist nicht geil. Ich bin halt immer froh, dass es schnell wieder vorbei ist, aber so geil finde ich es nicht.
Also das ist aber auf dem Segelboot zumindest, weil man jetzt nicht auf dem offenen Atlantik ist oder gerade gegen den Wind. Portugals Küste hoch segelt, wie vorletztes Jahr ich das gemacht habe, dann hat man nicht so oft so diesen Moment, wo man so ganz über diese Wellen rüber geschießt.
Ich habe jetzt bisher geschult, da ist Skipper bald und man muss ja durch Wind und Wellen...
Der erfahrene Skipper meint zu diesem Thema Kotzen, dass jeder kotzt, früher oder später. Also er kennt niemanden, der nicht kotzt und auch ihm wird irgendwann in irgendeiner Situation schlecht und sei es nur unter Deck sitzen, Sturm aussitzen und irgendjemand anderes fängt an zu kotzen. Und dann gibt es halt Kettenreaktionen. Ob der Gerüche und so weiter. Liebe Hörer, ich hoffe, ihr kommt noch klar. Aber er wäre zu dem Punkt gelang, dass immer wenn ihm schlecht wird, dann versucht er einfach so schnell wie möglich zu kotzen, damit sozusagen das vorbei ist und dann er wieder klar sich auf seine Tätigkeiten konzentrieren kann, statt stundenlang so dazusitzen und dagegen anzukämpfen. Weil das wäre auf jeden Fall, das war immer meine Herangehensweise, dann auch so. Dann setze ich dann so hin und gucke so ganz fokussiert zum Horizont und tief einatmen. Und so ja, passt schon, passt schon, passt schon. Aber so richtig passt halt nicht. Und er meinte dann auch so, ja ich bin jetzt zu alt für den Scheiß. Ich gehe gleich zur Reling und dann ist es vorbei. Und dann kann ich weitermachen. Und dann fand ich auch wieder alter Seemann. Oder so alt ist er nicht, aber erfahrener Seemann. Gibt dann auch lieber nach. Oder weiß einfach, wie er am schnellsten wieder zur Produktivität findet. In solchen Situationen.
Ja, das ist ja auch das Geile am Kotzen, muss ich sagen. Also, es ist zwar so auf dem Weg dahin, ist das irgendwie immer alles so ein bisschen doof. Aber wenn es dann vorbei ist, ist ja auch gleich besser.
So ein reinigendes Gewitter, ne?
Aber nicht bei jedem unwohl sein Gefühl.
Es kommt drauf an, was es ist. Ich hatte mal einen Sonnenstich, der war extrem fies. Weil du hast ständig diesen Krampf im Magen, aber du kannst nicht kotzen. Ich hab irgendwann angefangen zu fressen, damit ich dann endlich mal kotze. Und dann wurd's auch einigermaßen...
Sonnenstich.
Ja, das war recht Spanien, das überschätzt. Mitten im Sommer war ein relativ heftiger Wind. Es war nicht super warm, aber die Sonne hat trotzdem runtergebrannt wie Sau. Dann hab ich einen ordentlichen Sonnenstich bekommen.
Das äußert sich in Übelkeit? Dann hatte ich wohl noch nie einen.
Du bist halt dann so... Ja, ich war nicht groß fertig oder so, aber der Bauch hat sich total zusammengekrampft. Und zwar irgendwie...
Ja, die eigentliche...
Nein, ich meinte Höhenkrankheit hat ich halt das Problem.
Höhenkrankheit gibt es auch noch. Ist das das gleiche?
Also ich musste kotzen, ja. Nee, nee, Höhenkrankheit ist das, wenn du auf zu großem, über zu hohem Meeresniveau bist. Dünne Luft. Dünne Luft, genau. Ist üblicherweise, wenn du auf Berge steigst. Aber da hast du es... Also wenn du hochsteigst, eigentlich eher nicht. Ich hatte das gehabt, als ich nach Quito geflogen bin, nach Ecuador, ist ja die zweithöchste Stadt in der Welt. Jedenfalls was Hauptstädte angeht. Und da bist du auf 2,8, 2,9 so dazwischen. Und kommst halt aus dem Flieger und denkst dir erst mal so, okay, ich bin halt nur durch und dann am nächsten Tag bist du komplett weggelädert und willst halt eigentlich nur pennen und kotzen die ganze Zeit. Und Coca-Tee trinken. Ja, das ist so das Heilmittel in...
Hilf gegen alles.
Hilf gegen alles kann man immer trinken, genau. Alles ist auch nicht so schön.
Gut, die eigentliche Frage ist, wie kommen wir jetzt von diesem Thema wieder auf ein anderes Thema, mit dem man die Sendung dann doch irgendwie...
Mit einem harten Cut, wie immer.
Mit einem galanten, harten Cut.
Meinst du einfach so Schluss jetzt oder...
Kannst auch den klassischen haben wir noch demen Frage.
Ist ja alles jetzt so...
Spendenmodell-Thema nochmal aufrufen.
Da steht noch was von APFS.
Ich wollte ja noch einen Link schicken, ich suche den schon mal raus.
Vielleicht ein Projekt, auf das ich gestoßen bin, von dem ich keine Ahnung habe, ob es irgendwie sinnvoll ist, aber ich fand die Idee einfach cool. So aus der Abteilung. Geile Ideen, die manche Leute haben und darauf viel Zeit verwenden, um andere Leute davon zu überzeugen, dass es doch eine wirklich geile Idee ist. Man müsste es unbedingt mal machen, aber wir wissen nicht, ob es jemals geschehen wird, aber der Gedanke ist schon geil genug. Dieses Projekt heißt Endless Runway. Und das ist ein Konzept, was sozusagen mit dem Umstand versucht, da Lösungen zu finden, mit dem Umstand, dass wir immer mehr und immer größere Flughäfen haben, die immer mehr Landebahnen haben und von daher immer mehr Platz brauchen. Und in gewisser Hinsicht auch nicht unbedingt so optimal ausgelastet sind. Und jetzt gibt es so eine holländische Truppe, die ernsthaft vorschlägt, einen Flughafen zu bauen, der nur noch eine einzige Runway hat, die aber im Kreis angeordnet ist. Und die meinen das total ernst. Und wenn man sich irgendwie dieses Bild anschaut...
Und dann starten die auch in der Runde oder was?
Jaja, und zwar gleichzeitig. Also sie sind der Meinung, dass...
Kreisverkehr funktioniert auch in der Luft.
Naja, also das Ding ist...
Man kann auch nicht im Kreis starten und landen.
Doch! Also, naja, was weiß ich? Ich bin kein Pilot und schon gar kein Flughafeningenieur und als Berliner kann man sich da ja ohnehin nicht hervortun.
Bist du sicher, dass der Artikel nicht vom 1.
Nein, nein, das ist alles ernst gemeint. Da gibt es irgendwie auch einen BBC-Bericht darüber. Die meinen das irgendwie ernst. Und die Idee ist halt, du baust halt die Runway im Kreis und zwar halt wie so eine Rennbahn, leicht geneigt, sodass eben die Flugzeuge da Speed machen können, ohne halt einen seitlichen Drift zu haben. Also wie so eine Rennkurve. Und das Ding hat irgendwie dreieinhalb Kilometer Durchmesser. Nee, was war das? Ich kriege die Zahl jetzt gerade nicht mehr so ganz auf den Zeiger. Ich war ziemlich groß.
Also ich weiß, vom Münchener Flughafen, da sind die Start- und Landebahnen jeweils vier Kilometer.
Genau, es ist etwas kürzer als, also im Durchmesser etwas kürzer als jetzt eine einzige Runway. Aber dadurch, dass die halt nebeneinander und im Idealfall ja auch noch versetzt zueinander sind, damit du eben verschiedene Windrichtungen machen kannst. Also wenn der Wind sich dreht, dann muss er immer irgendwie gegen den Wind starten.
Das Luftfahrtbundesamt hat da bestimmt nichts dagegen.
Das ist zum Beispiel einer dieser Clues. Du kannst halt in einer runden Runway den Ort, wo der Wind von vorne kommt, ja sozusagen immer erreichen. Also du kannst sozusagen immer gegen den Wind starten, was optimal ist, um irgendwie schnell abzuheben und wo du halt dann auch weniger Anlauf brauchst. Und du kannst halt auch eigentlich überall landen. Und da wo du landest, kannst du halt in diesem Konzept, weil der Flughafen ist ja in diesem Kreis und hat überall Abfahrten, kannst halt landen und kannst halt immer sofort abfahren. Auf den Mittelkreis gehen und da dann zu deinem Terminal fahren.
Und sollen da jetzt gleichzeitig Flugzeuge landen?
Jaja, sie meint, dass sie da irgendwie quasi die Last von drei Runways auf einer Runway haben. Also der Flughafen soll so funktionieren wie ein Flughafen mit drei großen Runways. Weil sie halt gleichzeitig starten und landen können. Es gibt auch Leute, die wohl der Meinung sind, das wäre ein totaler Rezept für eine Katastrophe und es würde ja niemals funktionieren.
Naja, sagen wir mal so. Auf einer geraden Landebahn machst du es auch nicht so, dass du gleichzeitig startest und landest. Du hast da immer ein paar Zeitlöschende. Du hast da immer Abstände dazwischen. Und du würdest es auch gar nicht zugelassen kriegen, eine Landebahn mit mehreren Flugzeugen gleichzeitig zu benutzen. Also das halte ich für völlig unsinnig. Also die Idee, dass man aus jedem Winkel das Ding anfliegen kann, die ist eigentlich ganz cool. Zumindest gibt es bestimmte Orte in der Welt, wo er eben das viel bringt. In Mitteleuropa eher nicht so, weil der Wind halt immer aus Südwest kommt. Aber, naja.
Aber würde ein Problem ersparen, nämlich werden ja Landebahnen mit ihren Gradzahlen gekennzeichnet. Und da ja das Magnetfeld der Erde sich dauernd ändert, werden die jedes Jahr neu ausgemessen werden, wo jetzt der magnetische Kompass quasi diese Landebahn sieht. Und das könnte man sich da auch komplett sparen.
Ein unglaubliches Fahrpotenzial. Die Anordnung der Terminals ist halt auch ganz cool. Du hast einfach viel optimalere Verkehrswege. Hier in diesem Konzept gibt es hier gerade mal so einen Tunnel für die Autobahnzufahrt und Bahnzufahrt, die einfach da drunter geht. Und ansonsten ist halt einfach abgesehen davon, dass du so ein bisschen Platz noch links und rechts von der Runway brauchst. Danach geht es dann halt irgendwie weiter. Und angeblich soll das dann irgendwie auch noch dazu führen, dass es leiser ist und überhaupt ist es alles total toll. Ja, wollte ich mal so erwägen. Aber die sehen das halt ernsthaft so an, dass man da irgendwie mit mehreren Flugzeugen gleichzeitig starten und landen kann. Alles eine Frage der Optimierung.
Na ja, gut, aber du hast halt im zivilen Luftpfad sehr hohe Sicherheits-Margins.
Na ja, das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass das jetzt irgendwie morgen gleich startet.
Nee, nee, nee.
Sondern sie zeigen jetzt halt erst mal dieses Konzept. Also sie sagen halt, warum denken wir die Sache nicht einfach mal anders? Und das finde ich halt an sich schon mal relativ bemerkenswert, dass man sich eben über solche Sachen halt ernsthaft Gedanken macht. Na ja, das ist halt so Argumente. Dadurch, dass du halt den Anflug optimieren kannst, dass du halt einfach weniger Sprit und Lärm erzeugst, weil du halt immer optimal starten kannst. Tja, habe ich mal so gefunden im Internet und ein bisschen bestaunt und dachte mir, das interessiert euch doch bestimmt.
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall eine niedliche Idee, aber na ja, mal gucken.
Das kommt ja in diesem Video auch vor, mit diesen Crosswind-Landings, wenn du mal so im Video auf YouTube mal so... Das ist jetzt für erfahrene Piloten auch gar nicht so das Ding. Kann ich mir auch ganz gut vorstellen, dass man das irgendwie ganz gut rauskriegt.
Es kommt immer darauf an, wie bürg der Wind ist.
Bist du mal in so einer kleinen Cessna mitgeflogen? Ich hab das mal gemacht.
Ich bin mal im Segelflieger mitgeflogen.
Ich auf dem vorletzten Camp in Phinnofort mit Björn.
Genau, mit Björn. War ich nämlich auch. Und das ist schon eine Weile her. Aber ich hatte vorher immer so in normalen Verkehrsflügen, ich will nicht sagen Schiss, aber so richtig Geheuer, war mir diese ganze Start- und Landerei irgendwie auch nicht. Also fliegen, ja okay. Aber der Gedanke einfach mit so höllisch viel Schwerm, Scheiß, sich den Erde zu nähern und dann da drauf zu fallen, hat irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Und dann bin ich irgendwie mit Björn da in die Cessna gekrabbelt und dann sind wir da halt irgendwie auf so einem völlig irren Acker irgendwie gestartet. Es hatte so ein bisschen was wie Albatros Airlines. Das war ja noch nicht mal so eine richtige Runway. Ich dachte mir so, ja wo ist denn hier die Landebahn? Ja hier, ja Wiese. Das war halt so eine Wiese. Und dann ockelt halt dieses Teil los und wenn du halt in so einer kleinen Cessna sitzt, dann verstehst du überhaupt erst, warum man das auch Luftschiff nennt. Also so diese...
Luftschiff ist aber was anderes. Wenn ich das mal so sagen darf als jemand, der mal für ein Luftschiff in der Lage arbeitet.
Es ist Luftschifffahrt. Was ich meine ist, ja egal, dieses Konzept, dass man sich in so einer Masse bewegt, also was ein Boot macht und diese ganzen Dynamiken von Strudeln und Wasser und so weiter, das kriegt man halt hin, weil es nass ist und das sieht man. Luft sieht man halt nicht. Und in dem Moment, wo ich in dieser Cessna gestartet bin, habe ich so richtig diese Kräfte irgendwie gespürt, weil das reißt halt irgendwie so an deinem Ding. Und eigentlich ist das ganz einfach. Du drehst das Teil halt einfach so, dass es gegen den Wind geht und fliegst einfach los und dann geht das hoch. Und du schwimmst in dieser Luft so. Und auch beim Landen war das irgendwie genau das gleiche.
Dann kann ich dir auf jeden Fall fehlen, auch mal in so einen Segelflieger reinzusteigen, weil das ist dann nochmal... .nochmal plus plus davon, weil du dann halt auch nicht dieses Gebrabbel von dem Motor hörst, sondern wirklich das Gefühl hast, so du bist jetzt so bei jeder Sache dabei. Aber eine Sache, die mich oder eine Erinnerung, die ich an diese Cessna oder Cessna wie auch immer hatte, dein Golf 2. Und zwar jetzt nicht, weil die so außerfarblich oder so, aber so diese angelaufenen Amaturen wieder, weißt du, das war ja nicht ein niegelnagelneues Fabrik, neues Modell, sondern die hatte ja auch schon ihre, was nicht, 20, 30 Jahre auf dem Buckel, diese Maschine, mit der Björn da ankam. Und so dieses Einsteigen und irgendwie dachte ich so, das sieht aus wie ein alter Golf 2, so die Armaturen, alles so angelaufen, angekrabbelt irgendwie, aber es läuft halt. Wie so ein alter Golf 2. Kriegst du nicht kaputt, das Ding. Oder auch so wie die Tür so zuschnappte.
Das Ding wird ja auch schon seit Ewigkeiten gebaut in dieser Form und ist halt in gewisser Hinsicht perfekt.
Aber zu den Crosswinds nochmal. Warst du mal auf dem Flugfeld in Adlershof? Hast du das mal gesehen? Ja, das ist seit langem nicht mehr in Betrieb. Aber da sieht man noch sehr schön, wie früher die Flugfelder gebaut wurden. Da hattest du nämlich eine runde Fläche. Und am Rand der runden Fläche hattest du ein paar...
Also das gibt es noch, das Flugfeld.
Ja, so ein paar Teerflächen. Und was du dann machst, ist du fliegst halt an und setzt auf der Teerfläche auf und rollst dann auf der Wiese aus. Wenn du dir das Tempelhoferfeld anguckst, da siehst du auch an einigen Ecken auch noch diese Einbuchtungen, die Aufsätzeinbuchtungen, die man wahrscheinlich damals auch früher verwendet hat, um eben in einer bestimmten Richtung auf dem Feld zu landen. Oh Gott, frag mich Dinge.
Sicher, dass da nicht schon alles zugebaut ist?
Da, das da könnte es sein. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Aber du kannst es auch auf dem Tempelhofer Feld angucken. Da sieht man die auch, diese Einbuchtungen. Also hier, da die unteren, die beiden Dinger. Da fliegst du dann so von Süden an, setzt auf diese Ausbuchtung auf und kannst dann über die Wiese ausrollen. Das war früher relativ üblich. Da bist du halt nicht in der Kurve gelandet. Also in der Kurve landen finde ich jetzt auch ein bisschen.
Wie in der Ausbuchtung ist das ja richtig so eine Beule, oder was? Ist das so ein Loch?
Ja, so Teerplatten, gepflastert, genau. Damit du an der Stelle, wo die Flugzeuge immer aufsetzen, halt einen besseren Belag hast, der sich nicht so schnell abnutzt. Aber danach reicht halt der Rasen. Genau.
Deswegen gibt es diese Onkel an verschiedenen Stellen.
Genau, genau. Insofern, dass man immer gegen den Wind startet oder landet, ist jetzt keine neue Erfindung. Das will man eigentlich immer haben. Nur mit so einer großen Passagiermaschine als eine 747 kannst du natürlich nicht auf so einem Ding aufsetzen und dann auf einer Wiese ausrollen lassen. Das würde ich dann eher lassen. Zumindest machst du dir, glaube ich, relativ schnell die Wiese kaputt.
Und das Flugzeug vermutlich auch.
Und das ganze Ding zu teeren, ist vielleicht dann auch ein bisschen übertrieben.
Freunde des gepflickten Diskussionskanals. Ich glaube, wir sind durch.
Habt ihr eure Beef Jerky-Tüte alle bekommen?
Leergefressen. Hier ist noch ein bisschen was. Das ist das, was ich noch nicht hatte.
Ist auch tatsächlich leckerer geworden.
Ach so, leckerer, jetzt wo es alle ist sozusagen. Weiß nicht, gibt es noch irgendwelche Termine oder so? Die wir ankündigen sollten.
Nur den Ausspieler-Song, den ich dir jetzt schon per Link geschickt habe.
Ostern ist jetzt nächstes Wochenende für die, die es noch nicht mitgekriegt haben.
Also heute, also morgen.
Für mich ist auch das nächste Wochenende das nächste, kommende, aber für viele Leute ist das nächste Wochenende das dann in der Woche drauf, komischerweise. Aber das sind Detailfragen, die wir heute nicht mehr wissen.
Er hat nach Terminen gefragt. Ich hatte einen Termin.
Ich gehe segeln, ich habe über meinen Termin auch schon gesprochen.
Ich gehe zum Fußball.
Das überlege ich noch, ich will mein Fahrrad mal reparieren.
Finde ich übrigens auch geil. Es gibt auf YouTube mittlerweile so viele Videos, ich gehe überhaupt nicht mehr in den Fahrradladen. Es gibt alles so perfekt erklärt. Bremsen wechseln hätte ich früher nie selber gemacht. People Popel einfach, kriegt man wunderbar erklärt.
Eine Kleinigkeit zum Thema Luftfahrt, wo ich es gerade sehe, in der Liste bei YouTube. Nächstes Video. Der Remote-Controlled KFC Bucket Airplane mit dem Magnus-Effekt. Das ist ein geiles Video, das kann man sich mal angucken. Da baut jemand ein Flugzeug, das rotierende KFC-Becher als Tragflächen hat. Dadurch, dass sie rotieren, ist die Strömung so, dass sich ein Auftrieb ergibt. Er hat diverse Versionen dieses Dings durch, bis er es dann tatsächlich zum Fliegen gebracht hat. Aber es ist ein sehr lustiges Video, kann ich empfehlen.
Dann...
Haben wir das auch noch in die Show Notes?
Wo wir noch Luft...
Das sind nicht die Show Notes.
Naja, ist ja auch schon spät. Also, dann wünschen wir euch noch viel Spaß. Schöne Bilder.
Nein, ich bin Robert Skopin.
Eine Schornsteinmatte?
Ihr wollt doch eine Waldschneise. Ist doch aber auch schön. Legen Sie sich einfach auf den Schornstein, dann machen Sie sich nicht zu schmutzig.
Ach so, und ist ja auch dann viel bequemer, ne?
Und ich trottelwollt eine Waldschneise. Eckschmeiß ist meine Umweltpumpe, alle Gersen mein Möwchen.
Um welch Schutz handelt es sich denn?